Ungarn! Ungarn kann jetzt mit Island zusammen so ein neues Island-Ungarn oder Ungarn-Island aufmachen. Wär ja schön gewesen, wenn Österreich mit Ungarn zusammen aufgestiegen wäre, also was aufgestiegen weiter gekommen wäre. Es ist Fußball-Europameisterschaft, ihr merkt es schon, sogar hier in der Freak Show. Es geht ja immer so, die Kunde, dass so Nerds mit Fußball gar nicht klarkommen.
Ist auch mit vielen Nerds so.
Ja, aber du gehörst nicht dazu.
Ich spiele keinen Fußball, ich gucke keine Bundesliga, ich muss immer mir erklären lassen, was Champion Leagues ist und wer da spielt und so. Aber wenn es Turniere sind, vor allem mit K.O.-Systemen, bin ich immer vorne mit dabei.
Das ist immer ein Event-Fan.
Das Event ist mir auch egal, sondern ich brauche das KO., ich brauche vorhin den Ronaldo, der da kurz vor dem Platzen ist, sonst macht mir das keinen Spaß. Hatten wir doch schon mal hier nicht den Alos, sondern ganz früher, der da auf dem Spielplatz den Elfmeter verschießt und dann heulen musste. Das war nicht Alos, das war ein anderer, haben sie mich korrigiert.
Da haben schon so einige geholt, ich weiß es nicht.
Und das ist, dann macht mir Fußball Spaß, wenn ich sehe, da geht es um was, die sind alle mit dabei, die Emotionen sind hoch und so, dann kann ich sogar Tennis gucken, ist mir alles egal.
Okay, verstehe ich. Und du Roddi?
Ja, ich bin auch Event-Fan.
Was ich nicht leiden kann, ist Public Viewing so. Oder Leute, die da quatschen und alles besser wissen, das ist nicht so meins. Das mache ich lieber selber. Nee, aber eigentlich gucke ich Fußball dann so in Ruhe irgendwie.
Also Public Viewing bis, sagen wir mal, 30, 40 Leute mehr dann auch nicht.
Nee, um Gottes Willen.
So in so einer gemütlichen Kneipe draußen, das ist okay.
Und ich wohne ja da beim Brandenburger Turm, die Ecke, das heißt, das ist auch einer meiner Einflugs-Schneisen, so mit meinem Motorrad, ja. Und jetzt ist das da gesperrt, da kriege ich immer so einen Hals. Das geht gar nicht, weil ich musste immer Riesenkreise fahren. Weil wenn ich von außerhalb komme, da steht Berlin 50 Kilometer. Wenn ich nach Hause fahre, dann sind es genau 50 Kilometer, weil ich genau da wohne, wo Berlin Mitte ist.
Ja, ich kenne das, ich habe da ja auch mal gewohnt. Ja, aber ich habe auch immer ein gewisses Verständnis für so Sachen. Also die 100. Bauern-Demo, die geht einem dann immer so ordentlich auf den Senke irgendwie. Ihr mit euren scheiß Treckern. Aber ich meine, das ist halt nur mal der Ort, wo sie alle hinwollen, um ihre Anliegen zu verteidigen, auf der einen Seite, und auch ihre Partys zu feiern, auf der anderen Seite. Also muss man auch verstehen. Dafür hast du halt den Luxus des Zentrums.
Was ich letztens hatte, bin ich mit meinem Motorrad gefahren, da musste wegen so einer fucking Demo eine halbe Stunde in der Ampel stehen, weil erst die Demo vorbei ist. Und jetzt raten wir mal, was das für eine Demo war. Eine Motorradfahrer-Demo! Kein Witz, da haben die da irgendwie Motorradfahren auch ohne Gewalt oder irgendwie so wegen irgendwelchen Biker-Gangs, keine Ahnung. Da stand ich eine halbe Stunde und musste warten, bis die Tausenden von Motorradfahrern alle vorbei sind. Okay, aber jetzt zu den eigentlichen Themen.
Genau, wir sind nämlich hier...
Fußball!
Ja, früher noch Fußball.
Also Island ist jetzt im Achtelfinal, wir gratulieren der Nation. Da geht bestimmt gerade die Post so richtig ab, oder?
Bestimmt, bestimmt.
Ich find das ja so lustig, diese Schätzung, wie viele Islander sich gerade in Frankreich befinden.
Nämlich ungefähr zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung des Landes.
Da müsste voll leer sein, da oben auf der Insel.
Na, da ist eh leer, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch... ob das jetzt so groß auffällt. Aber naja, so ist das auf jeden Fall. So ist das auf jeden Fall. Wir wollten eigentlich nicht so über Fußball reden, aber...
Das hat sich jetzt irgendwie so ergeben.
Ja, ne. Ich bin ja auch... Wie bin ich denn da eigentlich?
Schmerzbefreit.
Na, erstens... Also ich kann wahrscheinlich Fußball noch ein bisschen mehr abgewinnen als ihr so. Im Default.
Was, noch mehr? Ja, ich weiß. Kannste bestimmt.
Ich hab Dauerkartaladen. Und fand aber auch schon immer so diesen Reiz von diesen Großereignissen eigentlich auch ganz geil. Also ich finde überhaupt so Welterreignisse vollkommen legitim. Ich mag das, wenn so der ganze Planet sich so um so ein Lagerfeuer scharrt. Ich meine, das ist natürlich immer sehr einfach. Und so die kleinen Eliten, die quäckten immer rum. So ESC ist auch so ein Beispiel. Europien Song Contest.
Ja, ich muss sagen, da bringe ich selten irgendwie die Schmerzbefreiheit auf, mir das tatsächlich anzugucken, weil die Musik beim ESC ist einfach jenseits meiner Liege, was ich vertragen kann.
Also der letzte ESC war wirklich, wirklich, wirklich sehr unterhaltsam. Also ich habe selten so gelacht und es war wirklich komisch. Von der Moderation her einfach grandios. Und den Show einlagen dazwischen, also wirklich fantastisch, auch mega selbstreflexiv. Und ich muss auch sagen, dass ich... Also es ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so die Musik, wo ich jetzt irgendwie im Internet nachkugeln würde oder so. Aber das ist ja auch was anderes. Also das ist ja sozusagen wie so EM halt. Es geht ja auch um Qualifikation und Sieg und so. Und man versucht halt irgendwie eine Darbietung zu bringen, die jetzt irgendwie ankommt. Und das ist natürlich sehr schwierig, wenn du jetzt nichts offensichtlich Zählbares hast, wie so Tore, sondern das Ganze eben einfach so über die Qualität kommen muss. Und da sind wir dann auch gleich bei der WWDC. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch so ein Ereignis, wo es jetzt auch keine klaren Tore gibt. So ist ja jetzt nicht so, ja, hier iOS 10, Release, so 5 Punkte oder so.
Air Force One in der 30. Minute.
Ja, also das bedarf ja auch immer der Interpretation und der Gewogenheit und danach ist die Jury ja auch da. Und sie ist mittlerweile auch weltweit. Also ich würde sagen, die WWDC ist auf jeden Fall so auf dem Weg von einer EM und eines europäischen Songcontests, eben auch so ein Lagerfeuerding zu sein. Es erreicht jetzt noch nicht alle, aber es erreicht verdammt viele. Haben die irgendwelche Zahlen gesagt, wie viele Leute da zuhören? Es sind Zahlen gefallen, aber ich hab sie mir nicht gemerkt. Habt ihr irgendeine Vorstellung?
Nee, ich weiß nur, dass immer so 5000 Leute Karten kriegen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine natürlich im Stream.
Aber war das schon vor vielen vielen Jahren, wo sie mal gemeint haben, da sind 50.000 Leute das zuhören? Das ist schon ewig her.
50.000, na ich denke mal, dass unter einer Million Streaming Endpoints wird das sicherlich nicht abgehört haben.
Ja, dann ist das schon lange her.
Aber ich kann mir jetzt schlecht so einen Oliver Pocher irgendwie beim ZDF vorstellen, der jetzt irgendwie die WWDC-Nachbesprechung macht zusammen mit diesen anderen drei Clowns da.
Nee, aber in neuen Medien. Also wir setzen uns jetzt gerade ein paar Stunden zusammen und kommentieren das. Andere Podcasts haben es vor uns getan. Weitere werden es nach uns tun. Du wirst tonnenweise auf YouTube irgendwelche Shows, wo alte Herren rum sitzen mit dicken Bäuchen und irgendwie das Wohl und Wehe einer Designänderung in iOS 10.
Gut, dass wir kein Video haben. Das sieht man, die dicken Bäuchen.
Gibt es das Bits und so eigentlich noch?
Ja, sicher.
Wie macht der Dominik das?
Der Dominik?
Der andere.
Timo.
Timo Hetzel.
Ach, das waren die, die Quatschern. Genau, die meine ich gar nicht. Ich meine die Fanboys.
Ich hab die Sendung zur WWDC nicht gehört, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass es auch eine gibt, die das reflektiert.
Die machen das auch noch.
Jaja.
Weil er ist ja jetzt immer drüben. Die machen das auch noch.
Zur Erklärung für unsere Hörer. Denis hört ja keine Podcasts. Und weiß eigentlich nicht Bescheid.
Korrekt. Ich will immer sehr unvoreingenommen in die Sendung gehen. Deswegen mach ich das.
Ja, es gibt ohne Ende. Also unsere Sendung könntest du ja schon mal hören, wenn du mal nicht da bist.
Ja, dann werd ich ja auch voreingenommen.
Bist du eh.
Ach, deshalb. Du hörst auch weg, wenn du nichts sagst.
Aber für die Continuity der Sendung wäre das manchmal ganz hilfreich.
Ja, ich kann ja auch mal die Klappe halten.
Wozu haben wir ihn previously?
Du musst ja dann auch die Klappe halten, aber du kannst ja zumindest mal zuhören, was wir sonst so...
Was interessiert denn jetzt, was wir in der letzten Sendung hatten?
Na ja, Feedback könntest du zum Beispiel geben. Du könntest dir über das, was wir gesagt haben, Gedanken machen und sagen, ja hier, hör mal, ihr habt ja wieder über Bitcoin dummes Zeug geredet oder so.
Glaubt er nicht.
Also, wenn man unseren Kommentatoren glauben darf, liegen wir schon das eine oder andere Mal im grenzwertigen Bereich.
Ja, ein bisschen provozieren in einer Sendung ist schon gut, weil dann kommen die Kommentatoren und sagen, wie es richtig ist, und da können die Hörer das dann nachlesen.
Klar, wir machen ja nie was falsch, weil wir sagen ja immer nur bewusst Sachen mit schwarzen Wahrheitsgehalt, um einfach Community-Feedback auszulösen.
Wir spielen und der, wie soll ich sagen, verteilte Schiedsrichter chat.
Sag das mit Fußball. Wir geben ihnen Räume, damit sich das Spiel auflockert und dass wir dann im richtigen Moment kontern können, um den entsprechenden Siegtreffer zu platzieren.
Alter.
Das ist das Schöne an Fußball. Mit Fußball kann man eigentlich alles wunderbar beschreiben. Also vor allem auch so soziale Dynamiken von Gruppen. Kriegst du einfach mit so einem Fußballspiel nicht nur gut beschrieben. Nein. Die Leute verstehen dich dann auch. Also jetzt außer den Nerds natürlich.
Doch, die verstehen das schon auch. Die wollen nur nicht.
Na die verstehen, sagen wir mal. Na ja, also wenn du jetzt... Wie weit versteht ein Nerd Fußballspielanspielung? Also Abseits könnte man vielleicht noch bringen. So Alter, du bist jetzt hier voll im Abseits.
Ja, aber ich meine, sagen wir so Sachen wie die Klinke ist rund und eine Sendung dauert 90 Minuten?
Das stimmt ja nicht.
Vier Stunden dauert es.
Vier Stunden. Okay, aber zurück zu WWDC.
Ach, ich weiß nicht. Also das Einzige, was eigentlich cool war, ich hab ja die WWDC auf dem Apple TV geguckt. Livestream direkt auf dem Apple TV. Das hat irgendwie Spaß gemacht. Also zumindest in den Noten.
Aber was ist anders, als wenn ich das hier im Browser öffne? Nicht deine Quality besser oder kannst du besser hin und her springen?
Nö, ich hab seit Monaten das Apple TV mal wieder verwendet.
Aber du meinst jetzt so ein Alters, oder?
Nee, ich hab ja das Aktuelle. Das haben mir jetzt die Developer für einen Euro übergeholfen.
Ja, wollen wir mal ein bisschen einsteigen? Also vielleicht für alle Leute, die komplett in Dampstein geschlafen haben, abgesehen, dass die Fußball-Europameisterschaft der Herren gerade läuft.
Das hieß Platform State of the Union.
Die Leute sehen nicht, was hier auf dem Beamer ist.
Ja, aber ich? Du wolltest, dass ich mich mehr einbringe?
Aber doch nicht so!
Aber doch nicht so! Ja, wenn man ein Setup immer so ein leichtes Raunen einspielen könnte, immer wenn so die Facepalm-Quote bei 5% plus liegt.
So ein Facepalm ist ja geräuschlos.
Das ist übrigens ein Punkt, wo ich... Ich bin ja ein großer Freund, ihr wisst ja, der Innovation. Und ich freue mich ja davon, dass wir es irgendwie schaffen, hier unsere Live-Sendung auch so ein bisschen mehr zu verquicken mit unserer Community. Wir haben ja unseren Chat jetzt hier in der Mitterebene-Community im Slack. Da ist auch schon wieder einiges los. Und Leute fordern einen Videostream, geht weg. Das werden wir nicht tun.
Wir können die Kamera ja aus dem Fenster raushalten.
Das ist einfach... Nee, wirklich, bleibt mir weg mit Kameras. Das won't happen. Nee, aber stellen wir vor, man hätte jetzt tatsächlich so... Jeder hätte so auf seinem iOS-Device so eine passende App. Es gab ähnliche Ansätze, im Übrigen auch schon mal in einer Podcast-Landschaft. Bei Bits und so wurde sowas schon mal live ausprobiert. Aber ich denke jetzt sozusagen über so ein generelles Feedback-System. Ich weiß, und da gab es auch schon mal ähnliche Sachen mit irgendwie das ist jetzt gut oder schlecht, aber sowas würde ich halt nicht machen. Wir brauchen mehr so akustische Emojis. Also wenn halt sozusagen die Leute der Meinung sind, das war jetzt einfach mal total facepalm-mäßig in diesem Moment, müsste halt eine Software in der Lage sein, das entsprechende Feedback der Leute einzusammeln. Also so wie wir ja hier die V-Mode in der Hand haben, um hier so nützliche Dinge wie Mikrofon ausschalten.
Ja, aber dazu sind sie halt sekundenmäßig zu verzögert. Das müsste schon sehr, sehr instant sein.
Na selbstverständlich müsste das sehr instant sein. Das heißt, man muss halt erstmal an den Stream ran. Darüber haben wir ja nun auch in den letzten Sendungen hier schon diskutiert. Ich will das nicht wieder aufbringen, aber somit wissen schon. SIP-basiertes Streaming zum Beispiel, oder überhaupt mal ein Streaming-Server-Setup, was in gewisser Hinsicht niedrigere Latenzen versucht zu erreichen.
Ich bin ja immer noch für Mambi.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, so ein Akkustoji, wenn da 500 Hörer im Stream der Meinung sind, sie müssten irgendwann irgendwelche Knöpfe drücken, dann kommen wir hier doch nicht mehr zur Sendung. Das ist ja schlimmer als...
Du machst da natürlich nicht jeden einzelnen, sondern nur das Gesamte der Masse.
Ja, schon, aber das ist doch schlimmer, als wenn wir hier in Vollbesetzung sind und alle quasseln dazwischen.
Das wird sich zeigen.
Nein, wieso? Du nimmst den Durchschnitt der Masse und wenn irgendwie mehr als die Hälfte der Meinung sind, das ist ein Facepalm-Wert, du kannst das ja sogar so mit so einer Menge anzeigen, wie so ein...
Nicht anzeigen, hören! Es muss so ein Soundgenerator sein, der halt so diesen Facepalm... Also wenn das Facepalm-Value sozusagen einen gewissen Threshold überschritten hat, dann kommt halt so ein Facepalm-Sound. So. Also wenn 100 Leute sich gleichzeitig ins Gesicht schlagen.
Haben wir das gehört?
Ja, aber das zeugt mich. Das macht man ja so ganz leise und geht so in sich.
Dann lieber Fangesänge.
Hatten wir ja gerade. Also die wunderschöne Adaption eines Union-Berlin-Fansongs hier zum Einstieg von...
Du hast ja gesagt, die sollen besonders auch passen, aber ich hatte da Schwierigkeiten, den Inhalt rauszufischen. Ich hab das nicht akustisch.
Ein Insider, kann ich das gleich mal sagen. Also David hat ja dann immer mal wieder so lustige Ideen und hat ja auch gewisse Serien. Und eine Serie, wo ihr euch natürlich naturgemäß etwas schwerer tut, insbesondere du, denn das ist, wenn er anderer Leute Podcast-Intros verwurstet und in ein Freak Show-Intro verwandelt. Das war heute mal wieder so eins.
Und welche?
Von Textilvergehen.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich hab's auch nicht erkannt.
Na wie auch? Ihr kennt ja den Podcast nicht.
Nee, nicht mal gehört, glaub ich.
Genau. Textilvergehend ist der Fan-Podcast des 1. FCO-Union Berlin.
Wo meist der Textilvergehen? Setzt ihr einen aus einem Fashion-Podcast an?
Weiß nicht, ob das jetzt abgestritten werden würde, aber ein Textilvergehen ist, wenn ein Fußballspieler den anderen am Trikot reißt.
Ah, verstehe.
Also so ein Faul per Trikot ziehen, was ja neulich zu zerrissenen Shirts geführt hat.
Ja, und zu stundenlangen Diskussionen.
Genau. Ja, das ist Textilvergehen und das war das adaptierte Intro. Insofern, David, wie immer, vielen Dank für deine Beiträge hier.
Hut ab!
Genau, Hut ab, Mats ab. Ja, Meter, Meter, Meter. Ähm, wir sind immer noch nicht bei der WWDC angekommen, ne? Ja, dann machen wir das doch mal. Also, die WWDC, die Apple Worldwide Developers Conference, sorgt ja von Jahr zu Jahr zu immer mehr Hyperventilationen. Ja, die Aufmerksamkeit ist schon enorm.
Ich finde, diesmal war ich ganz schön gelangweilt von der Keynote. Wirklich? Ja, weil sich die für mich interessanten Sachen, die sickerten erst danach so langsam durch. Also, was man während der Keynote gar nicht so richtig mitkriegt, weil das mehr so für den Konsumer irgendwie zurechtgeschnitten wurde.
Das ist aber nichts Neues aus diesem Jahr.
Ja, ich finde schon, aber es wird immer schlimmer. Früher war das mehr Developer-mäßig und da war es richtig interessant. Inzwischen wird das immer mehr zur Verkaufsshow und du musst schon danach erst ein bisschen suchen, bis du die interessanten Sachen so mitkriegst.
Nee, das ist es auch geworden. Ich glaube noch nicht mal Apple würde das abstreiten. Allein, dass sie ja schon für die Developer wirklich wichtige Informationen und Sachen, worauf sie lange gewartet haben, dann ein paar Tage vorab schon mal liegen, weil sie wissen, dass sie das nicht in der Keynote unterbekommen, weil sie so viele andere Sachen unterbekommen wollen, zeigt ja, dass das sozusagen an der Stelle gar nicht darum geht. Aber das ist ja auch okay. Ich meine, die Aufmerksamkeit ist da. Alle schauen halt zu, weil jetzt gibt es halt viel Neues und viel Details. Aber die wollen sich natürlich jetzt nicht stundenlang irgendwie Details über Swift 3 anhören. Sondern das ist halt eben für den Hardcore. Und deswegen ist halt das, was früher auf der Keynote mehrheitlich vertreten war, jetzt einfach mehrheitlich auf die zweite Keynote, die ja danach kommt, die du mich vorhin schon so schön korrigiert hast, die Platforms State of the Union heißt das, glaube ich, korrekt, ne?
Die hieß mal iOS 10 State of the Union. Nee, die hieß immer schon State of the Union. Nee, die hieß OS X State of the Union.
Nee, die gibt's schon länger, die gibt's schon länger als es OS X gibt.
Und dann haben sie es irgendwann Platform State of the Union genannt, als sie plötzlich zu viele Betriebssysteme hatten. Aber die hieß früher nicht Platform State of the Union, sondern OS X State of the Union.
Nein, nein, die gab's schon vor OS X, diese Session.
Ja, kann sein.
Die war bloß halt nie jetzt so Livestream und die war nicht so ähnlich gehypt, aber es gab schon immer diese Show nach der Steve Show, wo halt für die Entwickler das Wichtige noch mal zusammengedröselt wird, aber halt mit diesem reinen Def-Fokus und ohne diese ganzen sonstigen Klingelingen und Klingelings dabei.
Du bist der neue Starstar der Chris Lettner, ne?
Ja.
Da war ja tobender Applaus, als er auf der Bühne kam.
Ja, zurecht.
Ja, zurecht, würde ich auch sagen.
Aber bleiben wir vielleicht dann doch erstmal bei der Keynote. Also wir wissen, die ist halt for the masses mittlerweile und die Entwickler sind auch dabei. Aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass das jetzt alles vollkommen irrelevant ist für Entwickler wie Apple, neue Features ihrer Plattformen, auch der Öffentlichkeit erläutert. Also das ist ja sozusagen nicht nur eine Frage von wie genau ist es in der OP jetzt, sondern es geht ja auch um wie ist es gedacht, was, wie soll die User Experience sein? Wie nehmen die Leute, wie sollen diese Leute diese Features aufnehmen? Was sind die Dinge, die damit gemacht werden sollen? Und das ist natürlich dann konkurrent mit der Botschaft, hier, das sind die Features, die ihr demnächst in die Hand.
Ja, aber die Keynote war ganz klar dieses Jahr, aber auch die Jahre davor. Was ist neu für den User in den Betriebssystemen, die kommen? Also, es gab in der Keynote, glaube ich, nichts, was irgendwie developer-relevant war. Also, das war mein Eindruck.
Alles ist eigentlich developer-relevant.
Nein, aber die Keynote selber war nicht an den Developer gerichtet. Die ist for the masters, ganz klar. Aber das war sie in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren auch schon nicht. Ich sehe da jetzt auch keine große Entwicklung.
Nö, aber wenn man halt zehn oder 15 Jahre zurück schaut, dann hat sich schon was verändert.
Aber da war die WWDC auch keine Plattform, um anzukündigen, was als nächstes an Software rauskommt, sondern eine echte Developer-Conference. Also, ich kann mich halt an Jahre erinnern, da war sie nicht ausverkauft, weil sie halt nicht genug Leute gefunden haben, die sich den Scheiß angehört haben.
Kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen.
Entsprechend gab es auch keinen Stream und auch teilweise keine Aufzeichnungen von dem Zeug. Oder du hast als Developer die Aufzeichnungen nur hinterher in dieser gigantischen DVD-Box bekommen, wo du dann irgendwie die ganzen Talks in irgendwie 15 DVDs dann irgendwie dir alle einzeln angucken konntest.
Ich weiß noch, wie ich in den 90ern irgendwann, das war halt kein WWDC, sondern irgendeine andere Keynote, die die gehalten haben, das war ja früher mal zu Mac World im Januar irgendwie, war immer das große Ding. Und da gab es irgendwie so Infos, da hab ich ja schon auch da viel Mac, was hab ich gelesen? Mac in Touch und so hab ich gelesen. Und dann stand da, dass per Satellit nach Europa übertragen wird für die Apple-Zentralen, da in München ist die glaube ich, und in England irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Und dass die offen ist, nicht verschlüsselt, und dass man die da halt mitgucken kann. Und dann hab ich das, jemand der da so einen Satellitenempfängerschlüssel hatte, haben wir das dann da live geguckt und so. Ich glaub, das war schon ganz, ganz früh und ganz vorne mit dabei.
Ich war einmal, also als ich noch bei Ableton gearbeitet hab, da hat halt irgendwie der Ableton-Chef da zwei Tickets für so ein Event, wo sie mit Satellitenschüssel und so weiter, da hatten sie irgendwie da, wenn man vorm Brandenburger Tor steht, links ist dieses Haus mit diesem komischen Innengeschwurbel da. Da drin hatten sie das dann übertragen und das war ganz lustig, weil es gab Tickets für Presse und VIP. Also für Apple war damals entweder warst du Presse oder VIP. Und dann haben wir uns das angeguckt, aber dann hat leider der Sturm die Satellitenschüssel vom Dach geweht und dann haben sie irgendwie doch den Internet-Stream angemacht, der fürchterlich schlecht war. Da hatten sie die G5s vorgestellt und dann konnte man hinterher in so einem getrennten Raum noch ein bisschen die G5s angrabbeln.
Das, was ich meine, muss eher so 98 rum oder so gewesen sein.
Nunja, was ist denn neu?
Genau, also es fing an mit der Watch.
Mit der Watch, genau. Also sie haben ja endlich diesen komischen Ring mit den Kontakten weggemacht, den wahrscheinlich auch niemand benutzt hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den mal benutzt hast, ich nicht.
Nein, das war nicht wirklich benutzbar. Also ich fand's sehr interessant. Sie haben eigentlich, also sie haben nicht alles erklärt. Mir sind ein paar Sachen unklar. Zum Beispiel ist dieses Icon-Dashboard mit den ganzen Apps. Wurde überhaupt nicht erwähnt.
Dieses mit den runden Kreiseln. Das muss auch weg, das ist das, was mich wirklich obdich stört.
Ja gut, aber wie wählst du dann deine Apps aus?
Wahrscheinlich gibt's das noch, aber du hast halt dieses, diesen Task-Switcher, der so ein bisschen so dein, Dein Doc ist.
Ja, aber das Doc ist halt, es ist halt wirklich mehr ein Doc als ein Task-Switcher.
Es ist nicht so wie auf dem iPhone. Sie verwischen es aber ein bisschen.
Nein, aber du wählst explizit die Apps, die in diesem Doc sind.
Ja, du bekommst aber welche vorgeschlagen.
Ja gut, du magst ja irgendwelche vorgeschlagen bekommen, aber wenn ich jetzt halt eine bestimmte App explizit haben will, auch eine, die noch nicht aufgerufen wurde. Ich muss ja irgendwie in der Lage sein, das Doc rauszuschlagen.
Sie haben auch die Glanzes weggemacht, weil die irgendwie nicht sinnvoll waren.
Sie haben die Glanzes als separates Element, als separates User-Interface entfernt, aber Sie haben jetzt das Erscheinungsbild einer App unter dem Begriff der Glanzability definiert.
Aber Glanz war innerhalb einer App ein ganz bestimmter Screen, der als Glanz geladen wurde und was anderes war als die App. Sie haben die Glanzes weggemacht und die App selber soll so gebaut werden, dass sie Glanzable ist.
Du sagst das selber, was ich sage, in anderen Worten.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, die Glanzes sind weg. Die sind deprecated. Die gibt es halt nicht mehr unter Watchers 3.
Doch?
Nein, doch, nein, doch.
Weiter?
Ich hab schon zugehört. So ist es nicht. Naja, also, du hast eine Watch, Denis hat keine, Roddi hat eine.
Solange diese runden Dinger da sind, geht das auch nicht.
Die runden Dinger sind nicht optimal, aber die waren jetzt auch nicht so unbenutzbar und scheiße. Das Problem war eher woanders. Das Hauptproblem war, dass sie sich User-Interface, Dinge und Apps überlegt haben, die einfach überhaupt nicht gezogen haben. Zum Beispiel das von Roddi bereits angesprochene Kontaktmenü auf diesem großen Side-Button. Das war einfach nichts, was man am laufenden Meter und schon gar nicht so schnell irgendwie im Zug gefahren würde. Ich bin mir sicher, dass es in irgendeiner Form noch da ist. Nur eben jetzt nicht mit One-Touch auf einem Button, sondern Trippelklick, keine Ahnung, Longpress, irgendwas.
Die meinten ja in irgendeinem Interview, der Job mit der Uhr muss in zwei Sekunden erledigt sein.
Genau, das war nämlich das Hauptproblem. Das Hauptproblem war wirklich die Responsiveness, die war einfach nicht gegeben. Und wenn Dinge eben länger dauern als eine Sekunde zum Starten, dann wirst du einfach schon nervös. Allein schon, weil die Uhr auch nervös wird, weil die dann einfach irgendwann wieder auf Schwarz schaltet. So, bevor die App einfach überhaupt durchgestartet war. Das war einfach komplett pointless. Aber das war halt auch sehr offensichtlich. Und ich hätte mich jetzt auch schwer gewundert, wenn sie da nicht in eine Antwort geliefert hätten. Das Interessante ist, dass ihre Antwort jetzt nicht ist, hier guckt mal neue Uhr, dreimal so schnell, jetzt geht das auch fix, wirft mal die alte weg. Sondern sie haben es halt in Software gefixed bekommen. Zumindest eben mit diesen Doct-Apps, weil die liegen halt jetzt im Rahmen. Das ist halt eigentlich die halbe Wahrheit.
Genau, das ist die halbe Wahrheit. Die liegen länger im Rahmen, aber nicht unbedingt. Sondern die sind genauso, wie man sie vom Task-Switcher, vom iPhone kennt, werden die auch irgendwann beendet. Aber die bekommen im Hintergrund Zeit, um ihre UI zu updaten. Und können dann quasi einen Screenshot machen im Background, sodass du, wenn du einfach nur durchswipes, das Gefühl hast, die App würde laufen, aber es tut sie nicht. Das ist genau so wie bei iOS.
Das gibt es schon bei iOS? Warum hab ich dann immer noch so viele Apps, die ich irgendwie hochhole und die dann in dem Moment ihren Screen...
zu viel aufnörst und nicht genug speicherst.
Nein, weil du bei iOS State Restoration unterstützen musst. Und das tut kaum jemand, weil das ist einfach ein Pain in the Ass.
Die meisten Programme kriegen sie ja immer noch nicht mit.
Das heißt, wenn die gekillt werden, dann starten die Apps halt normal neu.
Ja, aber die Stopwatch von Apple sollte das ja wohl hinkriegen.
Ja, sollte sie, aber wenn sie es nicht tut, dann tut sie es halt nicht. Ich kann mich jetzt schlecht für Apple eigene Apps rechtfertigen. Wenn du sagst, sie tut es nicht, dann tut sie es vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher. Da müsste ich selber nochmal gucken. Aber ich hab irgendwie so immer mal wieder diese Experience, dass es halt auch nicht da ist. Aber du hast recht, vielleicht ist es einfach nur mangelnder Set-Party-Support. Wo man sich natürlich dann auch mal wieder fragen muss, warum ist das so? Warum werden Entwickler nicht mehr motiviert und angehalten? Oder warum entdecken sie selber nicht die Freude daran, solche Wartungsmaßnahmen am Code auch schnell umzusetzen?
Das kann ich dir sagen, weil die meisten Entwickler haben Produktmanager. Viele Produktmanager gucken sich erstens nicht die Apple-Doku an. Die wenigsten haben User-Interface-Guidelines gelesen. Und zweitens gibt es eine ganz große Gruppe dieser Menschen, die der Meinung ist, eine App hätte einen Homescreen. Der Homescreen wäre wichtig und der Real Estate auf dem Homescreen ist etwas ganz Besonderes, wo ganz bestimmte Dinge platziert werden. Und das funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn die App beim Start immer diesen Homescreen zeigt. Obwohl Apple das halt nicht will. Ja, ich weiß.
Es gibt aber Firmen, die rudern wieder zurück, weil sie merken, sie haben verkackt wie Ebay gerade.
Du, es gibt Firmen, die rudern zurück. Es gibt Firmen, die rudern gar nicht.
Die rudern nur mit den Armen.
Ich kann natürlich auch nicht für ganz viele andere Apps sprechen, aber gerade für gewisse Sachen macht es auch Sinn, sowas zu haben. Für andere Apps ist es schlauer, eine State Restoration zu machen. Wenn ich eine Fußball-App habe und mir als Letztes die Tabelle der Gruppe, der EM, angeguckt, dann ist es total sinnvoll, dass die State Restoration mir auch diese Tabelle wieder anzeigt. Und nicht irgendeinen Einstiegsbildschirm. Aber hey, auf der anderen Seite ist es technisch immer ein bisschen in Pain, das tatsächlich hinzukriegen. Also es ist nicht so, dass man das irgendwie weitestgehend geschenkt bekommen würde.
Was gab's noch bei Watch OS? Man kann jetzt rumscribbeln, ob das man nicht...
Naja, schau mal mal.
Sie haben ja eine ganz nette Demo gegeben, die schon mal zeigt, wo es vielleicht sinnvoll sein könnte. Nämlich chinesische Buchstaben schreiben.
Ja gut, aber chinesische Buchstaben, das ist auch schon in IOS seit Jahren drin gewesen, dass du die tatsächlich schreibst. Ja, ich halte das auch nicht für verkehrt, zumindest die Möglichkeit zu haben, tatsächlich einzelne Zeichen einzugeben. Aber wenn ich mir dann vorstelle, ich schreibe ein längeres Wort mit allen Buchstaben, einzeln, die ich da reinskribbeln...
Nein, dafür ist es halt nicht gemacht, sag ich. Das ist halt chinesisch. Was mich bloß wundert ist, warum sie dann keinen... Wie hieß noch gleich das Ding vom Palmpilot? Graffiti?
Weil du Graffiti erst lernen musst.
Ja, aber wenn du Graffiti für Emojis machst...
Normale Buchstaben können die meisten Leute schreiben, ohne dass sie es lernen müssen.
Wie Graffiti für Emojis. Ich scribble halt ein Emoji und ersetze es durch den Emoji. So wie ich ein chinesisches Zeichen skribble und das erst durch ein chinesisches Zeichen ersetze, könnte man doch auch eine entsprechende Sprache für Facepalm und so weiter machen. Und dann kannst du mit so 5 Fingerstrichen kannst du irgendwie Poop, Poop Smiley, Facepalm... Also wie gesagt......Mittelfinger......Mittelfinger Extended.
Jedes System, was du dir ausdenkst, müssen andere Leute lernen. Und ich glaube, nur um auf der Uhr ein Emoji einzugeben, lernen die Leute das nicht. Also das ist so...
SOS kann man senden. Wo ich mich ein bisschen gefragt habe, welcher Grad, also welchen Umfang das alles hat. Weil so wie sie das angedeutet haben, also was war das? Du musst lange irgendwie auf deine Sidebutton drücken oder sowas? Keine Ahnung wie lange, aber du drückst doch irgendwie ein paar Sekunden oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung. Hältst du die Taste? Wenn du merkst, dass die Lichter ausgehen und du rückwärts fällst, dann drückst du noch schnell auf den Button und hoffst, dass du ihn lange genug gehalten hast. Wenn dann der Hinterkopf des Asphalt berührt, dann 20 Minuten später der Sani da ist. Oder wie auch immer das dann dauert. Also keine Ahnung. Das war nämlich die Aussage, dass es ja nicht nur den Notruf auslöst, sondern auch noch irgendwelche Best Friends und Family informiert. Also keine Ahnung. Ich nehme mal an, sie machen ja sehr viel in diesem Health und so weiter Kram. Vielleicht gibt es im Apple Board jemand, der der Meinung ist, er bräuchte das unbedingt. Keine Ahnung.
Ähm, bräuchte was unbedingt? Das ist eigentlich eine total super Sache. Aber was sie ja auch gesagt haben, ist ja, dass es ja auch die Möglichkeit gibt, deinen Freundinnen deine Location zu melden. Also der Notruf ist sozusagen nicht nur ein ich ruf 112 an.
Jaja, schon klar.
Sondern eben auch dieses Freunde helft mir. Was ja dann in dem Moment, wo du eben dann deine enge Freundeskreisliste in irgendeiner Form, also deine Notrufliste definiert hast, durchaus ein sinnvolles Feature sein kann. Und zwar jetzt weniger mit Hilfe, ich werde überfallen, sondern mehr so, ich bin in einem...
Hilfe, das Bier ist alle oder die Mate.
Nein. Kritische medizinische Zustände bei jemandem, der in großer Gefahr ist, in kritische medizinische Zustände zu geraten.
So was.
Du musst mir jetzt nicht immer widersprechen. Nein, nein, nein. Ich sag das einfach immer nur, weil sie das gesagt haben. Und das fand ich eine sinnvolle Ergänzung. Und dann kommen wir eigentlich jetzt auf das Thema des Abends, sozusagen, also dieses Keynote-Abends. Nämlich, dass Apple eigentlich bemerkenswerterweise wirklich eine ganze Ladung von Integration bietet, wo Entwickler jetzt in der Lage sind, auf Dinge zuzugreifen, die bisher zuzementiert waren wie Beton.
Und das Keyword dafür war Extensions und nicht Integration.
Ja, Extensions sind, sagen wir mal, die Technologie und die Integration ist das, was du dann damit erreichst.
Ja, und sie lassen die Ladets an ganz schön viel ran. Also iMessage war ein großes Ding, ne?
Dann bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei der Uhr. Bei der Uhr war es nämlich zum Beispiel so, dass sie jetzt auch diesen ganzen Fitness-Apps etc. auch den entsprechenden Zugriff auf diese ganze Realtime-Sensor-Data gegeben haben. Hardrate und so weiter. Weil das war ja bisher das Elend. Ich hab ja, lauf jetzt gerade mal wieder nicht so viel, aber als ich das häufiger gemacht hab, da hatte ich ja auch gerade so die Watch, und das war so ein bisschen so minder begeistert, weil die Fitness-App von Apple, die war eher so meh. Und ich hab zum Beispiel Rantastic benutzt, gibt ja noch ein paar andere, die ganz okay sind. Und die hatten halt noch nicht diesen Zugriff. Du musstest dann eigentlich immer noch so einen separaten Hard-Tracker haben, zusätzlich zu der Watch, weil es da halt keinen Zugriff drauf gab. Und wenn ich das jetzt halt richtig verstanden habe, können mit WatchOS 3 im Prinzip auch alle Third-Party-Fitness-Apps im Wesentlichen dasselbe leisten wie die Boardmittel. Und das ist halt schon ziemlich cool, weil dann fängt das an langsam sinnvoll zu werden, das Teil.
Ich finde das auch von Apple, also fand das vorher mal ein bisschen bekloppt, dass sie gewisse Sachen so zu machen und der Meinung sind, das irgendwie selber hinzukriegen, weil Apple so, wie soll man sagen, um ein gutes Produkt zu machen oder was richtig Tolles, was Neues zu bringen, muss doch nicht einfach nur gut sein, sondern gehört auch noch eine Menge Glück und irgendwie, ja, Fantasie dazu. Und das braucht halt viele Leute, wo sich da mal was Schönes rausbildet. Und dadurch, dass Apple so viel selber macht, nehmen sie ganz vielen anderen die Chance, das zu tun. Und ich finde, wenn sie das öffnen, dann passiert einfach viel mehr.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues. Sie kommen ja immer erst mal mit den Dingen in einem geschlosseneren Zustand raus. Und dann, Schritt für Schritt, öffnen sie das. Nicht überall, in allen Bereichen immer so weit, wie das allen vorschwebt. Aber teilweise dann eben auch umfangreicher und auch besser, wie ich finde, als manche das gefordert haben. Also gerade das Extension-Modell von iOS 8 war einfach grandios, weil sie halt auf der einen Seite Zugriff ermöglichen in viele Subsysteme, aber auf der anderen Seite sich eben das Security-Modell noch erhalten.
Was ich so ein bisschen merkwürdig fand, war, dass sie, also das all diese, es sind ja ungefähr ein halbes Dutzend Extension Points, die neu sind. Und wenn du mal hinguckst, ist auch nicht wesentlich mehr dran als diese halbes Dutzend Extension Points, dass die so spezifisch sind. Also es gibt für jeden Extension Point einen Use-Case, den Apple im Hinterkopf hat. Und du bist entweder eine der drei VoIP-Apps, die das sinnvoll findet, oder das ganze Thema ist einfach völlig uninteressant. Oder du bist eine Health-App oder das Thema ist uninteressant. Also ich finde, für mich stellt sich das so dar, als wäre das alles so hochspezifisch, was sie da eingebaut haben, als hätten sie irgendwie im Board of Directors mal nachgefragt, welche Top-Apps benutzt ihr denn und warum sind die scheiße, was können wir tun, damit die besser sind.
Ja gut, aber sie haben eben nicht halt sich nur mit, sagen wir mal, Runtastic hingesetzt und haben gesagt, ey, wir wollen euch hier Zugang geben, wir machen euch das irgendwie speziell, sondern sie haben sich hingesetzt und gesagt, wir machen das für alle. Und wenn eine andere Bude kommt, dann nutzt die das halt. Und das finde ich schon gut, weil Konkurrenz belebt das Geschäft. Das ist einfach gut für den User.
Ja, das schon, aber ich habe zu keinem dieser Extension Points irgendwie das Gefühl, das ist visionär, so nach der Art. Wir öffnen jetzt mal an dieser Stelle das System für etwas, wo jemand mal Fantasie beweisen kann. Naja, das kannst du jetzt aber noch nicht sagen, was da zu so kommen wird. Aber wissen nicht, was da passieren wird, sondern das sind alles so extrem spezifische Sachen. Das ist halt eine Voip-App, das ist halt eine Running-App, das ist halt irgendwie irgendwas auf der Karte darstellen oder so. Also irgendwie...
Ja, das ist doch klar, warum? Also erstens ist auch, auch wenn du da zurückblätterst in Integration bei iOS, macOS, ist es so, am Anfang haben sie das für extrem spezifische Fälle aufgemacht. Und später, in einem zweiten und dritten Schritt, haben sie das dann noch weiter generalisiert. So, also das ist ja sozusagen nicht das Ende vom Lieb, sondern manchmal ist die Öffnung halt sehr zaghaft, manche sagen zu zaghaft, andere sagen, wir wollen es mal nicht übertreiben. Was ihnen aber dann in der Regel auch, also was sie ja auch immer mitliefern, ist eine User Experience dazu. Also es ist ja nicht einfach nur so, ja, jetzt ist das hier irgendwie offen, macht mal in der Karte, was ihr wollt. Weil wenn du halt jetzt sagst, alle Apps können jetzt in Maps machen, was sie wollen, dann machen sie da, was sie wollen und dann hast du halt die User Experience nicht mehr. In dem Moment, wo du aber sagst, wir definieren jetzt einen bestimmten Vorgang und in den passt du vielleicht rein oder nicht. Wie zum Beispiel, ich buche oder was waren da die Beispiele? Uber und OpenTable, Klassiker, Restaurant, Taxi holen.
Ich stelle mir ein Auto. Das ist halt ein Use Case, das ist ein Exchange Point.
Ja, aber das ist ja eine Frage des User Interfaces. Weil du musst ja dann das bestellte Auto visualisieren, du musst klar machen, dass da jetzt gerade was Wichtiges passiert. Du willst ja nicht einfach nur irgendwelche weiteren blinkenden Icons in der Karte haben, sondern die App soll ja immer noch einen Plan davon haben, was hier gerade passiert. Und deswegen überrascht mich das jetzt nicht, dass eben diese Extensions an der Stelle so spezifisch sind, weil sie eben die User Experience nicht aus der Hand geben wollen. Sie wollen das öffnen für Third Party und definieren von daher nur ein paar extrem vertikale Anwendungen, die aber nicht selbst so trotz populär genug sind und wichtig genug sind, dass das eben auch legitim ist, so einen Kanal aufzumachen.
Ja, aber besonders dramatisch ist es halt für Siri. Weil bei Siri gibt es halt sechs verschiedene Anwendungen, für die du Siri erweitern kannst. Und alles andere fällt halt komplett unten durch. Also wenn du jetzt nicht Write Booking, Messaging, Photosurge, Workouts, Payments oder VoIP Calling machst, dann hast du als Entwickler keine Chance, Siri zu erweitern. Für mich kommt das so unglaublich engstirnig und uninspiriert rüber.
Wer macht es denn besser? Also wo ist es denn anders jetzt?
Das ist nicht der Punkt.
Ich meine, was stellst du dir denn vor? Du hättest gerne einfach hier ist unsere AI, mach doch was ihr wollt.
Also gerade Siri wäre halt hochspannend, halt auch andere Anwendungen zuzulassen. Also keine Ahnung, ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wie würde man jetzt ein Voice-Interface definieren? Und vielleicht ist es auch gerade da ganz gut, dass man sich vorsichtig ran tastet, aber es kommt für mich doch sehr uninspiriert rüber.
Ich teile das nicht. Ich sehe gerade bei dem Siri-Interface das genauso wie bei Maps. Es ist wichtig für so einen Dienst wie Siri, dass du eine Vorstellung davon hast, was für eine Art Aktivität jetzt hier vorgenommen werden soll, was die Intention ist. Also vielleicht jetzt nicht bis ins Letzte, was genau für einen Dienst das ist und in welcher Klasse das ist. Hast du diese Liste von sechs Sachen?
Hab ich ja gerade vorgelesen.
Sag noch mal.
Write Booking, Messaging, Photosurge, Workouts, Payments und Voip Calling. Messaging, Photosurge, Workouts, Payments und Voip Calling. Siehst du, es wirkt auch so ein bisschen wahllos.
Nein, nein, finde ich gar nicht. Das sind populäre Dinge, die man jetzt auf jeden Fall auch tun wollen würde, mit seinem Telefon erst mal. Es sind Sachen, wo es mehrere Anbieter gibt, die da reinpluggen können, die auch da sind, die es gibt. Und du willst halt für so was wie einen Bezahlvorgang auch hier wieder ein einheitliches User-Interface haben.
Klar.
Also, es gibt ja diesen Amazon-Echo-Way, so nach dem Motto, ja, definiere da deine Command-Line, dann kannst du das runterplappern, so hier mein Modul, ich sage dir Commando X Parameter, hm, hm, hm, und dann macht man das.
Naja, das ist ja Unsinn.
Ja, aber so machen die das, so. Und alles nur auf Englisch. Und Siri macht das halt mit 37 Sprachen, also auch im Kontext unterschiedlichster Grammatiken und Arten und Weisen Dinge zu beschreiben. Ja, aber das ist der Punkt, glaube ich, an der Stelle, dass du die Komplexität von Weltsprachen im Prinzip ja erstmal zusammenführen musst auf wie sage ich es in dieser Sprache. Und da ist es natürlich hilfreich, wenn du weißt, was in etwa gesagt wird. Und sie generalisieren es halt so weit über mit, okay, wir haben jetzt ein Verständnis dafür, wie wir in 37 Sprachen ankündigen, dass wir eine Nachricht schicken wollen. Und da kannst du dich dann reinkloppen und wir geben dir den richtigen Kontakt. Wir geben dir irgendwie den richtigen Kontext. Wir geben dir irgendwie, was du jetzt zu tun hast. Und wir geben dir, was du schicken sollst. Und das, weiß ich nicht, finde ich nachvollziehbar und finde ich auch einen sinnvollen Ansatz. Also ich habe einfach Schwierigkeiten, damit mich in dieses Geschrei einzugliedern, was dann immer so, Siri hat keine AP. Natürlich haben die irgendwie von Anfang an darüber nachgedacht, nur haben sie halt andere Anforderungen, andere Vorstellungen auch davon, wie, auf welcher Ebene so eine AP ist. Und ihre AP ist halt vergleichsweise High Level.
Ich stell mich auch nicht hin und sage, sie müssen das komplett öffnen, weil sonst ist es ein Fail. Und ich hab auch nicht genug Möglichkeiten zu sagen, wie es überhaupt intern funktioniert und ob sowas überhaupt machbar ist. Also ich fand das sowieso erstaunlich, dass sie überhaupt Siri für eine AP öffnen. Aber fand es dann im Umkehrschluss wieder merkwürdig, dass sie das auf so spezifische Anwendungen reduzieren. Das hat mich einfach erstaunt, weil dieses wir ermöglichen jetzt diese sechs spezifischen Anwendungen einmal komplett durchs ganze System durch, war so... Ich weiß nicht, das hat mich... Irgendwie fand ich das komisch, dass sie sich jetzt so unglaublich auf diese Dinge beschränkt haben. So ein bisschen wie, das sind jetzt die top sechs Anwendungen im App Store, die runtergeladen werden. Und für die müssen wir jetzt machen und alles andere interessiert uns erstmal nicht, damit wir die große Plattform sind, die das ermöglicht, dass die erfolgreichsten Apps noch erfolgreicher werden.
Wie gesagt, du wirst wahrscheinlich daran scheitern, wenn du sagst, okay, wir haben jetzt hier so ein bisschen Intelligenz und jetzt öffnen wir das für alle irgendwie erdenklichen Programme. Das bedeutet ja, dass du keinerlei Annahmen machst, darüber, was das Ziel einer Interaktion ist. Und ohne diese Annahmen kannst du halt auch bestimmte Abstraktionen nicht durchführen. Wenn du diese Abstraktionen nicht durchführst, also wenn du diesen Dienst quasi nicht mit anbietest, verdummifizierst du quasi deine API. Du steigst auf einem niedrigen Level ein. Das heißt dann aber auch wiederum, dass du den Apps sehr viel mehr Intelligenz aufbürdest, selber aus dem, was da jetzt gesagt wurde, sich einen Reim draus zu machen. Und das finde ich ist eigentlich das Starke.
So ist die API nicht gebaut, aber das ist nur am Rande.
Doch, so ist die API gebaut, weil du steigst ja da an der Stelle ein mit drei oder vier abstrakten Dingen, in die du dich reinplackst. Und der Rest wird halt von dem Fragegerüst quasi vorgegeben.
Nicht?
Außer wenn es ja noch in Erwicklung ist, es geht ja weiter.
Hab ich was falsch verstanden oder was? Ich hab der Demo entnommen, haben sie das auf der Keynote gezeigt oder auf der State of the Union? Du hast auch das Beispiel mit den Messages. Und mit welchen Objekten quasi ein Programm an diese Art hier rangeht. Und da steckt halt eine Abstraktion drin. Da steckt eine Interaktionsidee und ein Interaktionsziel mit drin.
Genau.
Ja, und das finde ich einen sinnvollen Ansatz. Und wenn sie heute sechs Sachen haben, dann haben sie das nächste Mal weitere 30 und dann nochmal 100. Und wie viele unterschiedliche Apps willst du dann noch unterstützen?
Nein, technisch sehe ich das ein. Du willst den Suchraum eingrenzen und willst nicht alles möglich machen, weil das schaffst du einfach nicht auf einem Telefon. Das ist schon alles, also ich verstehe das schon, warum sie das so machen. Mich hat das einfach nur vom Gesamtenor so gewundert, dass sie sich so stark auf Spezifiker konzentriert haben und weniger generelles Zeug gemacht haben.
Ja, weil sie auch Zeug zum Vorführen brauchten.
Ja, so wie war das? Wie heißen die Dinger? Sticker? Ey, das hättest du auch unter Steve nicht gegeben. Das war doch super hässlich.
Ja, lass mal über iMessage nachher reden. Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu Siri und ihrem ganzen Deep Learning Aspekt. Sie haben ja auch eine, wie heißt diese API? Eine AI-API, also Artificial Energy oder Deep Learning API. Also irgendwas, was nochmal separat von, nee, einem Neural Network API heißt das glaube ich. Separat von Siri gibt es im OS. Ich frage mich, was die macht. Ich habe es keine Ahnung, wir haben das API nicht angeschaut, aber gibt es. Also es gibt da sozusagen eine Möglichkeit, noch in irgendeiner Form Neural Netzwerk-Fu machen zu können. Vielleicht, verstehst du, ist das ja ein Zugang. Aber was ich noch interessanter fand, war diese Idee mit, wie verknüpfen wir kollektives Lernen über alle Geräte und dem Wunsch, maximale Privatsphäre zu verknüpfen.
Kann ich dir erklären.
Du meinst dieses Privacy-Ding?
Sie haben dieses Differential Privacy aufgebracht, was die Arbeit von einem Wissenschaftsleiter, dessen Namen ich gerade nicht parat habe, abgedeckt ist. Und das haben sie halt mal implementiert.
Und so habe ich so einen Artikel dazu gelesen, der hat das gut erklärt. Und zwar gab es das vorher wohl auch schon. Das war eine Umfrage über, ich glaube sogar, Sexualkrankheiten oder so in die Richtung, wo man halt nicht gerne antwortet. Und damit sie den Leuten halt erklären konnten, dass es halt auch anonym bleibt und dass sie da nichts irgendwie zurückverfolgen können, obwohl ihr Name dabei steht, haben sie gesagt, sie sollen erstmal eine Münze irgendwie werfen. Und wenn die Münze so fällt, sollen sie die Wahrheit hinschreiben. Und wenn die Münze aber anders fällt, dann sollen sie nochmal die Münze werfen. Und ich glaube, es ging darum, ob sie irgendeine, sagen wir mal... Genau, ob sie eine Sexualkrankheit schon mal hatten oder nicht. Oder irgendwie sowas. Und so eine Ja-Nein-Frage. Und das heißt, also erstmal die Münze werfen. Wenn sie so fällt, antworten sie mit der Wahrheit. Und wenn die anders fällt...
Also wenn du eine Münze würfst...
Das heißt, 50 Prozent sagen die Wahrheit, genau. Und dann die anderen 50 Prozent sind auch genau exakt, weil die ja nochmal würfeln, sind in die eine Hälfte... Würfeln? Ja, und die andere Hälfte in die andere Hälfte.
Also Würfeln oder Münze?
Münze, Würfel ist doch dasselbe.
Eine Münze heißt 50 Prozent. Also wenn du das erste Mal sagst, sagt die Wahrheit, dann hast du sozusagen 50 Prozent. Und wenn du dann nochmal einen Münzwurf hinterher machst, dann teilt sich diese 50 Prozent ja nochmal in 50. Also hast du dann 75 Prozent. Also je nachdem, wie viele Münzwurfe du hintereinander wirfst, wird die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du die Unwahrheit sagst, immer geregelt.
Nein, du machst genau nur zwei. Also entweder einen Münzwurf, wenn du gleich die Wahrheit sagen sollst. Wenn nicht, machst du noch einen, um der dir dann sagt, ob du Ja oder Nein sagst. Das heißt, 50 Prozent deiner Antworten ist echt. Und die anderen 50 Prozent sind exakt aufgeteilt in 25 Prozent Ja und in 20 Prozent Nein. Und statistisch gesehen kannst du das genau abziehen und dann kriegst du auch genau wieder exakt das Ergebnis. Nur halt dafür brauchst du halt viele Leute, damit sich das im Rauschen... Genau. Und das kann man aber rausrechnen dann. Und das hat es bei mir auch verstanden. Vorher dachte ich auch, differential privacy, was machen die da Neues irgendwie reinmixen, schummeln sie dann, sodass es nicht auffällt. Aber jetzt so mit diesen Münzen macht das irgendwie Sinn und so werden die das tun. Und ich finde, das ist eine gute Sache. Was sie aber noch machen damit, weil sie sammeln ja mehrere Daten von Leuten und dann stand da wohl, wenn man mehrere Daten sammelt, dann könnte man ja schon Rückschlüsse ziehen. Deswegen haben sie von diesem Privacy-Budget geredet, dass halt nur pro Minute oder so was gibt es nur maximal eine Anfrage, die sie machen, damit man halt eben keine Rückschlüsse irgendwie ziehen kann. Also sie begrenzen das ein bisschen pro User, damit es nicht zu viel wird. Genau. Weil wenn du zehnmal die Münze wirfst, dann hast du ja auch öfter die Wahrheit gesagt als nicht. Nee, eigentlich auch nicht. Aber es müsste sich ein Bild ergeben. Ja, doch, genau. Es müsste sich ein Bild ergeben.
Dünnes Eis.
Nein, es ergibt sich ein dünnes Bild. Dass du die Wahrheit sagst, müsste dann 75% zu 25% sein, theoretisch. Ach, keine Ahnung.
Bei dem Münzbeispiel ist es so, ich hatte hier den Eindruck, dass mit niedrigeren Wahrscheinlichkeiten gearbeitet wird, aber im Prinzip ist es dasselbe Modell.
Hatten sie nicht irgendwie sich den Typen eingekauft, der das Paper ursprünglich geschrieben hat?
Die haben mir die AP mal gezeigt, und der hat gesagt, das hatten die auch da gequoten, der hat gesagt, das sieht ganz gut aus, aber es war auch schon ein bisschen schwach. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass der für die arbeitet oder so. Aber der hat mal drüber geguckt. Aber ich meine, eigentlich, wenn man das Prinzip erstmal verstanden hat, dann ja, und sie auch wirklich die Information pro Individuum gar nicht brauchen, sondern wirklich nur die der gesamten Gruppe, dann ist es ja eigentlich auch easy. Man muss es halt aber auch so wollen. Was ja bei vielen Firmen nicht der Fall ist.
Ich glaube, dieses Privacy-Zeug ist genauso wie Encryption. Da kannst du schnell was falsch machen, wenn du nicht genau weißt, was du tust.
Das kann sein, ja.
Ja, aber immer noch was anderes, als ob du einen Messenger auf den Markt bringst, der bei Default erstmal keine End-to-End-Verschlüsselung macht, damit man irgendwie schön zwischendurch in der AI alles mitlesen kann.
Du meinst im Jahre 2016?
Im Jahre 2016, genau dann.
Und das haben die dann nochmal wie genannt? Nicht Privacy, sondern auch nicht Kamouflage. Sondern, nee nee, dieses Feature, wenn es, wenn es... Nein, dieser Google-Messenger, da hieß es doch, wenn man Privat hat, das hieß es doch dann, ist nicht Kamouflage, wie hieß das? In Cognito, genau, also auch noch den falschen Namen dafür benutzt. Naja, das heißt, haben sie wieder schnell aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt, irgendwelche Manager, weil sie bis zu Google IO noch schnell was produzieren mussten. Sonst hätte er das anders gemacht.
Es gibt ja viele Leute, die wollen Apple das alles nicht glauben. Ich persönlich finde das ziemlich überzeugend, was sie da bringen in Bezug auf ihre Linie mit Privacy und wir machen alles nur auf dem Gerät und wenn dein Gerät verschlüsselt ist, dann rückt es das nicht raus. Das ist schon der richtige Ansatz.
Ich glaube, dass diese ganze CIA-Nummer mit dem iPhone 5 das alles nochmal beschleunigt hat. Und den Manager dann einfach gezeigt haben, wir haben jetzt einmal hier Zähne gezeigt und die Leute merken das, wissen das jetzt und jetzt setzen wir noch einen drauf.
Aber nichts von dem, was wir jetzt auf dieser Keynote gesehen haben, ist nach diesem FBI-Fall beschlossen worden bei Apple, dass sie das tun. Das kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass sie das jetzt in drei Monaten irgendwie mal eben gestemmt haben. Das Privacy, ja, ich glaube, das ist das Problem, dass es ein Prime-Selling-Argument ist für Apple, das hat Tim Cook schon vor zwei Jahren jetzt in irgendwelchen Interviews von sich gegeben. Also es ist nichts Neues. Trotzdem, sie werden sicherlich nochmal einen Gang zugelegt haben und vielleicht an Sachen arbeiten, in die wir jetzt noch gar nicht gesehen haben. Man kann ja auch nur feststellen, und damit haben sie auch ordentlich rumgebracht, dass sie halt einfach mit Abstand die sicherste Plattform sind derzeit.
Das war schon ein krasses Bedenken, dass wir von der Bubble-Button-OS hatten. Bubble-Button? Nein, dieses blaue Eye-Candy-Bubble.
Was hat das jetzt mit Privatspenden zu tun?
Früher wurde Apple immer als Spielzeugfirma verlacht. Schon eine Weile her wieder, aber wir sind ja schon ein bisschen länger dabei. Und dass das jetzt sich so gewandelt hat, dass es jetzt halt mit Privacy voranschreitet.
Aber ich meine, im direkten Vergleich zu Microsoft, die damals die Platzhirsche waren, stand Apple eigentlich immer deutlich besser da. Also jetzt in einigen Details nicht, aber ich meine, Windows NT war ja nur eine Vollkatastrophe. Windows XP war immer noch eine Vollkatastrophe.
Ja, aber dann hat auch Microsoft eingesehen, dass es eine Vollkatastrophe ist und in den Jahren dann hat Microsoft sehr viel Bahnbrechendes getan im Bereich Security für Apps. Und da gab es sicherlich eine Phase von ein paar Jahren, wo sie Apple auch deutlich voraus waren. Manche würden auch noch sagen, auf dem Level, also von OS X jetzt oder Mac OS oder wie auch immer wir das jetzt nennen wollen, da ist immer noch eine Menge zu holen. Und ehrlich gesagt hätte ich auch jetzt noch mehr erwartet im Hinblick auf weitere Lockdown-Features in Mac OS. Da gab es halt jetzt zuletzt das System Integrity Protection Kram. Da muss noch mehr geschehen. Aber overall und insbesondere bei iOS oder allen iOS-Varianten, im Prinzip gibt es ja nur zwei Betriebssysteme. Es gibt eigentlich nur iOS, das läuft auf der Uhr, das läuft auf dem Telefon, das läuft auf dem Fernseher, hat nur andere User-Interfaces und ist anders stripped down, aber im Wesentlichen ist es dasselbe OS. Und eigentlich ist auch Mac OS dasselbe OS, nur dass das halt noch 30 Jahre Desktop-Craft mit sich herumträgt mit Installed Base-Software, die man halt nicht von heute auf morgen wegwerfen kann.
Ja, aber Mac OS ist halt nur noch ein nachrangiges OS für Apple. Das muss man einfach mal so sagen.
Aber das eröffnet jetzt die Kapitelmarke zum Thema Mac OS. Denn das ist ja eigentlich das, worüber wir reden wollen. Oder wollen wir über TV OS reden, ne?
Ich wüsste nicht, worüber ich das...
Sie können jetzt Single Sign On, aber ich hab kein... also, nächstes Thema.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, was das war. Du hast es hier hingeschrieben, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, was.
Ich finde den deutschen Markt aber nicht so interessant, oder?
Ja, zumindest noch nicht.
Ach so, dass du da bei diversen Diensten dich gleichzeitig anmelden kannst. Ja, haben wir. Ist durch. Durch.
Also Mac OS, Sierra und vor allem, es heißt jetzt Mac OS und mit kleinem M.
Aber noch eine kurze Zwischenfrage. Dieses iOS 10, was ja als iOS 10 ausgesprochen wird, schreibt man das dann auch als iOS X oder wie? Da kommt man aber auch ganz schön durcheinander.
Ja, das hat mich auch grob verwirrt in einigen Videos, weil sie von 10 sprachen und 10 war für mich so click A, dass es Mac OS, aber nein, es war ja mal iOS 10 und das ist also, naja, wie auch immer.
Sie wussten schon mal, warum sie das jetzt ändern, weil sie genau das gesehen haben mit dem iOS 10.
Das OS 10 zu nennen war schon immer ein Fehler.
So weit würde ich nicht gehen. So weit würde ich nicht gehen.
So X und so Unix, das fanden wir doch alle geil.
Ja, aber man hätte es ja auch so nennen können. Einfach OS X, warum nicht?
Na ja, aber nach 9 kam 10, also das ist schon ein Fehler.
Ja, sie hätten es ja trotzdem so verkaufen können, aber sie hätten es ja trotzdem OS X nennen können und dann so, ja, ihr wisst schon X, römische, hm, hm, hm. Dass man es die ganze Zeit nochmal so ausspricht. Und vor allem, ich meine, OS 10, Leerzeichen 10, 10. Ja, aber es gab das.
10, 10.
Es gab das. X, 10, 10. Dreimal die 10 hintereinander.
Also das ist OS X, also das ist das X, das römisch für 10 ist, das habe ich bis heute noch nicht mitbekommen. Nein, wirklich.
Nein, du kokettierst jetzt.
Nein, da bin ich nie drauf gekommen irgendwie. Weiß ich auch nicht. Irgendwie habe ich nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Wie lange machen wir dieses Podcast jetzt hier?
Was für eine goldene Medaille verleihen wir denn jetzt?
Oder ich hab's vergessen, aber...
Also ich bin ratlos.
Der Denis Ahrens Award für besondere Kenntnisse im historischen Zahlensystem.
Das goldene Kopfbissen verlangt schnell.
Das war halt schon so drin, irgendwie hab ich nie drüber nachgedacht. Ich nehme an, ich hab's vergessen.
Da hab ich es nicht draufgekommen.
Na gut.
So, jetzt Mac OS Sierra.
Es heißt Mac OS und es heißt dann aber trotzdem noch Sierra. Das muss ich persönlich sagen, also diese Namen geben mir... Naja, meinetwegen, aber... Ich hätte es trotzdem sehr geil gefunden, wenn sie es einfach Mac OS 12 genannt hätten.
Vor allen Dingen, also ganz ehrlich, sie haben es Mac OS Sierra gesagt und dann mit so einem Ton wie naja, das war doch klar und irgendwie mir war überhaupt nicht klar, warum man das jetzt Sierra nennt. Also das wär jetzt irgendwie mal eine Erklärung wert gewesen. Gut, das ist halt irgendein Ort, wahrscheinlich in Kalifornien, vielleicht auch da irgendwo, wo dieser ganze Yellowstone-Müll ist, aber irgendwie so zu tun, als wäre das völlig klar, warum das Sierra heißt, also mir nicht.
Das hab ich auch noch nicht verstanden, also irgendwelche Berge oder was.
Ist ein schöner Ort in Kalifornien.
Ich schlag das gerade mal nach. Sierra County, Kalifornia gibt es.
Ja, das wird's dann wohl sein.
A county located in the US state of California. Da wohnen 3240 Leute.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht auch Sierra Leone, dann ist es wieder eins von diesen Lines, also Mountain Lines.
The county is located in the Sierra Nevada. Das ist Kalifornien. Sierra Nevada ist dann halt daneben. Was weiß ich? Sierra. Ja, ja, ja. Heißt also Sierra und heißt irgendwie 10.12. Und das finde ich wirklich, also ich meine, warum? Why?
Das 10, wenn sie jetzt mal weglassen können.
Ich meine, warum nicht, ja oder 12. Sie hätten eigentlich letztes Jahr die Scheiße umbenennen müssen, als sie von 10.10 mit dem blöden El-Kapitan hätte Mac OS 11.
Vielleicht haben sie was größeres in Aussicht für 11. Oder sie haben sie jetzt halt einfach bereits nach 10.9, 10.10 und 10.11. Also jetzt ist es halt mit 11.
Kommt vielleicht nächstes Jahr dann noch.
Wollen sie jetzt Ewigkeiten, die die Versionsnummer vorne auf 10 behalten und hinten durchzählen? Wenn wir dann in Rente gehen, was ist dann? Oh ja, jetzt 10.37.
Also mal ganz ehrlich, mal ganz ehrlich. TVOS hat sich ja an die iOS zählweise angeschlossen. Das heißt, wir sehen jetzt nicht nur iOS 10, sondern auch TVOS 10.
Was bestätigt, dass es das gleiche ist, ne?
Wenn man das weiterdenkt, dann würde es nächstes Jahr iOS 11 geben, TVOS 11 und dann würde nichts dagegen sprechen, auch ein MacOS 11 dazu zu tun. Dann kann man auf der Watch auch gleich 11 machen und dann ist alles in Zynk und alles super.
Naja, das heißt, haben wir übernächstes Jahr dann nochmal 12, ja?
Ja, aber das passt ja insofern nicht zusammen, als das ja WatchOS 3 ist.
Ich sag ja, dann passt man WatchOS noch an, dann hast du auch WatchOS 11.
Der Vorteil von den Zahlen sind, weil wir uns jetzt immer unterhalten mit, ja weißt du noch, damals mit Snow Leopard und ja, welches kam denn danach und dann ja, da blickst du nicht mehr durch und wenn du von 10.6 sprichst, dann weißt du 10.7, 10.5, was davor ist und was danach ist, so kann ich mir das immer schwer merken mit den tausenden Namen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, mir ist es lieber, dass es konsistent ist, als wie bei Windows, wo nach Windows 8, Windows 10 kam, weil Windows 9 ausfiel wegen irgendeiner komischen Java-Variante, die halt auf den Prefix von dem Namens-String testet und deswegen unter Windows 9 halt irgendwie komplett die Hufe hoch nimmt. Also insofern, ich finde es jetzt nicht so schlimm, ja, immer nur die Zahl hinter dem Punkt zu ändern, seit Jahren ist irgendwie auch nicht schön, aber es ist wenigstens konsistent, also...
Nun denn, Zahlen mystik. Kommen wir auf, was eigentlich Sache ist. Was ist denn da neu? Also sie haben so ein bisschen Climbim angekündigt mit ihrer Continuity, neue Features, Universal Clipboard, das heißt du machst Copy auf irgendeinem Device und hast deine ganzen Clipboards auf...
Das finde ich übrigens mal gut, das hat mir schon öfter mal gefehlt.
Ja, zerhaut dir Clipboard von allen anderen Rechnern sozusagen.
Ja, nee, nee, das ist ja extra gespeichert, du hast ja ein extra Command, um das da rauszuholen, das zerhaut dir also gar nichts.
Ach, wie denn?
Na, Menü, da musst du da schon ein extra Command nehmen.
Copy from Cloud oder was? Kann man machen. Und dann Auto-Unlock mit der Apple Watch, das ist natürlich auch geil.
Ja, kommt doch an, wie sie implementieren, aber könnte geil sein, ja.
Hatte ich übrigens schon vor...
Wie mit der Apple Watch, nicht mit dem Phone?
Beides, glaube ich. Mit Touch ID war doch das Ding, oder? Genau.
Was heißt, dir klaut jemand deine Uhr unter den Rechner und du bist raus?
Watch ist ja sozusagen Touch ID mit Dauer in Apple.
Wieso?
Wieso? Na, bei Apple Pay muss ich ja nur meine Uhr wedeln, weil die ist schon sozusagen autorisiert, da muss ich ja nicht noch mal am Telefon Touch ID machen. Beim Telefon muss ich immer wieder Touch ID machen, um einen Autorisierungsvorgang einzuleiten. Die Watch weiß, dass ich sie die ganze Zeit am Arm habe.
Wenn du im Hotel bist und man schläft ja viel, weil man tagsüber mit den Wahlen schwimmen war, und dann klauen sie dir während du pennst, klauen sie deine Uhr da irgendwie vor dem Nachtstand und dann können die schon gleich los shoppen.
Aber die ist ja gelockt.
Dann ist sie ja nicht mehr. Erstens ist sie gelockt und zweitens ist sie ja nicht am Arm. Aber wenn ich sie am Arm mache und mich einmal mit Touch ID am Telefon anmelde.
Ja, dann ist sie anlockt.
Dann ist sie anlockt und dann kann ich Pay machen, aber wenn ich sie abnehme oder lade oder...
Genau, wenn du sie vom Arm runter machst, dann lockt sie sich.
Ich hab ja keine Uhr, ihr merkt das.
Aber das heißt, ich muss nicht Touch ID machen, um mich an meinen Rechner einzuloggen, sondern ich setz mich einfach mit der Uhr davor und das Ding ist einfach anlockt.
Ja, wenn das ausreichend gut funktioniert, dann sei...
Also ich hatte das, ich überleg jetzt gerade, wie lange das jetzt eigentlich her ist, aber ich hatte das mit meinem Motorola T68i Telefon. Wie alt ist das Ding? Ancient?
Reicht das als Altersangabe?
War das noch irgendwie 2000, irgendwann?
Keine Ahnung.
Also mindestens 10 Jahre muss es her sein, wahrscheinlich noch älter. Ich guck grad mal hier, von wann ist denn das Ding? 2000. Hallo? Ach Wikipedia, wie schön, dass du mir erklärst. Komm mal auf den Punkt. Ich versuch grad rauszufinden, wie alt das Ding ist.
Ist doch egal, es ist halt alt.
Ja genau, es interessiert keinen Schwein.
Mich interessiert das. Ah ja, 2001.
Also 15. Und was wolltest du genau erzählen?
Naja, das hatte halt Bluetooth. Und ich hatte damals auf meinem Mac eine Software, die hieß Sawling Clicker. Das war schon so Bluetooth Remote, dass du dein Telefon als Remote benutzen konntest für Präsentations und so weiter Kram. Das war so das allererste Telefon-Computer-Integration, was so halbwegs funktioniert hat.
Ja, du konntest einen Rechner mit dem Phone.
Welcher Computer hat denn als erstes Bluetooth eingebaut?
Ich weiß noch, dass ich irgendwann bei mir so ein Dongle gekauft hab, damit ich Bluetooth hab. Das muss auch so 2003 oder 2004 muss das so losgegangen sein.
Das Alubuck, glaube ich, war das erste. Dieses Pismo, dieses schwarze Plastik, hatte glaube ich noch keins.
Ich glaube, dafür habe ich auch mein Bluetooth-Dongle gekauft.
Was gab es in 2001 so für Computer? Da gab es iBooks.
Nee, Pismo gab es da. Ist das nicht Wallstreet?
Powerbook, das Titanium gab es.
Das kam danach, ja.
Und das hat aber noch keinen Bluetooth.
Ich finde, wir schweifen gerade ganz schön ab. Das ist nicht gut für den Flow.
Na ja, trotzdem finde ich das einfach cool, dass es jetzt sozusagen 15 Jahre später dieses Feature kommt. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also, dass man mit der Uhr oder mit dem Phone das Auto unlock hat.
Das ist aber praktisch, weil ich locken den ganzen Tag an meinem scheiß Laptop ein und das ist irgendwie nervig. So, und was ist jetzt noch neu? Dann haben sie den ganzen iCloud-Drive überarbeitet. Das gehört jetzt nicht wirklich so direkt zu macOS, aber die haben da diese merkwürdige...
Eine eigentlich interessante Ankündigung, die gar nicht auf der WWDC war, ist, dass um die iCloud-Services benutzen zu müssen, musst du deine Mac-App jetzt nicht mehr im App-Store haben, sondern außerhalb des Mac-App-Stores distributierte Apps können jetzt iCloud-Services benutzen. Das ist eigentlich...
Aber sie müssen schon immer noch mit Developer ID und gesigned sein und so.
Wer das heutzutage nicht macht, der gehört sowieso geteert und gefedert. So wie zum Beispiel diese Idioten von Open Office. Vor ungefähr einer Woche haben die ein Update gemacht, was sie nicht gesigned haben. Und dann hat der Updater dieses Update installiert und dann lief es nicht mehr. Ruf mich meine Mutter panisch an, ihr Open Office würde jetzt nicht mehr gehen. Das hat mich eine Weile gekostet am Telefon, bis ich rausgefunden hab, warum. Ja klar, rechtsklick und dann geht's wieder. Logisch, aber finde das mal heraus, weil der Updater von Open Office das in-place updated und dann hast du plötzlich in-place eine App, die nicht mehr geht, weil der dann auch irgendwie nicht sagt, dass es irgendwie daran liegt, dass es nicht designed ist. Also das war echt eine große Nummer, naja.
Dann gab's noch Kleinkram, so Picture in Picture, Video, alles ganz nett.
Ja, fand ich ganz niedlich. Ich hatte das ja mal installiert.
Hatte das nicht schon mal angekündigt? Das iOS konnte das schon irgendwie, ne?
Ja, aber das ist natürlich auch sehr sinnvoll, weil so oft hatten wir jetzt hier gerade mit Fußballgucken, in dem wir noch irgendwelche Dinge geregelt bekommen, schiebst du die ganze Zeit Fenster nach vorne, nach hinten.
Ja, wie gesagt, meine halbe Stunde mit Sierra, die ich da mal gebootet hab, da hab ich das auch ausprobiert. Das ist echt ein niedliches Feature. Vor allen Dingen, weil du dieses Picture in Picture-Ding wahllos platzieren kannst, was eigentlich ganz cool ist.
Daran haben sie noch bekannt gegeben, dass alle Apps, die dem Standard-Dokumenten-Modell folgen, jetzt automatisch die Fähigkeit erhalten, ihre Dokumente auch in Taps anzuordnen.
Und jeder, der irgendwie was mit Views macht und vor allen Dingen so diese Leute, die anfangen, in die Title Bar von dem Fenster Zeug reinzumachen, die werden wahrscheinlich ganz schön fluchen, weil das natürlich die gesamte View-Hierarchie durcheinanderbringt. Und es wird alles vorne und hinten nicht mehr funktionieren. Na ja, viel Spaß, sag ich nur.
Gut, meinst du, sie können das erkennen und dann automatisch das Feature abschalten für so eine App?
Der Fix, der dürfte nicht übermäßig schwierig sein, aber du musst ihn halt machen.
Ich meine, bevor jetzt sozusagen Apple da reinpfuscht und sagt, du hast jetzt Taps und dann geht die App nicht mehr.
Ja, im Prinzip schon. Ja, ich denke, das können sie erkennen.
Mal gucken, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sich das verhält. Macht aber im Prinzip Sinn. Und das hatte sich für meinen Geschmack ja auch schon mal abgezeichnet, als sie diese allerersten Tap-Erfahrung da in Safari hatten, wo die Taps noch irgendwie oben waren.
Ja, diese Chrome-Taps, ne? Ja, nee, also ich finde das prinzipiell eine gute Sache, dass sie das jetzt einfach mal allen Apps zur Verfügung stellen und dann nicht jeder irgendwie sein eigenes Süppchen kochen muss.
Ja, haben sie erstmal gut abgehangen im Safari und jetzt dürfen alle mitspielen. Ja, was noch neu?
iTunes gibt es nicht mehr, das heißt jetzt wirklich Music, ne? Ist die Marke iTunes jetzt so verbrannt, dass sie tatsächlich die App umbenannt haben?
Wie? Auf dem Mac gibt es kein iTunes mehr?
Ja, das heißt jetzt Music.
Wie, ich muss jetzt Music starten um einen Podcast?
Naja, so wie es kein iPhoto und kein iMovie mehr gibt. iPhoto heißt ja jetzt auch Fotos.
Warum heißt es da nicht Tunes? Die iTunes-App heißt jetzt Music.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen hab, ja.
Bist du sicher?
Also es wurde zumindest...
Ich will aber nicht meinen Podcast in Music haben.
Du willst die auch nicht in iTunes haben. Man will diese ganze Apple-Music-Welt sowieso nicht mehr. Also ich meine, dass sie einem die halbe Music-Library wegläuschen und meinen sie per Heuristik, man kriegt dann andere Versionen von seinen Songs da rein und so weiter. Das willst du alles nicht mehr. Das haben sie alles echt kaputt gemacht.
Da haben sie aber auch entschuldigt, das war ein Bug. Dass sie die Musik gelöscht haben dabei, Leute. Da haben sie extra sogar als einen Developer zu so einem Typen nach Hause gefahren, dann hat sich das angeguckt. Dann haben sie das gefixt und haben aber auch zurückgewählt. Das war wirklich ein Bug. Gut, dann jetzt die nächsten drei Dinge, weil die sind da alle von mir, die gehören alle so ein bisschen zusammen. Dann gibt es ja mal die Frage, auf welchen Rechnern läuft denn jetzt diese Sierra überhaupt? Weil die letzten Jahre war das nicht mehr so wichtig, weil Apple einfach gesagt hat, dass das OS, was gerade rauskommt, es läuft auf allen, die auch das letzte OS schon konnten.
Ja, so drei oder vier OSs haben nichts deprecated.
Ziemlich lange, oder? Fanden wir gut, oder? Weil da muss man jetzt nicht mehr so nachdenken. Das ist jetzt diesmal nicht mehr ganz so. Jetzt haben sie mal wieder ein paar Geräte über den Jordan geschossen. Aber nicht viele. Aber nicht viele. Und es ist noch nicht so ganz klar, nach welchen Kriterien das machen. Aber es kristallisiert sich vielleicht jetzt so langsam ein bisschen raus. Und zwar eine Sache ist wohl, dass der Kernel-Code und damit auch alle Apps können jetzt SS-E4 benutzen. Das heißt, alle CPUs, die das nicht haben, und dazu gehört zum Beispiel der Mac Pro 1 und der Mac Pro 2, also die heißen ja eigentlich 1.1 und 2.1, die fliegen schon mal raus, weil die haben CPUs, die das nicht können. Die haben noch kein SS-E4. Nimmst du mal die Maus da weg?
Penrin-Prozessoren von Intel, also Penrin-Variante der Core 2 Prozessoren haben SS-E4. Keine Ahnung, ab wann die jetzt in Macs zum Einsatz gekommen sind.
Ja, weiß ich auch nicht, aber...
Nein, er ist bei manchen Baureihen ab 2009 Schluss, bei anderen bei 2010. Also es ist irgendwie...
Jedenfalls ist das eine kleine Sache und das sind wahrscheinlich schon... SS-E4 wird schon ganz schön lange unterstützt, aber ein paar fliegen halt raus. Die andere Sache ist, dass wohl das User-Interface von Sierra wurde ja schon angekündigt mit dem davor hier mit El Capitan, aber jetzt machen sie es halt, ziehen sie es auch durch. Das User-Interface nutzt jetzt wohl tatsächlich Metal und es schnell wie Sau, alle sagen, diese Sierra flutscht wie Sau. Und aber um halt Metal zu nutzen, brauchst du halt auch die richtige Grafikkarte. Das könnte sein, warum dieser Mac Pro 4.1 den du auch hast, warum der eigentlich nicht geht, obwohl er CPU-mäßig das doch alles kann. Aber wahrscheinlich weil der Mac Pro 4.1 nie mit einer mit einer Metal-fähigen Grafikkarte ausgeliefert wurde und der Mac Pro 5.1, der eigentlich exakt die gleiche Hardware ist, aber da steckt da dann halt eine andere Grafikkarte drin, die vielleicht Metal-fähig war. Ich spekuliere jetzt ganz stark, aber das ist eventuell der Grund, warum gesagt hat, der 4.1er fliegt raus.
Weiß ich, ob meine Grafikkarte Metal kann?
Aber ich glaube, deine kann das, weil du hast ja auch nicht mehr die Originale drin. Du hast ja auch diese geflashte 6000er-Serie. Und ich denke, die sollte das können. Weil die ist ja auch auf jeden Fall schon neuer als das, was der Mac Pro 5.1 konnte, was damals ausgeliefert wurde.
Ich werde zu alt, ich vergesse mal wieder, wie meine Grafikkarte heißt.
6970 heißt die. Du hast einfach die... Du hast die rechts unten Grafikkarte aus der 6000er-Serie.
Ich habe eine AMD Radeon R9 280X.
Achso, du hast ja eine neue gekauft. Achso, ja, verstehe. Diese R9 280X, das ist eigentlich... Das ist auch Schummel von AMD, das machen die gerne und viel. Das ist eigentlich eine 7970. Das ist eigentlich die 7000er-Serie, die dann halt im Namen geändert wurde, als die nächste Serie rauskam. Das machen die immer so. Also wir sollten da mit diesen Karten, mit Metal haben wir keine Probleme. Das funktioniert da drauf.
7970, sagst du?
Das war ja noch Zeiten, als man diese ganzen Sachen noch runterrattern konnte. Na gut, du kannst es immer noch, aber...
Ich hab die halt, die anderen, mit Nvidia kenn ich mich immer nicht so aus. Ich lese da mal so ein bisschen mit. Aber so im Groben weiß ich schon, was gerade mal die coolen Grafikkarten sind.
Ich habe hier gerade einen beliebigen Blogartikel im Internet gefunden, der meint, die AMD Radeon 7979-70 supports Metal.
Aber auf jeden. Geilo!
Und da ich auch meine neue Firmware verpasst habe, bin ich sehr erfreut, mit meinem 2009er Schlachtschiff auch die 2016 Systemsoftware, Sierra Leone zu begrüßen.
Wir haben tatsächlich noch Hörer, die uns zum ersten Mal hören und die letzten Sendungen verpasst haben. Man kann seinen Mac Pro 4,1 umflaschen auf einen 5,1, weil es exakt die gleiche Hardware ist, nur ist nicht die richtige Firmware drin. Das ist auch keine gefuschte Firmware, sondern nur der Installer, ein bisschen geändert, damit die Original Apple Firmware reingeflasht wird, was der Installer von Apple normalerweise für den 4,1 verweigern würde. Man hat danach die Original Apple Firmware in seinem 4,1 und nur dadurch wird er zu einem 5,1, kein anderer Unterschied mehr.
Tatsächlich ist es so, dass die Firmware von dem Installer von einer Apple URL in dem Moment während der Installation geladen wird, wobei das jetzt gebrochen ist, weil die URL sich auf dem Web-Server geändert hat.
Dann bringt er das jetzt noch mal mit der neuen URL raus.
Man kann aber die Datei bei Apple runterladen, als Disk Image, mounten und wenn man den Installer startet, während das Ding gemountet ist, dann holt er sich das von dem gemounteten Image automatisch. Also er checkt erstmal, ist das Ding lokal gemountet. Sonst macht er Zugriff im Web. Also von daher...
Alter, kriegt Apple sowas eigentlich mit? Merken die das, die vielleicht mal ein Pro-Gerät wieder rausbringen können? Also diese Mülltonne ist doch irgendwie... Lassen wir das fast zu. Lassen wir die Mülltonne zu.
Bei der Mülltonne müssen sie halt noch mal so eine WatchOS 3-Style-Announcement machen. Jetzt auch in geil.
Ja, aber das ist doch Mac Pro Watch Edition, oder? Also ich meine, das ist so irgendwie... Das Teil kannst du doch an den Arm schnallen, das ist doch kein Rechner.
Meinst du, es gibt jetzt vielleicht den Mac Pro auch in Gold?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
In Blau hätte ich den gerne. Es gibt ja Gerüchte, dass iPhone 7 auch in Blau kommt.
So Jeansfarben oder was?
Also Alu ist ja ein Alugehäuse. Und das kann man ja nur in gewissen Farben hier eloxieren. Und Blau ist halt mit dabei.
Also Königsblau, glaube ich, war es so. Was früher so die Tintenpatronen hatten.
Würde ich nicht so verkehrt finden.
Das war doch so ein iMac, oder?
Schlimm, schlimm.
Diese Ziffer iMacs.
Wie ist das zweite Wort?
Dalmatian.
Dalmatian, was ist denn das?
Na ja, das ist halt dieser... Dalmatianer-Look, also diese gefleckte...
Ja gut, aber das kriegen die so nicht hin, auf dem Alu.
Es gab halt auch noch den Flower-Power iMac. Wieso? Ist doch geil.
Ich fand es jetzt nicht schlecht.
Wieso nicht?
Wer's mag.
Es gab den auch irgendwie in so einem komischen Schwarz noch. Grafit.
Ist egal. Jedenfalls, ich find's ziemlich geil, weil mein Rechner wird weiter mit sehr funktionieren, weil mein 4.1 iMac Pro ist auch auf 5.1 gepatcht. Natürlich. Und ich freu mich schon auf einen UI, was jetzt noch besser flutschen wird, als vorher, weil ehrlich gesagt, ich konnte da schon im User-Interface nichts Langsames am User-Interface machen.
Geht immer schneller.
Sieht man dann, wenn man, also das muss man erst live erleben, dass man sagt, oh ja, es flutscht ja. Das hat ja einen Grund, warum. Ich hab hier ein paar Leute gelesen, die meinten, dass es flutschen wird, dieses Jahr.
Ich fand El Capitan schon schneller, also ich fand überhaupt ja mit den letzten OS-Releases immer kleine Schritte gemacht. Bei El Capitan fand ich den Schritt noch mal größer. Aber das mag auch immer dieser Update-Effekt sein. Das schnellste User-Interface, was ich in meinem Leben erlebt habe, auch wenn das natürlich nur begrenzt vergleichbar ist.
Warte, jetzt kommt Tim wieder mit BOS.
Ich hätte auch BOS geraten, aber...
Es ging noch schneller als BOS.
Was denn?
Mein Microsoft Xenics, mein SCO Xenics auf meinem 82-86er, AT-kompatiblen Computer 1990. Entschuldigung. Das war einfach...
Das ist kein User Interface. Das ist Textwüste.
Nein, es ist Text. Aber glaubst du, dass ein McIntosh, heutiger Bauhalt, mit einer Million Mal mehr CPU-Cycles pro Sekunde...
Wenn du im Textmodus startest, schon.
Ich erwarte ihre selber Responsiveness im Text Terminal. Und die ist einfach nicht gegeben.
Naja, mit Sierra vielleicht. Aber wahrscheinlich ist der Unterschied bei einem Retina...
Das findet ihr wohl unwichtig.
Ich hol mir erstmal ein Bier.
Mir auch eins, bitte. Es kann durchaus sein, dass du bei Retina-Macks den Unterschied viel deutlicher merkst, weil die mehr schieben müssen.
Das ist jetzt nicht so wenig. Es ist jetzt noch kein Retina.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so dieses MacBook, weißt du da, dieses Flachding, dieser R-Nachfolger mit Retina.
Ich hab im schnellen Rechner eine fette Grafikkarte und noch nicht so eine mega hohe Auflösung. Es gibt natürlich Rechner, die weniger Grafik-Power haben, aber eine höhere Auflösung.
Bei so einem MacBook könnte es durchaus sein, dass das verdammt viel bringt.
Auf jeden Fall darf es nicht mehr als ein verticales Green Refresh dauern, neuen Text auf den Bildschirm zu bringen.
Kommt jetzt wieder metallisches UI? Oder wie war das?
Ja. Ja genau. Wenn das Ding Metal heißt, dann möchte ich auch gerne wirklich den metallischen Anschlag. Klang, Klang, dass da nicht auch nur noch ein Molekül Luft dazwischen passt.
Prost auf den metallischen Anschlag. Wir machen mal gläsernen Anschlag.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ihr das SS4 unterstützen zum Speed mit dazu beiträgt, aber vielleicht auch ein bisschen. Warum nicht? Sie heben die Latte ein bisschen an, was eine CPU unterstützen muss, die halt modern ist.
Vielleicht ist das Teil von Metal, das das SS4 hat.
Genau, also SS4 ist im Wesentlichen die CPU-Neuerung, die Intel Ende 2009 ins Feld geführt hat.
Wer sich noch erinnert, früher an MMX, bei Funktions MMX. SSE ist eigentlich die Fortsetzung davon.
Aber mein Mac Pro von 2009, der hat ja dann keine CPUs, die SS4 haben.
Das gibt es wirklich schon eine Weile.
Krieg ich denn raus, was ich für eine CPU habe hier?
Dein Mac Pro meinst du oder was? Ja, der SS4.
Warum?
Na, weil du da ein Westmere-CPU drin hast. Und die kann das.
Westmere?
M-E-R-E.
Wo sagt denn dieses Teil?
Westmere Microarchitecture. Achso, nee warte, die kamen 2010 raus. Dann hast du nicht Westmere, ich hab Westmere, du hast noch Nehalem.
Im Mac-Tracker?
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf. Ich hab halt auch so eine Kiste. SSE hat auch schon SSE 4.2. Ja, haste. Alles entspannt bei dir.
Wo hast du das jetzt gerade nachgeschlagen?
Ich hab Google gefragt. Ich mag ja Google nicht, aber sie antwortet immer so schnell.
Also ich hab Intel Xeon 3500 oder 5500, Bloomfield, Gainstown.
Ja, das ist denn der, aber das ist ja, das ist der Untername. Ich hab ja nach dem Oberbegriff gesucht, glaube ich. Und Oberbegriff ist Ordinehalem Microarchitektur. Du hast den Sockel 1366 und du, weil du zwei CPUs drin hast, musst du auf jeden Fall die 5000er Intel-Serie haben, also die 5500, weil das geht nur mit den Dual-Sockets.
So, welcher ist denn das jetzt, der Early 2009 oder mit 2010?
Early 2009 hat der Timme.
Early 2009, also der Mac-Tracker behauptet... Was behauptet der denn? Der behauptet gar nichts. Von Prozessor doch hier Xeon 3500 oder 5500. Bloomfield, Gainstown. Also das ist jetzt, ich zitiere Mac-Tracker.
Und da steht da nicht dabei, welche Architektur das ist?
Nein, Mac-Tracker nicht. Da steht nur Intel Xeon 3500 oder 5500.
Bloomfield und Gainstown.
Bloomfield und Gainstown, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das für den Hörer jetzt wieder so spannend ist.
Klar.
Bloomfield, Gainstown, Linfield, die Intel Xeon-Serie auf Basis der Intel Nehalem Microarchitektur. Microarchitektur, so. Also das ist Nehalem. Und Nehalem kann SSE 4.
Habe ich nicht gerade eben gesehen, dass es Gainstown und Bloomfield ist?
Ja, und Linfield auch noch. Das sind die Unternahmen für spezielle CPU-Reihen. Und dieses Nehalem ist sozusagen das Gesamte, die Architektur. 2010 kam dann sozusagen ein Update. Diese Architektur, die hieß Westmeer, das ist die CPU, die ich bei mir eingebaut habe, aber nachträglich, die gab es für den Mac Pro ja von Apple erstmal nicht. Aber dann 2010 hat Apple dann hier die Westmeers verbaut. Die sind nicht nur. Nanometer sind die ein bisschen kleiner, sparen mehr Strom und so weiter und so fort.
Okay, dann feier ich das mal kurz ab hier.
Weiter in einem Leben, aber dann könnte dann schon langsam nächstes Jahr eng werden.
Das Ding hält noch lange durch.
Weiß nicht, was nächstes Jahr für Anforderungen kommen. Aber es könnte eng werden. Vielleicht vierer jetzt schon rausgekickt ist, kann sein, dass wir nächstes Jahr mit einem Fünfer weitermachen.
Ich nehme einfach spirituellen Kontakt mit Tim Cook auf.
Und sag ihm, dass er mal wieder ein richtiger Mac Pro ist.
Genau.
Wenn ich aus dem OS-Cycle rausbreche, dass es dann einfach erforderlich ist, dass die passende Maschine am Start sein muss. So, das wär geklärt.
Aber ich bin ja schon vorbereitet. Ich hab ja gesagt, an dem Tag, wo mein Kiste nicht mehr von einem aktuellen OS X, also von Mac OS unterstützt wird, so heißt das ja jetzt, FreeBSD ist schon am Warten. Die scharren schon mit den Hufen. Die wollen sozusagen ran.
Woran?
An meinen Mac Pro, FreeBSD. Also Mac OS nicht mehr geht, dann werd ich da FreeBSD drüber bügeln.
Gutest du Mac OS denn schon von ZFS?
Nee, noch nicht. Aber es wäre dann auch das nächste Thema, hab ich da auch aufgeschrieben. Das kommt dann, wenn wir uns über File Systems unterhalten. Das wär jetzt auch soweit. Achso, aber diese kleine Sache da noch, genau. Und zwar diese Jungs hier bei Netcast, was ist das? Netcast Org, die ja auch immer hier dieses Gepatch von 4.1 auf 5.1 machen und die auch hier die Grafikkarten patchen, damit man da ewig Support hat und ein Boot-Screen bekommt und so weiter. Bei denen stand, dass sie da so ein bisschen rum experimentiert haben mit diesen Serien und haben da auch reingeguckt. Sie haben herausgefunden, dass da die Treiber für diese Fury-GPUs von AMD drin sind. Wer sich erinnert, das ist ein paar Monate her, hat mit dem aktuellen Polaris, glaube ich, nichts zu tun. Aber da hat AMD eine R9 Nano rausgebracht, hieß die, glaube ich. Die verbrauchte ziemlich wenig Strom, war auch kurze Bauform, also wirklich relativ klein. Hat aber dafür, dass sie so klein war, ganz schön viele Bums. Also es war natürlich keine mega high-end-Karte, aber sie war auf jeden Fall schon oben mit dabei, so mittlere Liga, wie auch immer. Also eine sehr nette Karte, weil auch wenig Strom verbraucht. Und dafür sind jetzt Treiber in Sierra mit dabei. Das heißt, wenn einer so eine Karte haben will, dann müsste das mit Sierra funktionieren. Bootscreen hat man da erstmal noch nicht. Da muss man dann gucken, was die Hacker denn da so machen. Der Typ heißt ja netkras auch selbst. Und ja, ich finde das gut, weil dann ist so eine aktuelle Karte, die man wieder in seinen Mac Pro stecken könnte. Und die sich sogar an den zur Verfügung gestellten Strom irgendwie damit auskommt und nicht zu viel zieht. So wie die Karten, die wir jetzt haben, die ziehen ja eigentlich ein bisschen zu viel für den Mac Pro.
Sind die jetzt toller als meine, diese Furies?
Ja, sind ja viel neuer. Wie gesagt, deine ist ja, die heißt mal 280, aber ist eigentlich nur die beste Grafikkarte von ein, zwei Jahre von davor. Diese dann als 280 war sozusagen die zweitbeste Karte, weil die 290er kamen ja raus, irgendwie so. Und dann labeln sie das halt um, damit sie, weißt schon, damit das von den Namen irgendwie alle Sinn macht. Aber eigentlich ist deine Karte die, wann ist das? Ist jetzt auch schon vier, fünf Jahre alt oder so. Vier, ja vier, doch vier, fünf Jahre könnte passen. Ich glaube, 2011 kam die 6000er-Serie. Kann sein, dass es 2012 war, als die 7000er-Serie kam. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher. Ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Karte, wie gesagt. Hat mehr Bums, glaube ich, als die, die wir drin haben und das bei weniger Stromverbrauch. Also ist nicht so schlecht. Also wenn die mit Bootscreen-Support, mit dem EFI Firmware oder EFI Bios rauskommen, dann würde ich da sofort wechseln.
22. Dezember 2011 ist sie vorgestellt worden. Also 2012 quasi.
Ja, also viereinhalb Jahre alt. Da ist schon aber einiges passiert seitdem.
Bisschen was.
Ja gut, aber ich hab immerhin eine High-End-Karte, die noch mal drei Jahre jünger ist als meinen Rechner selber.
Ja, und vor allem tausendmal besser als die Karte, die ja original drin war.
Und wenn du meinst, sie kriegen Fury dann... Also Fury, der Treiber, ist schon in Sierra drin?
Genau.
Aber warum kann man dann nicht davon booten?
Weil beim Bootscreen dein OS ja noch nicht gestartet ist, sondern das halt die Firmware des Rechners macht. Und die Firmware will halt... Der fragt auf dem PCI-Bus nach irgendwie Zeugs und wenn die Karte das nicht hat, dann erkennt er die nicht und...
Okay, aber für einen zweiten Screen oder sowas...
Auf jeden Fall, ja...
.würde man das machen. Das sind diese R300 oder was? Was ist denn das für eine bekloppte...
Versuch das doch nicht zu...
Nee, Fury X war glaube ich die große und es gab eine Fury Nano. Die große kann man dann auch nehmen, weil Fury ist Fury. Also das ist sozusagen auch die gesamte Architektur.
Also es gibt X, nur Fury und Fury Nano.
Genau, Fury Nano ist die geile, die so wenig Strom verbraucht. Die so ein bisschen kleiner ist als der Rest, aber man kann auch sich die Fette rein machen, natürlich.
Ah, Mini-ITX Format, also richtig Compactomat. Verstehe. Na gut, genug CPU, GPU, Generde. Tatsache ist, auch mit dem Mac Pro kann man immer noch in den Sonnenuntergang reiten.
Na nicht nur reiten, sondern an den anderen vorbei. Na ist immer so, die machen immer wieder Benchmarks, so aufgerüsteter Classic Mac Pro, so nennen wir das. Sie nennen das ja CMP, wenn die da so Kurzsprech machen, weil die Kürze ist ab, das heißt dann CMP. Und der Neue heißt der NMP, New Mac Pro. Und da machen die immer wieder Benchmarks und jedes Mal der Classic Mac Pro räumt diese neuen Dinge ab. Also jetzt nicht bei CPU-Power natürlich, weil da haben die Neuen ja auch richtig fett was drin. Wobei so ein Classic kann ja auch Dual Hexachore kann man sich da reinpacken für richtig Geld, wobei inzwischen ist es billig. Aber da können die nicht, glaube ich, ganz mithalten. Aber so GPU-Power kannst du halt alles Mögliche in dein Mac Pro reinstecken und auch an sonstige Karten. Und da macht der Classic Mac Pro den neuen einfach locker platt. Dieses Alteisen ist wirklich das beste Stück Hardware, was ich lange hatte.
Ja, definitiv auch echt. Also ich hab mit dem Mac Pro und mit dem R2013 die besten Macs ever, die ich je hatte.
Wobei mein Pismo war auch geil. Mit den zwei Batterien, ich fand das geil.
Pismo mit zwei Batterien.
Genau. Hatte ich damals schon sieben Stunden. Okay, mit zwei Batterien.
So, genug vom Krieg erzählt, kommen wir zum eigentlichen Thema des Abends.
Yeah, ein neues Verhältnis.
Wollen wir erstmal klatschen?
Ja, aber warte, warte. Genau, Slow clap.
Slow clap?
Ja.
Warum? Weil es so lange gedauert hat?
Erstens.
Und?
Zweitens. Wie sagt man? Too little, too late, ja. Irgendwie so.
Bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher.
Ich mir schon.
Äh, es gibt ein...
Was ist passiert? Also, Apple hat unter anderem ein neues Fallsystem vorgestellt. Lange vorher gesagt.
Mit dem Namen APFS wie Apple File System.
Scheiß Name.
Boah, ich find den nicht so verkehrt, ehrlich gesagt. Gut, man hält ihn noch AFS, aber das war bestimmt schon vergeben.
Nee, das war schon... Das ist schon vergeben. Andrew File System.
Ja, das wäre nicht gegangen, aber man hätte sich sicherlich...
Ich finde APFS jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Das ist auch total egal in der Zukunft.
Das ist sowieso Nerd-Kram.
Ja, genau. Sieht ja unten runter.
Da kannst du auch ein Nerd-Name haben. Also das ist dann nicht egal.
Wenn du die Leute heute fragst auf der Straße, wie ihr File System heißt, fragen sie erst, was ein File System ist. Die, die wissen, was ein File System ist, können auch nicht antworten. Zu 90 Prozent.
Ist mir doch scheiß egal.
Genau.
Das ist auch eine valide, richtige Antwort. Ist mir scheiß egal.
Genau. Also, ein File System ist ein Thing. Und es ist noch etwas unklar, woraus es genau besteht. Ich würde sagen, auf den ersten Blick besteht es nahezu alle unsere geäußerten Anforderungen, die wir schon immer in ein zukünftiges Dateisystem gehabt haben. Mit der Ausnahme des Check-Zooming wurden dem noch nicht ganz klar, ob es nun da ist oder nicht.
Es ist klar, dass es nicht da ist. Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt.
Weil sie es so gesagt haben.
Weil da gab es diesen einen Typen, der hat die Leute gelöchert im Lab und die haben gesagt nein.
Adam Nebenthal ist nämlich einer der Programmierer von ZFS. Der hat zum Beispiel das G-SIP-Compression in ZFS eingebaut und ist da lange mit dabei. Also wirklich ein Top-Developer bei ZFS. Denen haben die wohl auf die WWDC geschmuggelt. Der hatte eigentlich keine Karte, aber er hat eine bekommen von irgendjemand, der wollte, dass er da speziell hingeht und die da wegen diesem APFS löchert.
Wussten die das schon vorher?
Wenn der Jumpaolo oder wie heißt der, der ist ja der, wie war das? Das war der File-System-Schreiber von BIOS, der das BI-File-System geschrieben hat. Den Apple ja vor zehn Jahren irgendwann übernommen hat. Oder wann war das? Das ist schon eine Weile her, ne?
Eine Weile, aber ich glaube keine zehn Jahre.
Der muss ja auch durch einen Tal der Tränen gegangen sein. Von BFS zu HFS Plus.
Na, wenn er das neu machen darf, ist ja okay.
Ja, aber jetzt ist 2014. Was hat er die ganzen anderen Jahre gemacht?
Wir wissen es nicht.
Doch, aber was wir wissen ist, er war entscheidender Grund, warum ZF nicht genommen wurde. Er war dagegen wohl.
Ja, da gab es ja viele Geschichten. Und das hatte auch viel mit Oracle, und mit Zeiten und Lizenzen und hin und her zu tun. Das wird wahrscheinlich nie so 100% aufgeklärt werden. Aber was ich auch noch gelesen hatte, frage mich jetzt mal bitte nicht nach der Quelle, aber das ist halt professionell geäußertes Halbwissen, es hat wohl drei Anläufe gegeben.
Ja, das hab ich auch schon gelesen.
Das APFS, was wir jetzt sehen, ist der dritte.
Ist erst zwei Jahre alt.
Das dritte Ergebnis. Man weiß es nicht, man weiß ja auch nicht, was dann, also sie werden ja nicht immer wieder...
Und ob ZFS schon einer dieser Anläufe war?
Ob ZFS einer dieser Anläufe war, ich hab so gelesen als nicht. Und weiß ja auch nicht, wie lange diese Anläufe gehalten haben. Und nur weil du einen neuen Anlauf machst, heißt ja nicht, dass du alles in Frage stellst. Also bestimmte Dinge wie Encryption und so weiter sind irgendwie dann auch immer noch dasselbe. Es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass sie jetzt angekündigt haben, dieses Fallsystem nicht nur zu bringen, sondern, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ab nächstem Jahr auch als Grundlage aller ihrer Betriebssysteme einschließlich WatchOS auszuliefern.
2017, ja. Das heißt wahrscheinlich mit den jeweils nächsten Versionen der OS.
Genau, davon gehe ich aus. Und sie haben eine Möglichkeit, in-place das Fallsystem zu ändern. Das heißt, du hast HFS und dann läuft im Hintergrund der Demon und der schrubbelt dir das irgendwie über Nacht langsam zu einem APFS, während du damit weiterarbeiten kannst.
Ja, das ist ein interessantes Feature.
Das ist in der Tat ein interessantes Feature.
Also nicht für diesen einmaligen Vorgang, weil den macht man ja nur einmal, aber das kann ja eventuell auch in der Zukunft deine Sachen ändern. Vielleicht kann das ja auch so wie 5 Volt dir unterm Arsch während du arbeitest dein System verschlüsseln. Da weiß ich nicht, ob das...
Ja, das bestimmt auch, weil ich meine, das können sie ja heute schon.
Aber nicht on the fly, sie können verschlüsseln. Aber vielleicht macht dieses Tool ja das auch on the fly, während du damit arbeitest und sagt ok, ich bin jetzt fertig, ab jetzt ist verschlüsselt.
Ja, aber das macht doch 5 Volt schon. Heute.
Ja, aber du musst einmal neu booten.
Du musst einmal neu booten, damit er damit anfängt, ja. Aber dann, wenn du neu gebootet hast, kannst du das System verwenden. Aber mit dem booten startet er.
Ist nicht so, dass du warten musst zum Ende und erst dann ist alles verschlüsselt, sondern du bootest einmal und ab dem Moment ist alles on the fly im Prozess verschlüsselt zu werden.
Genau.
Und ich würde vermuten, dass das hier ähnlich läuft. Also erstmal sprachen sie davon, es sei SSD-optimized. Das hatten wir hier auch schon vermutet. Dass, wenn sie jetzt in die Zukunft gehen, dass sie dann auch modernen Storage-Systems im Blick haben. Aber es geht auch für Platten.
Ja, aber das Ding ist wohl, dass sie es so optimiert haben, heutige SSD-Controller optimiert arbeiten können. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie wirklich in dieses Stack der SSD-Storage da rein gehen, sondern sie haben es einfach nur darauf optimiert.
Ja, keine Zylinder mehr und so.
Das Ding ist ja, dass SSDs halt eben keine Blöcke mehr haben, die ein halbes Kilobyte groß sind wie Festplatten, wobei die inzwischen ja auch bei 4 Kilobyte sind. Also diese Advanced Formatting, die kleineren haben glaube ich immer noch ein halbes Kilobyte, sondern SSDs haben glaube ich sogar 8 Kilobyte.
Ja, die immer gleichzeitig gelöscht werden.
Genau, das geht nicht einzeln. Das heißt, darauf können sie sich so ein bisschen einschießen, dass sie das halt wissen, sonst musst du immer erst, wenn du nur ein halbes Kilobyte schreiben willst, und du kannst aber nur 8 Kilobyte schreiben, dann musst du erst die anderthalb 7 Kilobyte einlesen, damit du weißt, was da stand, damit du es dann insgesamt als 8 Kilobyte rüberschreiben kannst, weil du kannst ja eben nur 8 schreiben. Also da müssen die schon ein bisschen aufpassen, dass wenn die das mit SSD Optimized meinen, das andere wäre dann, dass sie Trim supporten, was ja aber schon längst da ist, dann was du gerade meintest, dass...
Nein, sie haben aber gesagt, dass sie tatsächlich Trim auch out of the box unterstützen, auch für alle Geräte. Ja. Das haben sie gesagt.
Was heißt für alle Geräte? Also ich hab gesagt, sie unterstützen Trim.
Ja, du hattest eine Weile lang hattest du dieses Ding, das nur wenn du eine Apple SSD hattest...
Ach so, aber das haben sie ja aufgegeben.
Trim tatsächlich unterstützt wurde.
Haben sie ja aufgegeben, das ist jetzt ja für alle.
Okay, ja, also sie unterstützen Trim.
Sie haben jetzt offiziell zur Kenntnis genommen, dass es Trim gibt.
Also das, was sie vor einem Jahr eingeführt haben, haben sie jetzt noch mal bestätigt, dass es ab jetzt Trim ist. Aber, weil du meintest, dass sie da mit diesem SSD Optimized hier in die Zukunft gucken, ich finde SSDs schon lange nicht mehr Zukunft, sondern es ist Gegenwart Zukunft, sind zur Zeit ja diese Shingled Magnetic Recordings oder wie heißt das, SMR, das ist, wo eine Spur, damit du mehr drauf kriegst, so leicht die vorherige Spur überschreibt und du kannst die vorherige Spur nicht überschreiben, ohne die danach kaputt zu machen. Das heißt, so wie Dachziegeln, du kannst nur anlegen, aber du kannst nicht mehr Sachen von davor ändern, ohne alles neu zu machen. Deswegen Shingled, also wie Dachziegel. Und damit kriegen die mehr auf eine Platte. Und da gibt es verschiedene Ansätze, wie man sich darum kümmert. Und davon habe ich halt zum Beispiel nichts gehört. Das ist bei ZFS, da reden die schon drüber, bei anderen Filesystems wahrscheinlich auch, wie man diese Festplatten unterstützt. Weil das sind halt die neuen Monster, die kommen, diese 8-TB und 10-TB Platten, das sind sogenannte Shingled Magnetic Recording.
Na ja, also der Vortrag über dieses APFS klang so, als wäre Spinning Rust nicht bei denen auf dem Radar funktioniert, ist ihnen aber egal.
Ja, aber das ist halt nicht egal. Ja, aber da kommt dann ihr Fallsystem auch einfach nicht zum Tragen. Also so eine Platte hast du halt in großen Serverinstallationen, in irgendwelchen Rates, in irgendwelchen Backup-Backends, in großen Data Storage-Klatsalationen.
Klar, 98% der Leute werden das nicht nutzen, aber natürlich gibt es eine Menge Leute, die ihre Moviesammlung haben, ihre Mega-Monster-Bildersammlung, die alles in ihrem Leben irgendwie aufheben und machen und tun, oder Leute, die viele Videos aufnehmen. Das ist aber traurig, wenn Apple da sagt, die sind uns egal.
Ich glaube, das ist dann Apple aber auch ganz schön egal.
Du heulst eine ganze Menge rum und sagst, du willst hier dein Kalender-Feature usw. Dann sag ich auch, das braucht niemand außer du. Da bist du sogar wirklich der Einzige.
Du hänselst mich ja auch immer damit. Also darf ich auch zurückhänseln. Okay, dann kriegen wir halt so einen Durchschnitt beim Thema. Ja, wie auch immer. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass eine neue Aufzeichnungstechnik bei Festplatten irgendwie die Zukunft ist. Sondern das ist nichts anderes. Das ist so ein bisschen wie VDSL. Wir holen mehr raus.
Factoring ist Glasfaser.
Genau, Factoring ist Glasfaser und SMR ist die Zukunft von SSDs. Sie sagen, Ihre Geräte, die Devices, die Sie ausliefern, die Sie bauen und von denen Sie meinen, dass man sie an Ihren Computer mehrheitlich primär betreibt, anschließt, da ist einfach viel Flash am Start. Und mal ehrlich, auch diese 10TB und diese ganzen Steigerungen bei Festplatten, das mag ja ganz interessant sein, aber diese Steigerungen werden wir bei SSD auch haben. Das wird sich verdoppeln und nochmal verdoppeln und nochmal verdoppeln und irgendwann hast du diese scheiß Festplattenkacke, ist die dann einfach nicht mehr wirtschaftlich. Und wenn dann erstmal anfängt, irgendwie der erste oder der zweite Hitachi oder Seagate die Tore zu schließen, dann ist die Technologie auch in 2-3 Jahren vom Tisch.
Ja, kann sein.
Und dann bauen einfach alle nur noch Flash.
Aber zur Zeit sieht es auch noch nicht so richtig aus. Also sind einfach nochmal deutlich günstiger. Und für so einen Daten-Grab, für ein Schrank legen, ist so eine Platte immer noch gut.
Ja klar, weil es noch andere Märkte gibt. Aber das ist halt jetzt Daten-Grab, ein Schrank legen ist nicht unbedingt ein Design-Goal für ein File-System von Apple. Die haben jetzt nicht so...
Ganz offensichtlich nicht, nein.
Alles, wo ein Bit drauf kann, das ist nicht ihr Target, sondern ihr Target ist, wir brauchen ein File-System, was mit wenig RAM auskommt, mit wenig CPU auskommt.
Von der Watch bis zum Mac Pro, haben sie gesagt.
Genau, Mac Pro mag das ja auch alles haben, aber die Watch hat es definitiv nicht. Sie haben auch betont, dass sie mit das Low Latency ein Ziel war.
Und nicht Performance.
Nachvollziehbar, also es geht nicht um maximales Ruput, wenn man irgendwie massenhaft Daten liest, weil das ist Ihnen in der Regel schnell genug und wenn du schneller brauchst, holst du dir das schnellere SSD und dann ist die Sache geritzt. Aber die Latenz ist immer entscheidend. Also wie lange dauert es, wenn ein kleiner Block angefragt wird, bis der dann wirklich geliefert werden kann.
Genau, das haben sie ja auch gesagt.
Das ist, finde ich, ein geiles Goal. Dann haben sie halt Encryption leicht eingebaut und kombinieren im Prinzip den Mac Style, also File Vault, sprich On Disk, Block Encryption, Full Disk Encryption.
Ja, komplette Disk mit einem Key.
Genau.
Im Gegensatz zu jedes File mit einem anderen Key.
Sie können beides.
Und sie können jetzt beides, das heißt sie vereinigen im Prinzip den iOS-Ansatz mit dem macOS-Ansatz. Sie haben Multi-, wie haben sie es genannt? Sie hatten da wieder irgendein Buzzword. Also im Prinzip, wenn du eine Partition mit APFS machst, kannst du da mehrere Volumes drauf haben. Also Apples Sprache für Filesystem, so wie das bei ZFS auch ist. Also was bei ZFS dein Pool ist, da sind Filesysteme drauf. Wo Filesysteme drauf sind und wo das Anlegen eines Filesystems erstmal nicht mehr, nennst du es mehr, mehr Platz verbraucht als ein normales Directory.
Das ist eine komplikere Operation.
Wenn es schnell geht und mal eben so ein neuer Mountpoint dargeschafft wird, der seine eigenen Parameter haben kann, so oder so ähnlich wird es bei APFS auch aussehen. Das heißt, du hast halt deine Partition, wir haben es jetzt nicht Partition, sondern wir haben gesagt, was war ihr Begriff? Volumen? Und da drüber war?
Container oder so.
Sie sprachen von einem Container. Du machst einen Container, ein Container ist in der Regel eine Festplattenpartition.
Die in der Größe fest ist. Sie hatten so was gesagt, wie die derzeitige Beta kann aber nicht richtig Partitionen und irgendwie zumindest kannst du keinen Fusion-Drive oder so, also es war ein bisschen merkwürdig, was die derzeitige Version kann.
Ja, es gibt derzeit Einschränkungen, aber grundsätzlich ist es so, du hast halt einen fixed storage space, wie zum Beispiel die Partition einer Festplatte, die dann in der Regel die ganze Festplatte ist. Und darin kannst du beliebig viele Volumes anlegen. Heute mit HFS heißt Volumen eben innerhalb dieser Partition. Nein, nein, die Partition ist die Partition und darin hast du Volumes, aber die Volumes sind fixed size.
Ja, ja, weil die Volumes so groß sind wie die Partition. Bei HFS Plus ist das synonym, mehr oder weniger.
Nein, das ist nicht so. Die Partition ist die Partition und darin hast du Volumes.
Ja, schon, aber die Größe unterscheidet sich nicht, weil das Datalsystem das nicht kann. Also du kannst natürlich das so ein bisschen schrinken und dann kannst du die Partitionsgrenzen verschieben, aber du kannst...
Ist das nicht so, dass die Partition auf BIOS-Ebene vom OS, vom HFS in mehrere Volumes geteilt wird, die das BIOS nicht unterscheiden?
BIOS, du meinst... EFI Firma. Genau, du hast ein Partitioning-Scheme auf EFI-Ebene, das macht dir Partitionen. Und zwar mehr als BIOS, das kann... ist auch egal. Aber du kannst in einer Partition bei HFS nur ein Volume haben. Und du kannst aber die Größe des Volumes shrinken. Das heißt, dass du am Ende der Partition dann freien Platz hast. Du kannst aber dann die Partitionsgrenzen nicht verschieben, wenn danach noch mal in der nächsten Partition wieder ein Volume drin ist, weil du das Volume als Ganzes nicht verschieben kannst. Das heißt, wenn du die erste Partition verkleinern kannst, also das erste Volume verkleinern kannst und kannst das zweite Volume löschen, dann kannst du auch die Partitionsgrenze verschieben zum heutigen Zeitpunkt.
Aber was nicht geht, ist den Anfang der Partition nach vorne zu ziehen, richtig? Schnell vor, du hast Partition 2 und davor ist Partition 1 und du willst Partition 2 größer machen. Hinter Partition 2 ist die Festplatte aber zu Ende. Du könntest jetzt natürlich sagen, ich lösche Partition 1 und ziehe den Anfang von Partition 2 nach vorne. Das kann aber niemand, aber eigentlich wäre das auch ein easy Trick. Man lässt den Block einfach bei einer Milliarde anfangen und dann zieht den danach vor. Da sie wahrscheinlich aber jeden Block immer bei Null anfangen lassen, geht das nicht.
Du kannst das Volume einfach nicht verschieben.
Im Chat werden immer schon Pfannkuchen gebacken, weil man euch nicht mehr folgen kann.
Ja, das könnt ihr ja sich zwei, drei Mal anhören, dann geht das schon.
Ich fasse kurz zusammen, APFS, jetzt haben wir so lange drauf gewartet, jetzt müssen wir da auch einmal rein nerden. So viel steht ja schon mal fest. Tatsache ist, man kann den verfügbaren Plattenplatz jetzt deutlich flexibler verwalten. Man kann sich Volumes oder Fallsysteme oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte anlegen. Und die haben alle denselben Free Space. Und deswegen, das ist auch so eins der kleineren Details, die Developer jetzt einfach mal in ihre Programme rein denken müssen, so sehr sie Annahmen über Free Space haben.
Wer würde so etwas tun? Ja, gut, aber naja, meine App wird sowieso nicht mehr unter Sierra laufen. Insofern ist es egal.
Kurzfassung.
Keine Garbage Collection und der Sierra.
Ich hab diesen Scheiß ja nie mitgebracht.
Ey, das Teil ist jetzt seit 10.5 oder so im App Store und ich hab kein Update bis jetzt gemacht und es ist egal.
Haben wir die positiven Sachen schon alle durch?
Ja, es gibt Snapshots. Und da muss ich sagen. Und nicht nur Snapshots, sondern sie haben auch Clones. Generell sehr viel Atomicität in diesem ganzen File System drin. Also erstmal, um das Crash-Prone hinzubekommen. Das heißt, eine Operation auf dem File System ist automatisch, entweder sie gelingt vollständig oder sie gelingt vollständig nicht.
Da könnten wir kurz die Tiefe eintauchen. Weil bei ZFs ist das ja auch so. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach. Und zwar benutzen die auch die sogenannte Technik Merkel-Tree. Das heißt, die Blöcke sind immer signiert. Jedes Mal, wenn du an einem Pfeil eine Änderung machst, ändert sich ja auch die Direktorie da drüber, weil sich die Checksaming ändert und das von der Direktorie da drüber gechecksamt wird. Und die Direktorie da drüber wird von dem File System gechecksamt und das File System wird dann bei ZFs von dem Pool gechecksamt. Und ganz am Ende ist sozusagen ein sogenannter Überblock, der die Master Checksam hat. Und wenn die nicht korrekt ist, dann wird der Block nicht anerkannt und dann wird ein alter Master Block genommen, wo die Checksam richtig ist. Deswegen liegen da mal mehrere Master Blocks rum, was man mehr machen kann, weil man auch ein Copy-on-Write macht. Also man schreibt ja nie über den originalen Block rüber, sondern man schreibt ja mal an drinnen. Und wenn Apple sagt, dass sie das auch so machen mit diesem, dass es nie kaputtgehen kann und mit den Atomic Writes, dann müssten sie das eigentlich auch genau mit diesem Märkertree machen, mit Checksamung. Und sie haben ja auch gesagt, sie machen Checksamung für ihre Metadaten. Und das ist vielleicht der Grund, warum sie das können.
Klingt sinnvoll.
Weil sonst, wenn ein kaputter Block liegt, checken sie durch. Alles klar, Checksamung stimmt nicht. Nehmen sie die alte Version davon, da stimmt das alles und dann macht der Baum Sinn. Und sie haben auch gesagt, dass auch sie schreiben die Metadaten auch mehrfach. Das macht ZFS ja auch, also Fyldaten, Asyldaten werden einmal geschrieben, Metadaten werden zweimal geschrieben und die ganz wichtigen Sachen, ich glaube, hier also Filesystemen und Sachen, die zum Pool hören, die ja mega wichtig sind, weil wenn der Pool weg ist, sind alle Filesystems weg, also das ist alles, alles weg. Die werden sogar dreimal geschrieben auf eine Platte und wenn du ein Mirror hast, dann sogar doppelt dementsprechend und so, also sie haben da schon ein bisschen Redundanz und haben auch gesagt, das kostet irgendwie so ein bis zwei Prozent der Platte, das scheint dann Apple auch alles so übernommen zu haben. Das finde ich auch gut, das gefällt mir. Da bin ich da ganz mit dabei. Was hatten sie noch, dieses Fast Directories Sizing?
Was ich ein ganz interessantes Ding finde, weil ich glaube es gibt kein anderes Dateisystem, was sowas tut. Das ist einfach nur, damit du im Finder immer siehst, wie viel Zeug ist in einem Directory drin.
Ja und darum dann Kopiervorgänge einfach schneller starten zu können.
Ja stimmt, weil sie mal erstmal vorher durchrechnen bevor sie...
Genau, das dauert ja ewig lang. Und überhaupt mit ihrem ganzen... Also es ist ja nicht nur das, sondern es ist ja auch dieses Cloning, was da noch mit reinkommt. Also sie haben ja das File-Cloning auch noch mit in ihrer Liste. Das bedeutet, wenn du über ein spezielles, und da wird es auch jetzt interessant, wenn du über ein spezielles API sagst, ich möchte gerne von dieser Datei einen Klon erstellen. Also im Sinne von einer Kopie erstellen. Nicht, ich öffne die Datei, ich lese die Blöcke und schreibe sie in eine andere. Sondern ich sage einfach, mach mal eine Kopie. Nicht im Sinne von kopiere jetzt mal alles, sondern nur, merkt ihr mal, dass es davon jetzt eine Kopie gibt. In dem Moment, wo auf die Kopie halt geschrieben wird, dann kommt dieser Copy-and-Write-Effekt. Also das heißt erst in dem Moment, wo wirklich Blöcke anders sind, werden sie dann auch separat geschrieben und nur die.
Wobei aus der Dokumentation nicht so ganz klar hervorgeht, ob sie tatsächlich nur die geänderten Blöcke schreiben oder tatsächlich das gesamte Datei samt den geänderten Blöcken nochmal.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass sie...
Ich bin mir auch relativ sicher. Wenn nicht, dann müssten wir ja nochmal ganz doll lange lachen.
Ja, weil ich meine, erst mal feiern, dass 2 GB ganz schnell geht, aber dann drei Beizahnen drin schreiben, dauert eine halbe Stunde. Das kannst du mir nicht erzählen.
Ja, je nachdem, wie du so eine Datei schreibst, kann es halt einmal komplett neu sein.
Dann können sie gleich wieder nach Hause gehen.
Vor allem macht es dann keinen Sinn, dann können sie die Datei ja gleich vorher kopieren, weil dann habe ich ja nichts gespart.
Ja, eben.
Außer auf den Fall, dass ich sie nie wieder ändern werde, aber dann hätte ich auch keine Kopie gemacht, wenn ich sie nicht ändern wollte.
Das macht auch keinen Sinn für die Snapshots. Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ihr ganzes Snapshot-Block-Konzept, die ganze... Wie ist alles miteinander vernetzt? Im Wesentlichen den selben Ideen folgt wie ZFS. Da sind keine eklatanten, konzeptionellen Unterschiede. Das einzige und an der Stelle, um das auch noch mal zu bringen, bevor wir irgendwie über Checksum reden, sie haben dann eben auch dieses Atomic Saving. Also du schreibst als Programm in deine Datei und willst, dass da dir keiner in die Quere kommt und das haben sie ja sogar so weit erweitert, dass es auch für komplette Directories ist.
Das ist aber die eigentliche Neuigkeit, weil vorher eine einzelne Datei automatisch zu schreiben war, ist halt keine schwierige Sache. Du schreibst halt irgendwo hin und benennt sie dann um.
Ja genau, das muss aber die Applikation machen und sich selbst umkümmern.
Nein, nein, nein. Ja doch? Nein, es gibt eine API, wo du sagst atomically...
Ja, aber es macht das OS für dich. Jetzt macht es das Fallsystem für dich.
Genau, das ist ein Unterschied. Ja, das ist richtig.
Und das ist eben auch kein Podcast-Call, sondern das ist ein...
Nur der eigentliche Unterschied ist, dass du das jetzt für ganze Directories machen kannst, die tatsächlich atomar geschrieben werden, was vorher halt einfach nicht ging. Also so eine einzelne Datei ist keine Magie, aber ein ganzes Directory atomar zu schreiben, halt so ein Bundle, das ist halt schon sehr cool. Also das muss man ihnen lassen.
Bleibt als einziger Wermutstropfen, wenn du mich fragst, also einen anderen Wermutstropfen habe ich jetzt so noch nicht direkt gefunden, Check-Zooming auf Block-Ebene.
Ja, auf User-Daten meint sie.
Aber ich glaube, dass sie überall in allen Tech-Blocks dafür, glaube ich, einen Einlauf kriegen.
Wir kriegen alle so auf den Deckel und bis zum nächsten Jahr haben die das. Das kann aber auch sein, da bin ich mir halt noch nicht so sicher, wenn...
Bis zum nächsten Jahr, ich meine, das ist doch wohl mal die Basis von dem ganzen Scheiß.
Eigentlich schon. Also für mich fällt das fast aus, weil es kein Check-Zoom mehr hat. Dann wenn ich da schon wechsle auf so ein File-System, also ich werde wechseln, weil das HFS gehört abgelöst. Aber wenn mir dann Daten lieb und wichtig sind, dann denke ich mir, da ist mein ZFS besser.
Ich frage mich, was bitte hält sie davon ab, das zu machen?
Ja, das größte Problem, Silent-Bit-Rot nicht anzugehen, ist irgendwie...
Eine Sache, die sein könnte, ist, dass bei Encryption, wenn man das sowieso schon encryptet, dann kann man auch Authentication mit einbauen. Authentication ist eigentlich das gleiche mehr oder weniger wie Checksumming.
Weil sie müssen sicher sicher sein, dass ihr Krypto-Scheiß sicher ist. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo es verschlüsselt ist, hast du quasi Checksums?
Ja, aber nicht mehr auf Block-Ebene natürlich. Warum nicht? Sondern auf File-Ebene.
Na kommt drauf an, also...
Kommt drauf an, ob iOS oder die andere Methode.
Na sind die beiden Methoden nicht vielleicht sogar beide gleichzeitig, dass du ein Key noch mal auf dem hast, was auf der Platte noch mal verschlüsselt ist? Na das willst du doch nicht entweder oder haben, das willst du doch beides haben. Also der Block-Encryption-Teil kann ja auch etwas, was vorher schon mal verschlüsselt wurde, von einem File-Key auch noch mal in seinem Disk-Key verschlüsseln, das ist ja kein Problem. Was er nun verschlüsselt ist egal, das sind zwei Abstraktionsebenen, das eine ist Zugriff auf die Datei, bestimmte Blöcke haben einen Key, bestimmte andere Blöcke haben einen anderen Key, aber alle Blöcke in diesem Volumen oder Container oder Partitionen oder was auch immer, sind noch mal mit einem Disk-Key verschlüsselt. Das beißt sich ja nicht, das kannst du ja beides gleichzeitig machen.
Glaub ich nicht, dass sie das machen.
Ich wüsste nicht, was sie davon abhalten sollte, das zu machen, weil das kostet sie keine Zeit.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, du kannst tatsächlich beides anschalten. Na ja, egal, also das ist so ein Punkt, wo ich in der Doku, das weiß ich nicht mehr so genau, aber ich glaube tatsächlich, man konnte beides gleichzeitig anschalten.
Das Jacksumming ist ein Abfallprodukt von encryption und das da automatisch mitkommt. Ist mir auch total unklar, warum, also ich meine, wenn die da seit 2014 sitzen, das ist nicht so wirklich lange, überall steht, man braucht so ein paar Jahre mehr für so ein Fallsystem, Zeit der Wesse hat 2001 angefangen wohl, den musste auch jeder gesagt haben, ey Jungs, das geht nicht ohne Jacksumming. Alle sagen das. Was der Apple sagt ist, sie sagen ja hier, alle Flash- und SSDs, die sie von ihren Herstellern da einkaufen und verbauen, die haben die Anforderungen, dass sie keine kaputten Daten zurückgeben oder irgendwie, oder dass die halt hier Error-Correction-Codes haben und so weiter, aber wir wissen alle irgendwie, kaputtes Kabel hier, kaputter Firmware da und schwupp sind deine Daten im Arsch und du willst das möglichst früh wissen. Die Bitrot willst du halt merken und das geht nicht.
Was ja auch noch APFS unterscheidet von ZFS ist, dass sie halt keinerlei Raid-Systematik drin haben, sondern sie sich an der Stelle einfach auf externe Raids verlassen.
Das wundert mich jetzt aber nicht so sehr.
Das finde ich aber, das können die bestimmt aufbohren, weil ich glaube schon, man konnte ja, sie haben ja gesagt, wenn da so ein Container ist und dazwischen, dann kommt eine andere Partition, dann kann man den ersten Container auch da hinten mit einem zweiten Container verlängern, obwohl dann eine andere Partition dazwischen ist. So, wenn man das machen kann mit einem Container, der irgendwo dahinter liegt, also die nicht direkt miteinander verbunden sind, dann kann man das auch mit einem Container, der auf einer anderen Festplatte liegt, machen, könnte ich mir, also könnte ich schwören.
Es hieß irgendwo in der Doku auch, dass sie explizit diesen JBOD, also Just a Bunch of Discs Modus auch haben. Also sie können in irgendeiner Form mehrere Platten zusammenwerfen.
Ja, das ist doch dann das schon.
Ja, trotzdem war halt explizit die Rede für Raid, komplexere Raid.
Raid ist ja Redundanz und nicht einfach nur ein größeres Modus.
Also sie machen kein Mirroring im Fallsystem, sie machen keinen Striping, sie machen kein Redundanz-Ding, sondern sie machen nur, okay, wir haben hier verschiedene Bereiche, wir betrachten die als einen.
Zeig mal den Link da, Ronaldo erfährt das, dass APFS kein Jack-Samuel unterstützt. Das ist bestimmt die Szene vorhin, wo er sich so aufregt, oder?
Wahrscheinlich. Nein. Nein. Nein, anderes Trikot, oder doch? Ah nee, das ist nur die Fehlfarben.
Den musst du natürlich auch mit rein posten irgendwo, wenn du den übernimmst.
Tja, dann muss dir jemand pinnen.
So schön dieses APFS auch ist als Ablöse für HFS+, weil es ist auf jeden Fall natürlich ein deutlicher Schritt nach vorne. Und so klein ist der jetzt ja auch nicht, ist ja alles drin, auch mit Encryption, dass es so built-in ist. Und sozusagen auch, wie sagen sie, einen Primary Feature oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Das ist eine gute Sache, unterstütze ich alles. Aber das mit dem Shag-Summing, das macht mir irgendwie...
Das ist nicht gut.
Ja, das ist, keine Ahnung, als wenn da was fehlt. Und weil war es auch ein Primary Feature. Ich finde, Shag-Summing ist ein fucking Primary Feature. Was nützt mir meine verschlüsselten Daten, wenn da nur noch Müll rauskommt.
Ich finde es wichtiger, als dieses alberne Cloning, ehrlich gesagt.
Na, es ist schon beides wichtig. Also Cloning finde ich auch super wichtig.
Ja, aber normalerweise ist das ganz oben in der Liste.
Die Anforderungen nicht. Doch, ich hab die am laufenden Meter.
Sachen klonen?
Nee, ich auch nicht.
Manchmal lade ich Sachen doppelt runter. Aber dann habe ich keinen Vorteil von dem Cloning, weil der ja kein D-Dub macht, sondern nur ich kann, wenn ich eine Datei habe, die halt klonen.
Nein, der macht schon D-Dub. Der macht halt sozusagen nur, was sich verändert hat.
Ja, wenn du Sachen, die du im Dateisystem hast, klonest, dann ist es D-Duplicated. Aber wenn ich zweimal die gleiche Datei von irgendwo runter lade, dann hast du sie auch zweimal auf der Platte.
Das ist doch ein Edge-Case, Mann.
Bei mir ist der weniger Edge-Case als das echte Cloning. Ich hab Cloning auch noch nie benutzt.
Cloning noch nie benutzt? Hast du auch nie einen Ordner kopiert?
Das ist kein Cloning.
Selbstverständlich ist das Cloning.
Hier heißt das jetzt Cloning. Du kopierst einen fucking Ordner. Guck mal.
Ich sage nicht nie, aber das mach ich fast nicht.
Ich dachte du meinst jetzt von einem Snapshot ein Clone. So heißt das nämlich bei Zettel.
Nein, ich rede von dem Cloning im Sinne von APFS.
Du meinst Duplicate, Apfel D. Sag es doch, Duplicate.
Das mach ich extrem selten.
Ja, manchmal.
Warum auch?
Darf ich es mal erzählen? Das ist doch vollkommen normal.
Na gut.
Du hast da 300 Gigabyte Video-Files.
Und dann hast du hinterher 600.
Mit denen willst du jetzt gleich mit Final Cut Pro loslegen und tralala. Wir haben Live-Gäste.
War mal zu laut?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Die Live-Gäste haben ein Skateboard dabei.
Ja, weiß auch nicht. Bringt mich ganz aus dem Konzept. Also ich hab 300 Gigabyte Video-Files. Gigabyte, 300 Gigabyte Video-Files rumlegen. Auf einer Platte, die vielleicht noch, naja, weitere 200 Gigabyte frei hat. Vielleicht auch nur noch 50. So, und jetzt möchte ich da gerne drauf herum operieren und mit denen was machen und da irgendwie rumschneiden und konvertieren und pipapo.
Dann reichen dir die 50.
Neu arrangieren und so weiter. Was?
Red weiter, ja.
Doch klar, weil ich im Wesentlichen die so auslese, aber ich ändere halt unter Umständen dieses ganze Layout, dieses ganze Verzeichnis-Layout. Ich importiere die in irgendwelche anderen Sachen, ich sortiere die, ich arbeite einfach mit den Daten. Da ist das cool, wenn ich davon nochmal eine Kopie habe. Aber wenn diese Kopie mich nochmal 300 GB kostet, dann kostet mich das Zeit und Platz, den ich noch nicht habe.
Warum hast du keinen Snapshot gemacht?
Mann, weil es APFS ist, weil es keinen Snapshot gibt.
Nein, aber bei dem neuen APFS gibt es ja Snapshots.
Davon rede ich doch, dass das toll ist, dass man das jetzt machen kann. Weil ich sage einfach, mach mir mal eine Kopie und es kostet mich vielleicht 150 KB on disk. Und das war's.
Was ich meine ist, dass du hast jetzt die Möglichkeit, dieses Cloning zu benutzen oder das die Möglichkeit, einen Snapshot zu machen.
Das auch.
Und dann würde ich doch eher einen Snapshot machen.
Das könnte ja sein, dass ich mit mehreren parallelen Verzeichnissen arbeiten will.
Okay, der Nachteil ist auch, Snapshot ist wahrscheinlich auch das gesamte Fallsystem. Cloning ist wahrscheinlich nur für bestimmte Orte.
Beides ist natürlich sinnvoll und Snapshots, denke ich mal, werden auch bedeuten, dass Time Machine, also vielleicht muss man nochmal kurz erklären, was Snapshots sind. Also Snapshot ist der vollständige Zustand des kompletten Volumes zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Den kann man jetzt einfach einfrieren und einfach weitermachen und wenn man dann irgendwann meint, alles in die Hose gegangen, kann ich einfach zurück zu diesem alten Punkt und kann sagen, schnapp ein die komplette Festplatte bitte in diesen vorherigen Zustand und es dauert nicht lang.
Ja oder du kannst sie halt als eigenes Dateisystem mounten und Sachen da wieder rauskopieren.
Oder sowas.
Wenn du sie brauchst.
Ist halt alles da, aber ich denke, dass Time Machine vor allem deshalb jetzt nicht funktioniert, weil sie einfach gar nicht erst diese Features eingebaut haben, dass du einen Link von einem Directory machen kannst, sondern sie werden Time Machine einfach auf APFS umstellen. Also Time Machine in was auch immer nach Sierra kommt.
Und ich hoffe, es kommt schon nächstes Jahr.
Basiert auf APFS, das kommt auf nächstes Jahr, weil das ist mir in dem Moment klar geworden, als sie gesagt haben, wir können on the fly die Disc ändern, während du damit arbeitest.
Damit ist das Ding durch.
Weil das Einzige, was sie nicht forcieren können, ist, dass die Leute alle ihre Daten von der Platte ein Backup machen, neu formatieren und wieder zurückkopieren. Und das wird niemand tun. Aber so eben mal, konvertier mal auf modern und schnell. Dann läuft das so ein Abend durch. Und dann ein paar Limen, ist alles verschlüsselt.
Und wenn ich das richtig gelesen hab, dann ist es sogar so, dass man sich denkt, alles klar, ich hab hier irgendwie so eine 4TB-Platte. Und sagen wir mal, ich hab da nur alles, sind alles so eine 10GB Dateien. So Filme zum Beispiel, ja, dann ist das scheiße. Jetzt muss der meine 5TB irgendwie durch die Gegend schieben. Nein, wenn ich das richtig gelesen hab, dann ist ihr Tool, was das OS, also was das File-System ändert, lässt die User-Date genau an der gleichen Stelle liegen, wo sie sind, und ändert nur das Drumherum.
Ändert nur die Metadaten.
Und das geht dann ratzfatz. Wenn die das so gemacht haben, was schlau wäre.
Macht eigentlich Sinn, ne?
Macht total Sinn. Weil die mussten ja eh da liegen bleiben. Wo das nicht geht, ist, wenn du ein Krypto machst, dann müssen wir das neu schreiben. Aber wenn du kein Krypto machst, dann lässt du einen neuen Einhorn darauf zeigen und fertig.
Machen sie dann einen zweiten Durchgang. Erst mal konvertieren und dann Krypto an.
Eigentlich ist das ja total easy. Wenn ich da jetzt bei Apple sitzen würde, wir hätten so ein Meeting, wo ich sagen würde, alles klar, wir nehmen hier Half-S, wir blockieren irgendwie mal so ein Gigabyte Speicher, sagen, die Blocks sind jetzt da belegt, dann nutzt Half-S die nicht mehr in diesem 1 Gigabyte, schreiben wir schon mal unseren ganzen neuen APFS-Header-Zeugs, Pool, Fallsystem, Direktrestruktur und so weiter. Und dann lassen wir da die ganzen Pointer auf die ganzen Dateien zeigen, die ja schon da sind. Oder anmounten, new mount und boop. Total schnell. Also um so größer die Dateien sind, um so schneller geht das.
Also um so weniger Dateien sind.
Und Time Machine wird auch ein Traum werden, weil dann wird's nämlich so kommen, weil jetzt du hast irgendwelche neuen Sachen, du installierst einen neuen Xcode und dann sitzt wieder eine Stunde da, weil dein Time Machine so lange braucht. Das neue Time Machine wird dann wahrscheinlich auch block-based arbeiten und nicht mehr file-based, so wie früher. Und das wird einfach mal flutschen.
Das wird richtig flutschen, wenn man jetzt eine Stunde lang arbeitet.
Wie ist Time Machine? Was sagt das am Anfang? Preparing Backup, was auch immer der da durchzählt. Wahrscheinlich auch die Directory-Sizes durchrechnet und so. Das dauert ja teilweise fünf Minuten.
Nee, ich glaube, er geht einmal durch die Struktur durch und guckt nach, was sich überhaupt geändert hat seit dem letzten Backup.
Ja, aber das müsste er über den FS-Eventer doch sowieso wissen, schon lange.
Ja, aber der muss es sozusagen einsammeln.
Aber der FS-Eventer macht das nur auf Directory-Ebene, soweit ich weiß. Also der sagt dir nur, in dem Directory hat sich was geändert.
Ist egal, das dauert immer alles viel zu lange und ich hoffe, das fixen sie damit auch, dass das in einem Abfallstand alles durchgeht und ich sag da Backup und das macht Ka-Ching und ist fertig. Das muss auch Klang machen. So wie mit Metal, das muss einfach schneller gehen.
Also erstmal hast du überhaupt die Möglichkeit, Time Machine Funktionalität auf derselben Disc zu haben, was ja derzeit auch mit dem Time Machine, das haben sie irgendwie auch eingebaut, Local Time Machine, das gibt's doch irgendwie.
Ja, das gibt's ja schon länger. Das merkst du immer, wenn du länger keinen Time Backup gemacht hast und dann klemst du deine Platte an und dann macht er irgendwas und plötzlich hast du halt 10 oder 20 Gig mehr Speicher frei, weil er diesen ganzen Scheiß rüber kopiert hat. Und dann die quasi Snapshots auslöscht.
Das fällt dann aber auch jetzt weg, da werden keine 10 oder 20 Gigabyte mehr frei. Aber sie wurden auch gar nicht erst belegt, weil das ist halt gesnapshotted. Und BlockBase ist immer gut, das geht alles viel schneller.
Genau. Wenn es auf eine andere Platte geht, dann macht er einfach einen Snapshot und kann im Hintergrund schön das Snapshot wegschreiben und muss da gar nicht viel...
Ein interessantes Titbit fand ich übrigens die Sache mit dem Apple Talk. Dass APFS keinen Apple Talk unterstützt, sondern nur SMB2.
Du meinst nicht Apple Talk, sondern AFP.
Naja, netter Talk halt, wie auch immer.
Ja, warum fandest du das jetzt besonders erwähnenswert?
Das ist aber auch kein technischer Grund, sondern politischer, oder? Weil sie AFP gerade abschalten.
Kann auch sein, dass du für AFP irgendwelche Metadaten brauchst, die sie halt einfach nicht mehr vorsehen.
Wieso? Ich kann doch mit AFP...
DataFork, glaube ich, gibt es immer noch.
Die können auch USB-Sticks mit Fett irgendwie anbieten, oder nicht? Das heißt, das AFP-System ist doch das Fallsystem eigentlich wurscht. Oder nicht?
Ja, aber du hast ja bei Netatalk auch das Problem, dass du nochmal so eine Datenbank hast, die im Hintergrund irgendwelche zusätzlichen Adribute speichert. Die normalerweise in einem HFS Plus mit gespeichert werden. Das kann halt einfach sein, dass sie gesagt haben, diesen ganzen Scheiß, den hauen wir jetzt über Bord, was aber dann im Umkehrschluss bedeutet, dass ein AFP das wieder in so eine dämliche Datenbank speichern müsste und Apple halt einfach gesagt hat, komm, lass den Scheiß. Sodass sie halt jetzt nur noch SMB machen. Also keine Ahnung, ich spekuliere jetzt natürlich auch so ein bisschen. Aber ich fand das ein interessantes Titbit irgendwie.
Ja, ich hab das abgespeichert unter, wir müssen nicht jeden Scheiß unterstützen und irgendwelche Bits hätten wir da noch setzen müssen, aber das wollten wir gar nicht erst testen. Also schreiben wäre vielleicht gar nicht das Problem, aber dieses muss auch noch getestet werden, obwohl das eh hinten rüberfällt.
Was ich mich gefragt hab, was ist mit Time Capsule? Gibt es da ein Firmware-Update für Time Capsule? Und Time Capsule macht dann auch APFS?
Das gibt dann eher neue Time Capsules.
Nein, neue Time Capsules, die dann APFS können.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass diese neuen zylindrigen Dinger schon modern genug sind, um da auch APFS zu bekommen.
Ja, zumindest ein Update. Aber ich meine, wenn das Dateisystem jetzt so unheimlich ressourcenschonend ist, dass sie es auf die Uhr bringen wollen, dann könnten sie es auch für alte Dinger portieren. Das werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht tun.
Das glaube ich nicht. So etwas haben die noch nie gemacht.
Und weiteres Detail, was mit Open Source?
Nur, was ich verstanden habe. Open Source wurde erwähnt, glaube ich.
Was kein Nein ist, immerhin.
Ich denke mal, bevor sie das Format nicht fixt haben. Sie schreiben ja, wenn du so einen Teil anlegst, dann kriegst du ja in der Kommandozeile den dicken Disclaimer. Du legst jetzt hier ein Dateisystem an, das wird nicht kompatibel sein zu zukünftigen Dingern. Und solange sie das Format nicht fixt haben, denken sie, werden sie es auch nicht Open Source. Das war ja bei Swift letztendlich das Gleiche.
Und ich hoffe, sie kriegen wirklich von allen Seiten auf den Deckel. Also von uns habt ihr auf jeden Fall deutlich auf den Deckel gekriegt. Richtig, aber richtig.
Ich würde sogar sagen, tritt in die Eier.
Na ja, man muss ja nicht gleich so.
Doch, muss man.
Tritt in die Eier gibt es erst in einem halben Jahr, wenn es dann immer noch nicht so weit ist. Das ist jetzt nur die Warnung vor dem Tritt in die Eier. Ja, Schweigen im Wald.
Was mich auch noch interessiert natürlich, ich weiß nicht, inwiefern das wirklich wichtig ist, weil wenn man sich heutzutage anschaut, wie so Computer miteinander Daten austauschen, also früher war ja so dieses Festplatte von einem anderen Computer an einen neueren Computer anschließend, um Daten zu übernehmen. Und andersrum schon ein großes Thema. Heutzutage läuft halt relativ viel übers Netz und relativ viel über Cloud.
Und USB-Sticks.
Und USB-Sticks und all diesen ganzen Kram. Sprich, wie viele Gedanken muss sich Apple machen über alte OS-e, die kein APFS haben?
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, hieß es El Capitan. Wird es bekommen? Ja, aber vielleicht hab ich es falsch in Erinnerung.
Gibt es einen Backport, meinst du?
Warum auch nicht? Das hast du gehört. Hab ich so im Hinterkopf.
Ich glaube, dass wenn sie El Capitan und Sierra...
Zumindest Read Only.
Ja, also wenn die beiden das können, wie viel Prozent des Marktes decken sie dann ab bei ihren derzeitigen Update-Strategien? Relativ viel und der Rest kann wunderbar irgendwie das Ganze auch mit RoboX machen.
Platten wandern ja jetzt ja eh nicht so doll durch die Gegend.
Das ist nicht mehr so sehr das Thema, sondern eigentlich ist der ganze Storage mehr oder weniger drin in den Rechnern und klar, du kannst natürlich auch auf den USB-Stick dann APFS machen.
Aber soll ich dir sagen, was die User auf dem USB-Stick machen? Nix, die lassen nämlich das Fett drauf, was da schon ist und schreiben mir Pfeile drauf, weil die wissen überhaupt gar nicht, was da überhaupt abgeht. Die sehen da, dass da ein Hard Disk-Icon aufpoppt, schmeißen da ihre Daten rein und nutzen das dann. Also 90% Leute ist das so.
Das ist sicherlich der Fall, aber wenn sie sie mal löschen, dann löschen sie es garantiert mit ihrem Default-Filesystem.
Nee, dann kommt ja auch der Disq-Util, dann sagst du Erase und dann macht er das mit dem gleichen Filesystem, was da schon drauf ist. Aber ich meine, die Leute nutzen noch nicht mal Disq-Util, das machen die einfach nicht. Die wählen dann alle Files aus, mit Apfel A und Apfel Backspace und dann löschen sie die. So wird gelöscht. Dieses Disq-Util kennt doch fast keiner.
Ja, du hast ja die zwei Optionen, Windows-kompatibel oder nur Apple.
Ja, der Chat weist uns gerade darauf hin, dass es ja für Datenübertragung auch eine andere Alternative gibt, wie zum Beispiel Z-Mode mit dem schönen, charmanten Hinweis, dass das genau vor 30 Jahren eingeführt wurde. Oh man, ich kann mich da sogar noch dran erinnern.
Wir hatten noch Z-Mode am Anfang des Jahres, diese Sendung.
Nein, ich kann mich nicht als Z-Mode erinnern, als Z-Mode rauskam.
Das hatten wir Anfang des Jahres.
Ypsilon Mode war plötzlich nicht mehr cool.
Riesen Z-Modern in unserem Podcast. Chuck Fortberg, der ist nämlich gestorben, glaube ich, da gerade. September 2015 ist der gestorben. Ich glaube, wir haben da eine Sendung so ein bisschen Z-Modern behandelt. Ich war Fan von Z-Modern, das war immer cool.
Power of Checksum, ne? Z-Modern. Bei 30 Jahren sind Checksum auf dem Vormarsch. Apple muss jetzt auch...
Z-Modern, ZFS. Wenn es kein Z hat, dann hat es keine Checksum.
Aber wenn wir noch bei ZFS sind, weil wir jetzt mit dem Fallsystem das Kapitel zumachen werden gleich, richtig?
Ja, gleich.
Gab es letztens noch einen Tweet von dem, ich glaube der Jörg Lundmann, oder wie heißt der denn, ZFS nach US-10-Port hier?
Ja, Lundmann.
Und der hatte Screenshots gepostet, dass er seinen US-10 gebootet hat mit dem Root File System als ZFS. Also er hatte ein ZFS als Root File System. Also das heißt, er muss davon gebootet haben. Es ist noch nicht ganz klar, ob der das über irgendwelche Zwischentricks gemacht hat, dass der US-10-Könnel erstmal noch von Half-S Plus kam und danach dann das, wie das ZFS gemountet wurde oder so. Aber man kann demnächst wahrscheinlich, vielleicht auch wenn es noch ein bisschen mit Tricks rein ist, kann man sein ZFS unter US-10 booten. Und das wär schon ziemlich cool. Also da muss sein APFS auch erstmal gegen anstinken.
Ja, aber APFS wird halt überall sein. Und es nimmt den Kampf mit ZFS da auch irgendwie nicht so richtig auf. Also es ist nicht angetreten.
Niemand wird ZFS doll groß benutzen. Aber ich find cool, dass es kommt.
Habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass dieses neue Trackpad scheiße ist?
Nee, hast du noch nicht.
Ich kann das nachher erzählen. Es geht gar nicht.
Du warst ja erst sehr angetan.
Erst war ich sehr angetan und jetzt bin ich es nicht mehr. Also ZFS kann jetzt booten?
Auf einer Maschine eines Entwicklers von ZFS.
Genau, also es ist noch nichts für jedermann, aber die sind schon dran.
Hold your horses.
Na gut, aber das EFI kann das ja nicht. Was ist denn da der Trick?
Du kannst mit EFI eine Art Boot-Partition anlegen, die dann quasi deinen Kernel startet und so. Also du müsstest in der Lage sein, in diesem ganzen EFI-Mechanismus deine ZFS-Frameworks reinzubasteln. Aber das sind echt... Ich meine, Kernel-Extensions sind ja schon Black Magic, aber Booten mit Kernel-Extensions ist wahrscheinlich doppelt Black Magic.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie er das genau gemacht hat, aber... Vielleicht hat er ja auch den FreeBSD weggenommen und anstatt den FreeBSD-Kernel zu laden, lädt er einfach den Mac OS X-Kernel. Irgendwie muss man den Kernel ja am Anfang starten können. Und hat da ein bisschen rumgespielt mit irgendeinem, der sich da gut auskennt in der Materie und plötzlich ging's. Keine Ahnung. Werden wir ja bald sehen. Find ich auf jeden Fall gut.
Kommen wir nochmal ein bisschen zur Keynote und den sonstigen Verkündungen und Verheißungen. Da gab's dann auch nochmal ein paar Nachrichten zu Apple Pay. Nämlich, dass sie jetzt Apple Pay auch ins Web tragen wollen.
Das haben sie aber auch schon früh angekündigt, dass sie das so machen wollen, ne?
Das wüsste ich nicht, dass sie das getan hätten.
Ich kann mich da genau erinnern.
Nee, was sie getan haben, ist ja im Apple Pay in Apps.
Also in Apps war das und jetzt kommt's im Web.
Eine Webseite kann sich dir entgegenlehnen und sagen, willst du nicht mit Apple Pay bezahlen? Da fragt man sich natürlich, wie? Das heißt, auf der einen Seite mit Safari auf dem Telefon kannst du dann halt das tun. Und wenn jetzt halt macOS Sierra ja auch einen Touch-ID-Sensor bekommt, wovon natürlich jetzt nicht die Rede war, aber das macOS selber...
Na ja, wenn du es mit der Uhr anlocken kannst, dann kannst du eventuell über den Umweg Uhr damit bezahlen.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass sie jetzt einfach auf Passwort zurückfallen werden, sondern sie werden schon denselben Grad an Sicherheit haben und wahrscheinlich bedeutet das auch, dass künftige Macs dann halt auch mit dieser Secure Enclave in irgendeiner Form daherkommen.
Ja, aber das müsste ja Hardware in irgendeiner Form unterstützen, ne?
Das müsste Hardware in irgendeiner Form unterstützen, genau.
Was sein denn? Wie gesagt, du transferierst es zu einem iOS oder zu einer Watch?
Ich frage, ob sie das in einem Intel Prozessor überhaupt machen können.
Jetzt heizt die Gerüchte an, dass sie nochmal ein ARM-Chip rausbringen.
Nö, es könnte auch sein, dass sie Intel Prozessoren sowas kriegen. Was sollte Intel Prozessoren davon abhalten, auch eine Secure and Clef zu implementieren, wenn das bei ARM so erfolgreich ist?
Hm, jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass wenn nur Apple das will, dass es für Intel eventuell ein zu kleiner Markt ist, um dafür Real Estate auf dem Chip zu...
Ich glaube, wenn Apple irgendwas will von Intel, dann sind die da gewerbeifuß.
Ja, dann machen die Männchen.
Na ja, also erstmal verkauft Apple sehr viel von ihren Top-Prozessoren und B, sind die jetzt auch kein kleiner und wichtiger Partner.
Aber redet mal weiter, wir gucken gleich das Ergebnis.
Ja, du hast natürlich recht, es spricht nichts dagegen. Und ich glaube, dass auch andere Betriebssysteme durchaus in der Lage wären, sinnvolle Dinge mit einer Secure Enclave zu tun.
Gut, aber ich habe mir weniger über die Implementierung auf Rechnern Gedanken gemacht, sondern ich habe mir eher Gedanken darüber gemacht, wann denn eigentlich mal Apple Pay nach Deutschland kommt.
Sieht nicht gut aus, oder?
Sieht nicht gut aus. Es ging dann hier wild so eine komische Petition herum.
Ja, was ja auch super sinnvoll ist.
Was ich am Anfang etwas strange fand, weil ich mir dachte, woher wollen wir denn wissen, dass das nicht schon lange in Planung ist? Dann gab es allerdings auch tatsächlich Rückmeldungen, Aussagen von dem Bankenverband, dass es keine Pläne gäbe, Apple Pay umzusetzen, weil sie ja irgendwie Pay direkt machen würden.
Bei den Sparkassen ist man hingegen nach wie vor offen für eine Kooperation. Das wäre natürlich cool, wenn die Sparkassen dann einfach reingrätschen.
Die Sparkassen sind doch schon auch relativ fett, oder? Die waren doch ziemlich groß.
Also das heißt, wenn Apple Pay in Deutschland mit nur Sparkasse startet, bin ich schon zufrieden als Sparkassenkunde.
Das sehe ich ähnlich.
Auch wenn es sicherlich sinnvoll wäre, mehr Banken im Boot zu haben. Wir haben jetzt wieder dieses sinnlose, die Banken wollen jetzt auch noch ihren eigenen Payment-Dienst, damit da kein weiterer Mit-Ement kommt. Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht nachgeschlagen.
Das muss so ein Not-Invented-Hier-Syndrom-Wing sein.
Das ist wieder so ein weiterer Versuch, irgendwas zu verstehen, was komplett scheitert. Basiert auf jeden Fall nicht auf biometrischen Merkmalen, die in deinem Telefon eingebaut sind. Basiert sicherlich auch nicht auf komplette Anonymisierung des Bezahlvorgangs. Ich muss sagen, ich finde das wirklich affig. Weil eine Bank soll mit meinem Geld arbeiten und soll mir einfach den sichersten, möglichst einfachsten Bezahlweg bieten.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Machtding. Die Banken haben einfach Bammel davor, da an irgendwen in irgendjemanden Kontrolle abzugeben. Und dann machen sie lieber irgendwie ein zweitrangiges Scheißsystem, was sie dann gemeinsam durchdrücken, statt irgendwie...
Ja, aber das gab es doch gerade in den USA schon.
Wie hieß das?
Currency, was jetzt irgendwie komplett gescheitert ist. Ja, komplett gescheitert ist das. Und es war auch klar, dass es scheitert ist.
Der eine Kommentar war, dass sie die Todgeburt jetzt endlich begraben haben. Also das ist schon eine krasse Aussage.
Ja, genau. Und das ist bestimmt hier auch wieder so eine Todgeburt wie die ganzen anderen. Vor allem, die auch schon kein Mensch mehr auseinanderhalten kann. Also erst mal diese ganzen Namen. Giro, Pell, Pell direkt, Maestro, Pipapo. Keiner weiß, was was ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, mich erinnert das immer so an dieses Todgeburten-Produkt-Portfolio von dem großen Riesen mit dem T im Namen. Von der Telekom, die haben doch da auch irgendwelche komischen Messaging-Services.
Oder die posten mit ihrem eigenen Messenger.
Ja, diese ganze Schrott. Ja, das erinnert total daran. Also irgendwie...
Deutschland.
Ja, deutsche Manager versuchen cool zu sein.
Montag morgens um acht im Nieselregen. Alle CEOs deutscher Industrie, alle auf dem Platz, pöterfrei und dann Wasser marsch. Und dann einfach mal richtig den Hintern versäulen. Zwei Stunden lang. Und danach ist vielleicht irgendwas noch zu retten in diesem Land. Aber ich glaube ohne diese Maßnahme ist einfach nichts zu holen.
Naja, ich...
So richtig schön mit so einem Lineal. Weißt du, mit so einem breiten Lineal, mit so einer scharfen Kante.
Ich lehne sinnlose Gewalt ab, weil ich...
Das ist keine sinnlose Gewalt, das ist Gewalt, die ein...
Doch, wir sind sinnlos, weil ich nicht glaube, dass sie was ändern wird.
Das ist Gewalt, die einen Sinn hat. Der hat den Sinn, endlich ein Bezahlsystem einzuführen, was sowohl sicher als auch anonym als auch funktionierend ist. Das wär doch mal was, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Tut noch ein paar Themen mir, ein paar ordentliche.
So ist's.
Ja, okay, Apple Pay ist durch. Gibt's nicht, haben wir nicht, kommen wir auch nicht wieder rein.
Da kannst du dir doch vorstellen, dass die so einen großen Markt den Deutschen sich nicht einfach so wegnehmen lassen.
Aber nicht heute.
Ja, aber das muss jetzt auch wirklich mal kommen. Ich hab ja nicht damit gerechnet, was ich länger als ein Jahr warten muss nach dieser Uhr, bis das dann irgendwie da ist.
Tja, ist aber so.
Ja, offensichtlich.
Schlimm.
Gut, wollen wir über iOS reden? Weil Apple hat sehr viel über iOS geredet und wir wollen ja heute viel über Apple reden. Jetzt haben wir auch viel über Macs geredet und über File-Systeme, ist eigentlich für jeden was dabei. TVOS lassen wir einfach mal raus. Was ist denn neu auf dem iPhone?
Also ich hab's noch nicht gesehen, weil Marketing ist ja immer so eine Sache, aber alle sagen, es ist irgendwie die größte iOS-Endung, die es so gab.
Ja, also ich hab's schon installiert. Und was wirklich sofort ins Auge fällt, sind halt die Notifications. Weil die sehen komplett anders aus, verhalten sich auch ein bisschen anders. Und du hast halt die Notification API, wo du halt jetzt noch Sachen mit reinklemmen kannst. Du kannst sogar als App die Notification abfangen und ändern, bevor der User sie zu sehen bekommt. Stichwort End-to-End-Encryption in Messenger. Also sowas wie 3MAR könnte halt einfach mal eine verschlüsselte Notification schicken, vom Server aus. Und die App auf deinem Client kann die entschlüsseln und dann die entschlüsselte Message als Notification dann dem System zurückgeben und sie würde entschlüsseln angezeigt werden. Das ist so meine persönliche Lieblingsänderung.
So wie die iMessage, das er schon immer gemacht hat. Auch hier wieder ein Feature, was sozusagen auf einmal allen zur Verfügung steht.
Nein, aber du hast halt auch die Möglichkeit tatsächlich selbstgeschriebene Views in deine Messages, in deine Notifications reinzumachen.
Also Previews von Bildern?
Von Bildern, von Karten, von whatever. Deine App tatsächlich anzeigt mit deinen Views. Also du kannst nicht interagieren, aber du kannst halt wirklich einmal tabula rasa, Freifeld, alles machen, was du willst. Das ist schon ein großes Ding oder könnte ein großes Ding sein.
Man kann ja auch Reaktionen definieren, Antworten.
Ja, aber das ist nichts Neues, weil das gab es unter iOS 8 schon, die Buttons, die du definiert hast und unter iOS 9 den Text, den du eingeben kannst. Was halt neu ist, ist, dass du wirklich das komplette Aussehen der Notifications ganz anders im Griff hast.
Das könnte auf jeden Fall einen riesen Unterschied machen.
Ja, weil Notifications, also alles geht ja so ein bisschen mehr in Richtung Kontext basiert. Man will jetzt nicht immer stundenlang Programme suchen und die öffnen, sondern man will eigentlich die Änderungen direkt über den Log-Screen oder nach dem Log-In dann direkt dahin kommen, wo halt neue Sachen passieren. Ich will ja nicht jedes Mal zur dritten Seite das Programm öffnen und überhaupt herausfinden, welches Programm ist das jetzt. Weil wir haben jetzt wie viel? Wir haben Signal, wir haben Streamer, wir haben iMessages, wir haben keine Ahnung, wie viele andere Chat-Tools. Und du willst eigentlich nur noch klicken. Mir ist eigentlich fast egal, welches Chat-Tool da kommt, oder? Also, der gleiche Weg wie bei der Uhr, mehr Kontext basiert.
Vor allem sollen die Notifications mal auch visualisierter sein. Also, wenn jetzt mein Podcast-Klein mir erzählt, dass er eine Episode runtergeladen hat, dann ist das immer ein ewiges Geschwafel. Eine neue Episode von dem Podcast wurde heruntergeladen.
Du kannst halt jetzt...
Ich errast mir so ein Runterlad-Symbol mit der Episoden-Namen und dem Podcast-Cover und fertig.
Du kannst jetzt ein Attachment hinzufügen, was dann eine Grafik wäre. Das wäre dann das Podcast-Cover. Du kannst auch so Sachen machen, wie... Was definiert wurde, sind sogenannte mutable notifications. Der Server kann sagen, ja, die ist mutable, der Client darf die verändern. Dann hast du einen Image-Link in deiner Notification drin als weiteren Key, den der User nicht sieht. Die App kann einfach sagen, ah, dieses Image, das lade ich kurz runter, klemme das an die Notification ran und lasse ihnen die Notification anzeigen. Das finde ich schon eine ganz niedliche Sache soweit.
Kleinigkeiten...
Race to Wake habe ich nicht zum Laufen gekriegt auf meinem Test-Device, was ich abgedatet habe. Aber ich habe es auch nicht wirklich ernsthaft versucht.
Race to Wake heißt, dass man eben nicht, um einen Unlock zu machen, also um den Lockscreen zu sehen, nicht noch eine Taste drücken muss. Vor allem nicht mit dem Problem beim iPhone 6, dass wenn man die Taste drückt, dass ja die Touch-ID-Erkennung so schnell ist, dass es dann eben auch den Lockscreen sofort wieder verlässt.
Ja, du hast noch so ein zusätzliches Ding. Also bei Devices, die keinen Touch-Sensor haben, kannst du halt den Home-Button drücken und kommst nicht direkt zu dem View, wo du deinen Pin-Code eingibst, sondern bekommst den View, wo die Notifications und die Widgets zu sehen sind. Also gerade auf dem iPad ist das relativ offensichtlich. Und wenn du dann nochmal den Home-Button drückst, dann kommst du zu dem Screen, wo du dein Zeug eintippst. Fand ich eigentlich eine ganz sinnvolle Änderung.
Das muss man mal anfassen. Auf jeden Fall ist die ganze Optik auch von dem Control-Center etc. Also alles hat sich irgendwie stylisch auch nochmal geändert. Ich hab auch gehört, dass es Buttons gibt.
Na, das Control-Center hat sich insofern geändert, dass es jetzt in zwei Teile geteilt wurde. Du hast alles außer dein Audio-Playback-Dingens in dem normalen Control-Center. Und du kannst dann nach rechts swipen und bekommst dann quasi nochmal ein eigenes Control-Center für alles, was Audio ist. Also Play-Pause vor, zurück, laut, leise, Zeug. Was ich eine ganz coole Änderung finde. Ja, das ist ganz schön überladen, ne? Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ist es ziemlich überladen, ja.
Genau drum.
Und deswegen haben sie diesen ganzen Play-Pause-Kram, Lautstärke haben sie alles rübergeschmissen auf die andere Seite. Was war da noch?
Wie stabil ist das alles?
Also für eine Beta, da wirklich mal Hut ab. Ich war kurz davor, es direkt auf mein normales Device zu laden. Also da muss ich mal sagen, alter Schwede. Das war wirklich... Das Einzige, was nicht richtig funktioniert hat, war, ich hab die WWDC-App benutzt, um die Videos runterzuladen, um sie lokal zu haben. Und da ist ja ganz fürchterlich durcheinander gekommen mit. Also es kann sein, dass dieses ganze Background-Loading von Content und Lokalhalten usw., dass es alles noch braun ist. Aber ansonsten, nichts Nennenswertes gemerkt. Also ich hab auf dem iPad Mini Retina, dieses allererste Retina iPad Mini, hab ich halt dieses, können wir später noch drüber sprechen, Swift Playgrounds ausprobiert. Und es ist höllenlangsam auf dem Teil. Ob das jetzt am Device liegt oder daran, dass das alles noch nicht optimiert ist, sei dahingestellt. Also es macht Spaß, aber es ist höllenlangsam. Und ansonsten, nee, also es ist wirklich stabil. Die Maps sehen besser aus, sind auch wirklich funktionaler geworden.
Was heißt sehen besser aus?
Sehen besser aus, nein. Nee, leider hab ich vergessen mitzubringen, aber ich hab so viel Schrott dabei, das hätte mir das Genick gebrochen. Nein. Die Art und Weise, wie Straßennamen angezeigt werden und auch so Ortsnamen und so weiter, ist einfach aufgeräumter. Die Schrift ist ein bisschen größer geworden, aber sie zeigen das intelligenter an, sodass es nicht irgendwie, also es ist schwer zu beschreiben. Es sieht einfach besser aus. Also im direkten Vergleich denkt man sich so, wow, das habt ihr besser hingekriegt. Aber ich könnte jetzt nicht im Detail sagen, woran es liegt, aber es sieht einfach gut aus.
Mein Benchmark für sieht besser aus ist ja immer, ich kann auch aus größerem Abstand noch Zuglinien verfolgen.
Das ist übrigens etwas, auch das ganze User-Interface für Navigation und so weiter ist einfach viel größer geworden. Also du kannst jetzt auch so ein iPad quasi dir auf der Beifahrerseite irgendwie unter die Scheibe klemmen. Und du kannst es einfach sehen, was da passiert und wo du hin musst und so weiter. Es ist einfach nicht mehr so fisselig.
Was mich an Maps immer stört, ist, dass ich hab da irgendwie was und da steht Straßenname und dann kann ich das halt nicht lesen, weil ich ja wieder mal nix sehe. Und dann will ich reinzoomen und was ist? Die werden halt, also die Map wird größer, aber die Straßenname, der wird natürlich vectormäßig genauso klein reingerinnert wie vorher und bleibt so klein. Und du willst zoomen und das wird aber einfach nicht mit Größe auch in der letzten Stufe nicht. Und ich krieg immer die Krise. Das ist so das natürliche Instinkt, du zooms dran, damit du was besser lesen kannst und das geht einfach nicht.
Das nervt mich sowas von. Also ich hab das Gefühl, die Straßennamen sind ein bisschen größer geworden.
Na, ich hoffe. Also sollte man auch einstellen können da speziell vielleicht.
Ansonsten, hm.
Wir haben ja schon erzählt, dass es halt diese Extensions gibt bei Maps.
Ja, da hab ich noch keine wirklich gesehen.
Da würd ich mir ja sehr wünschen, dass sie das auch selber benutzen und zwar für Find My Friends. Weil du hast ja bei Find My Friends auch eine Map und kannst da tauchen dann auch immer. Ich seh halt so, ah, hier Personen an diesem Ort. Ich zoom rein, zoom rein, dann kommt da so ein Kaffeesymbol. Ah, Person ist in einem Kaffee. Welches Kaffee ist denn das?
Oder ich hätte jetzt gerne die Route dahin.
Nein, du kannst ja noch nicht mal drauf tippen.
Ach so.
Ich muss dann sozusagen sagen, zeig mir das alles jetzt in den normalen Maps an, um überhaupt auf dieses Symbol drauf tippen zu können. Also ich hab nicht denselben Interaktionskontext wie bei der anderen Map. Und von daher wäre es sinnvoller, wenn so etwas wie Find My Friends oder jede andere Kartenvisualisierungsgeschichte entweder ein voll funktionsfähiges Maps sich einbaut und nicht nur die Karte oder dass es sich selbst in Maps einbaut.
Ja, beides geht so ein bisschen. Also das Interessante ist, du kannst als App jetzt sagen, ich habe hier etwas, das hat einen Ort. Und das würde ich gerne der Suche verfügbar machen. Also vorher gab es ja auch schon dieses In-App-Searching-Dingens. Und du kannst jetzt diesem In-App-Search-Results noch einen Ort geben, sodass diese In-App-Search-Results dann auf deiner Karte auftauchen, als das ist jetzt ein Ort, der ist interessant in folgender App. Und du kannst dann da drauf drücken und kommst entweder in die App. Oder die App kann per Extension dann Dinge anzeigen, die zu diesem Ort dazugehören. Also wie z.B.
Kato Goro, hier ist ein Auto.
Zum Beispiel. Oder, weiß ich nicht, wenn du eine Starbucks-App hast, dann kann dir eine Starbucks-App halt für jedes Lokal, weiß ich nicht, Öffnungszeiten und der Frappuccino-Dingens da ist, gerade jetzt an der Dings da, in Venti billiger als den, weiß ich nicht.
Mit Karamellflavor.
Also du kannst quasi dann halt an diesem Ort, den du da reingeworfen hast, halt dann auch durch die Extension noch zusätzliche Informationen vorhalten. Irgendwie so. Also wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, ich bin mir nur so 90% sicher.
Ja, Maps mit Extensions.
Nee, aber insgesamt, also die Maps gefallen mir gut, muss ich sagen.
Vieles passiert im Bereich AI, oder wie man das auch immer nennen soll. Also alles, was so Siri-intelligenz-mäßig ist. Also Siri ist ja auch letzten Endes nichts anderes als Spracherkennung für dieselbe, Intelligenz, mit der sie halt eben viele andere Dinge auch machen. Was halt dazu kommt, ist Face Recognition. Das gab es ja insofern schon auf dem Mac. Und gab es das auf dem iPhone auch?
Na ja, es gab in Fotos oder damals noch iFotos auf dem Mac gab es diese doch sehr mäßig funktionierende Face Recognition für deine Library.
Ja, was ich ja schonmal sehr gut fand, ist, dass der Computer überhaupt in der Lage ist, zu erkennen, ob irgendwo ein Face ist. Also nicht WESSEN Face das ist.
Ja, aber auch nur so mit mäßiger Akkuratesse.
Das funktioniert an der Stelle sehr gut, wo ich es eigentlich am laufenden Meter benutze, nämlich wenn ich halt Fotos in mein Adressbuch reinziehe. Da erkennt er halt das Gesicht und es heißt halt automatisch den Ausschnitt entsprechend ab.
Okay, das habe ich nie gemacht, aber ja.
Das ist super praktisch. Da ist ein Bild rein und es ist immer in der richtigen Stelle, in der richtigen Größe. Und jetzt kommt aber eben der ganze Spaß auch zu iOS und das gleich in richtig Fett, weil sie halt jetzt einerseits diese Bilderkennung machen, also diese Gesichtserkennung machen, aber sie machen halt auch richtige Bilderkennung. Im Prinzip haben sie genau das angekündigt, oder im Wesentlichen das angekündigt, was auch Google jetzt mit seiner Fotos-Geschichte macht. Das heißt, wir wissen jetzt mal, was auf diesem Bild drauf ist.
Aber halt angeblich privacy-neutral.
Es wird auf dem iPhone berechnet, nachts, wenn es am Strom ist, oder auch tagsüber, wenn es am Strom ist, aber nur, wenn es am Strom ist.
Na ja, das mit dem am Strom, das hätte ich nicht mitgekriegt, aber es macht natürlich Sinn.
Ja, also es fängt nicht... Beziehungsweise auch, wenn du ein Foto schießt, dann macht er das auch sofort, weil dann geht's halt schnell. Aber jetzt seine ganze Bibliothek durchackern, da fängt er jetzt nicht gleich das Thema Update ab. Und das machen sie dann halt einfach später, wenn sie am Strom dran sind. Denis, was hast du hier noch beobachtet, dass sie verschiedene Gesichtsausdrücke auch erkennen können?
Ja, das hat irgendwie einer geschrieben. Der hat sich da irgendwie die Bannerys geschnappt und da irgendwie reingeguckt. Ich weiß nicht, ob der jetzt verarsche war oder nicht. In dem Kommentar hat einer das mit den sieben Zwergen irgendwie gut Vergleich gezogen, aber ich glaube, der Kommentar war ja verarsche. Aber dass es nicht nur Gesichter erkennen kann, sondern auch sieben verschiedene Expressions von Gesichtern. Und dass es Objekte erkennen kann, und zwar bis zu, da stand erst was von 400, aber in Wirklichkeit sollen es wohl 4000 sein. Und der, der das rausgefunden hat, hat diese 4000 nochmal bestätigt. Ich weiß aber nicht, was es genau heißt, 4000 Objekte in Bildern wiederzuerkennen.
Also, sollte das funktionieren, wäre es natürlich geil. Ich meine, bei Google Fotos soll es relativ gut funktionieren, aber ich werde einen Scheiß tun und das irgendwie in ihre Cloud gießen. Aber ich hab auch neulich mal das Problem gehabt, riesiges Archiv, irgendwie ein Jahr Fotos und ich hab halt ein Scheißfoto vom Wohnwagen gesucht. Ein einzelnes Foto in Mengen von allem anderen Kack. So, dann hab ich mir sonst eigentlich immer damit behäufen, also in dem Moment, wo das Foto quasi jetzt von deinem Telefon gemacht ist, das kannst du ja auch über die Location gehen, wenn du noch weißt, wo du das Foto gemacht hast. Irgendwie finde ich, da hab ich aber totale Schwierigkeiten in der aktuellen Fotos-App irgendwie den View zu finden. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das einschaltet.
Jetzt auf dem Mac.
Auf dem Mac, genau, aber auf dem Telefon ging das ja gar nicht. Du konntest ja überhaupt nicht die Orte anzeigen lassen. Du kannst ja nicht auf dem iPhone sagen, zeig mir mal, wo die Fotos sind. Und teilweise hab ich natürlich auch das Problem, dass mir das dann nicht weiterhilft, weil ich halt an bestimmten Orten, wie z.B. in meiner Wohnung, so viele Fotos schieße, dass ich darüber überhaupt nichts auseinanderhalten kann. Und eben auch nicht weiß, wie die Zeit...
Da in der Wohnung steht ein Wohnwagen?
Nein, aber da kann ich z.B. auch ein Foto von einem Wohnwagen in der Zeitung machen oder von irgendwas, was ich halt irgendwie suche. Also jetzt nur so, was die nützlichen...
Oder du kannst daraus fotografieren.
Ja, nee, du hast natürlich recht.
Ja, oder aufm Camp. Ich war aufm Camp, hab tausend Fotos aufm Camp gemacht, suche ein Foto vom Camp. Da hilft mir die Location dann halt auch nicht wirklich weit.
Nein, du hast natürlich recht. Also wenn das gut funktioniert, dann ist das auf jeden Fall eine große Sache. Ob das dann tatsächlich so gut funktioniert, müssen wir wohl abwarten.
Also ich selber bin ja mit AI noch skeptisch, weil ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, die kann eigentlich nichts. Aber ich bin auch gespannt.
Das sagt man nur so lange, bis sie bei dir an die Tür klopft.
Naja, so Deep Learning Kram, das kann schon gut funktionieren. Das glaube ich auch.
Naja, das ist der aktuelle Hype. Aber ich bin ja immer noch skeptisch, was dann am Ende wirklich AI ist. Also auch das, was Siri gemacht hat, hat ja mit AI eigentlich noch lange nichts zu tun, finde ich jedenfalls.
Doch. Sehr viel.
Ich sage, ich mich nicht richtig mit Kontext unterhalten kann. Das ist alles keine Unterhaltung. Das sind einzelne Kommandos, die da gepasst und verstanden werden. Das ist keine AI, finde ich. Und in großen Datenbanken denn irgendwie Wohnwagen zu erkennen, ist auch alles, ist wie alles noch nichts. Ist halt Auslegungssache, aber ich denke, da geht noch einiges besser und ich glaube nicht, dass das schnell kommt.
Ich glaube, dass wir sehr große Fortschritte erzählen werden in den nächsten Jahren. Ich glaube, dass das in sehr wenigen Jahren einiges total absolut anerkannte Lebensrealität sein wird, was uns heute noch ein bisschen sci-fi-mäßig vorkommt.
Und wahrscheinlich auch scary.
Und dass vieles davon auch nicht mehr scary ist, aber manches wird seine Scary-Ness bestimmt auch erhalten. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass die Fortschritte im Bereich AI sind auf einmal signifikant.
Nachdem 40 Jahren nichts passiert ist, ne?
Ja, na klar, weil erst seit 2009 halt der Durchbruch dort erzielt wurde. Diese Deep Learning. Deep Learning bzw. halt eine Verfeinerung dieser existierenden Deep Learning-Algorithmen der Analyse neuraler Netzwerke, neuronaler Netzwerke, die halt auf einmal diese Effizienz hergestellt hat bzw. die Fehleranfälligkeit der alten Modelle über einen Haufen geworfen hat. Auf einmal ging das. Auf einmal konnte dieser George, wie heißt er, Denden, Händen, ich kriege nicht auf seinen Namen, der hat sicher irgendwie alle YouTube-Videos geschnappt und Google hat ihn mal rechnen lassen und dann hat er halt alle Videos mit Katzen gefunden. So, das geht. Doch, das genau.
Na ja, es ist Mustererkennung. Beides ist ein Sinne, aber...
Es basiert halt auf neuralen Netzwerken, die selber lernen, was eine Katze sind. Da hat sich nicht einer hingesetzt und hat halt irgendwie gesagt, dass hier ist eine Katze. Ich hab meine CAE-Sendung mit AI gehört.
Hast du unsere Chaosradio-Sendung mit AI gehört?
Nein.
Da war so ein Beispiel, glaube ich, die Bundeswehr hat auch irgendwie so einen KI losgelassen, die so irgendwie Panzer erkennen sollte. Da haben sie dem immer angelernt mit Panzerbildern. Und dann haben sie das getestet und dann hat die Kanone in den Wald geschossen. Dann haben sie gesagt, was denn das jetzt für ein Scheiß, warum schießt ihr in den Wald, ist ja alles kaputt. Und haben geforscht und gemacht und getan. Dann haben sie herausgefunden, dass die Bilder, die sie angelernt haben, die standen alle im Wald oder vor dem Wald oder war immer im Wald. Also das ist einfach, das ist nur Anlernen. Das ist keine AI, das ist alles Sport und Rö.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht gerade der Maßstab, sondern das ist halt eher, was Google macht, ist so State of the Art.
Was machen die? Patternerkennung und große Datenbanken. Das ist keine AI.
Nein, das ist nicht.
Aber mit bestimmten Punkten wird es mehr als nur Patternerkennung und große Datenbanken.
Doch, das ist schützliche Intelligenz, weil die Systeme ja selber alles sich erlernen, ohne dass du ihnen das beibringen musst. Du liest denen Dinge halt irgendwie Wikipedia vor und danach können sie Deutsch.
Das will ich ja sehen.
Also ich fand diesen Artikel, ich weiß nicht, wo der her war, ganz interessant, wo ein Spielehersteller irgendwie eine AI gebaut hat, um halt für die Player eine AI zu haben. Und dieses Ding ist dann so dermaßen ausgetickt, dass es dann sich super hochgerüstet hat und die Player alle gemessert hat. Dann mussten sie es dann innerhalb weniger Tage wieder abschalten, weil das Teil halt dann auch so Schachzüge gemacht hat, von denen die Entwickler nicht wussten, dass sie in dem Spiel möglich sind, weil er hat ein bisschen zu effektiv gelernt. Also das...
Genau davon rede ich. Also ich verstehe dein Unglauben, Denis, und man kann sich schnell an irgendwelchen gescheiterten Experimenten von Leuten, die meinen, das mit dem AI im Griff zu haben, kann man sich besser erheitern, gar keine Frage. Aber Fortschritte werden gemacht. Autos werden selber fahren, Kameras werden alles erkennen können, was vor ihnen geschieht. Und zwar mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit. Die Frage ist nur unter Einbeziehung wie vieler großer Computer, aber das ist das, was Google Photos heute macht. Und sie werden es genauso mit Videos machen können. Das heißt, du wirst in absehbarer Zeit, wenn wir ein System haben, das kann klein sein, das kann groß sein, das wird vielleicht nicht sofort ein iPhone sein, aber irgendwann wird es auch ein iPhone sein. Ein iPhone, wo du die Kamera einschaltest, was nach draußen guckt und dir die ganze Zeit auf Koreanisch erzählt, was auf deiner Straße passiert.
Ja gut, also das sind ja jetzt Zukunftsvisionen, wo wir wahrscheinlich alle keine Ahnung haben, wie weit sie noch weg sind.
This decade.
Ja, gut. Lass uns mal weiter im Text.
Ja, und deswegen können sie jetzt halt auch Dinge immer besser tun. Sie haben jetzt in iOS Voice-Mail-Transcription drin, was ich ein schönes Feature finde und wo ich halt immer wieder so dieses Wann-kommt-Podcast-Transcription.
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment. Das ist nur die halbe Sache, weil Transkription ist jetzt Teil vom OS. Du kannst ein Audio-File nehmen und es dir transkribieren lassen.
Als API? Unter iOS 10?
Ja, und unter macOS. Soweit ich, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab. Du kannst das machen.
Wie war jetzt schon Live-Mitschnitt von unserer Sendung?
In welchen Sprachen?
Den üblichen wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung. Ich nehme es mal an, in den Siri-Sprachen halt. Also nehme ich mal an, ich weiß es nicht genau. Ja doch, es gibt diese API.
Lass dich mal raussuchen bitte.
Live-Mitschnitt oder aber Audiofile reinschmeißen. Mit Zeitmarken und so? Davon war jetzt nicht so die Rede. Die war, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, relativ simpel gestrickt.
Würdest du denn die Vormachtstellung unserer New Overlords anerkennen, wenn sie in der Lage ist, diesen Podcast korrekt zu transkribieren?
Du meinst, ob ich sagen würde, die AI kann ja doch was, wenn jetzt plötzlich hier so ein fertiger Text rausfällt, wo alles drin steht, was ich auch jetzt gerade sage, ohne Fehler. Das ist doch keine AI, das ist Spracherkennung.
Spracherkennung ist, sorry, das ist aber Intelligenz.
Da habt ihr aber echt eine niedrige Latte für Intelligenz.
Nein, das ist ein sehr hoher, ich meine, wie lange wird da jetzt schon geforscht? Seit 30 Jahren wird Spracherkennung gemacht. Und man ist halt nicht weit gekommen über sehr lange Zeit. Und in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren ist man sehr weit gekommen.
Siri, vor drei Jahren war viel... Aber AI ist doch nicht, Spracherkennung ist doch nicht AI, sondern Inhalteverstehen ist AI.
Das ist ja dasselbe. Es geht ja nicht nur um Sprache im Sinne von Phoneme, sondern Siri versucht ja herauszufinden, was du gemeint hast. Und das ist Intelligenz. Künstliche Intelligenz heißt herausfinden, was eigentlich hier Sache ist, worum es tatsächlich geht.
Ja, nee, das ist aber nur die Wahrscheinlichkeit, weil es mit anderen tausend Texten irgendwie vergleichen und wissen, welches Wort wahrscheinlich hinter welchem kommt und was zusammenpasst und was gar keinen Sinn macht. Das ist alles nicht Verstehen von Inhalt.
Doch, das ist Verstehen von Inhalt, weil die Techniken, mit denen die Computernetzwerke und die neuronalen Netzwerke das analysieren, denen unsere nicht so unähnlich sind. Deswegen heißt es ja neuronale Netzwerke. Da laufen vergleichbare Prozesse ab, digital nachgebildet. Nur, dass man eben die Art und Weise, wie die Neuronen funktionieren, so nicht verstanden hat, weil das nicht ohne Weiteres beobachtbar ist. Man hat aber im Algorithmischen Nennenswerte-Fortschritte erzielt, die diese ganzen digitalen Assistenten- und Verstehprogramme und diese ganzen Computer-Benutzer-Versteher jetzt ermöglichen. Und Siri vor drei Jahren war viel schlechter als Siri heute. Siri in drei Jahren wird einiges beeindruckender sein, als das heute ist. Und alles, was du heute als das wird ja nie funktionieren bezeichnest, wird wahrscheinlich dein täglich Brot sein.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich glaube, ich muss ein Stück zurückrudern. Es scheint nur iOS 10 zu sein und nicht macOS.
Hab ich nämlich jetzt für macOS auch nichts von gehört, aber wenn es halt wirklich eine richtige Transkription...
Any device running iOS 10. Usually requires an Internet connection.
Ja gut, ich meine, kein Problem. nehme auch eine App, die einfach auf einem iPad läuft, der ich irgendwie meine Datei gebe und die dann mal eben das Transkript macht. Auf welchem OS das läuft, ist mir ehrlich gesagt egal. Das muss ja nicht die Cloud sein. Darf auch gerne dezentral laufen. Na, so viel zu künstlichen Intelligenz. Home.
Ja, ich hab das in Anführungszeichen reingeschrieben, weil es gibt diese Home-Applikationen, die irgendwie diese ganzen HomeKit-Devices da in eine einzelne App gießen will. Mangelverfügbarkeit dieser Devices. In meinem Umfeld hab ich da nur einen leeren Bildschirm mit einem netten Wand, wo so Wein dran hoch wächst, gehabt. Insofern war das jetzt nicht so spannend, das sich anzugucken. Aber sie haben wohl auch nochmal eine Handvoll Device-Typen hinzugefügt, die du da in dieses HomeKit-Devices mit reintun kannst, bis hin zur IP-Kamera und zum Zeug. Kann ich jetzt nicht so richtig viel zu sagen, aber es klang auf jeden Fall. Wenn man dieses Zeug hat, ist es bestimmt ganz geil, dass du dir an einer zentralen Stelle mit dieser zentralen App deine Workflows zusammenklicken kannst und sagen kannst, ich geh jetzt ins Bett und mach jetzt die Jalousien zu und die ist Licht aus und die Heizung runter und so weiter.
Mir fühlt es ein bisschen schade, dass sie nichts dazu gesagt haben, wie sich diese ganze Crypto-Privacy-Geschichte bei HomeKit abzeichnet. Es geht jetzt seit zwei Jahren irgendwie mit HomeKit. Und diese Home-App ist ja eigentlich das, was eigentlich auch mehr oder weniger von Anfang an hätte da sein können. Gut, jetzt haben sie gewartet, bis es auch entsprechend Geräte gibt. Die App könnte das jetzt beschleunigen, weil das ist ja das, was man haben wollte.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Teil des Home-Kit-Standards ist, dass die Gerätehersteller auch ordentlich Krypto machen müssen. Auf jeden Fall. Ansonsten kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass sie da irgendwas zugesagt hätten.
Sie haben als HomeKit mal rauskamen, ein bisschen was dazu gesagt, aber da hatte das noch nicht so den Umfang, soweit ich mich erinnern kann. So oder so ist natürlich so Home-Automation schon ein Thema. Es gibt einfach ein paar Dinge, die würde ich eigentlich auch ganz gerne automatisieren. Der Scheiß nicht bloß so teuer wäre. Also ich meine, diese einzelnen HomeKit Appliances, um eine einzige Lampe an- und auszuschalten, da irgendwie 30 Euro auszugeben oder auch 60 oder was auch immer da gerade so gefordert wird, ist nicht so ganz meine Vorstellung von Automatisierungsbasis. Das müsste schon doch deutlich billiger werden. Das kann sich mittelfristig natürlich herstellen. Ich frage mich nur, ob es bestimmte Kontrollelemente gibt, die vielleicht so viel Nutzen bringen, dass man die dann trotzdem haben will.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann ist diese Home-App vor allen Dingen dazu gut, dass du halt diese ganzen Devices so bündeln kannst, dass du halt so ein Workflow baust, wie ich gehe jetzt ins Bett, mach mal alles von Jealousie über Licht, über Heizung, über Zeug, Fernseher aus, alles aus. Oder Guten Morgen, der Wecker klingelt, Jealousie geht hoch und so ein Zeug. Also so habe ich es verstanden, ob das jetzt so ein spannendes Thema ist, das sei dahingestellt.
Na gut, wenn du so starke Stromverbraucher hast, die du häufig laufen lässt, aber nicht laufen lassen möchtest, dann macht das irgendwie sinnvoll sein. Zur Absicherung ist natürlich interessant, so etwas wie Rollladen hoch und runter, will man definitiv automatisiert bekommen, weil das ist irgendwie elend, selbst wenn es elektrisch geht, da sich immer wieder einzeln darum zu kümmern. Jetzt habe ich erstmal wieder keine Rollladen in der Wohnung, aber...
Du hast hier einen.
Ich habe hier einen und der ist auch elektrisch. Den würde ich auch ehrlich gesagt ganz gerne mal so remote steuern können, obwohl es für mich eigentlich... Naja, mal ehrlich. Das Ding geht schon automatisch nachts ab einer bestimmten Uhrzeit runter. Wenn ich also mal vergesse, den Rollladen runterzulassen, ich die Meterebene verlasse, dann ist es halt spätestens nach 1, 2, 3 Stunden, dass er halt unten... Von daher... Ja, ich habe den einfach poamiert auf um 3 Uhr nachts. Fährst du runter, fertig.
Warum nicht schon vorher?
Weil wir da in der Regel noch senden.
Mach den jetzt trotzdem schon runterfahren.
Könnte ich machen, aber warum sollte ich das tun?
Das würde mich nur verstören, du würdest dich erschrecken. Ich glaube, interessant ist die ganze Kombination nach der Art. Jetzt Meter-Ebene starten, Rollladen hoch, Beamer wird angemacht. Weißte, Kühlschrank stellt, 3 Rasten weiter nach unten, damit das Bier auch kalt ist. Weiß ich nicht, halt sowas in der Art.
Da ist er wieder, der verletzte Kühlschrank. Eigentlich sollte er das Bier bestellen. Jetzt will man ihn nur 3 Grad kälter haben.
Ja, was weiß ich. Ich finde, ich hab auch immer noch das Gefühl, dass das alles sich auf so einer Spielkind-Ebene abläuft. Weiß ich nicht, wie das ist, wenn man so ein vernetztes Haus hat und sagt, ich fahre jetzt auf Arbeit los, mach mal alles, was weiß ich, Heizung an.
Ja gut, Sensoren, Alarmanlagen, Geschichten, Überwachung. Das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall alles ein Thema. Wir werden es sehen.
Aber da gab es ja auch News, und zwar ist ja der Tony Ferdell, oder wie er hieß, der Nest gegründet hat, die ja von Google gekauft wurden. Der ist ja da jetzt gegangen, richtig?
Oder worden.
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr da. Und dann gab es ja auch hier bei dem Daring Fireball, der hat ja dann irgendwie auch, weiß ich, ob er selber geschrieben hat oder zitiert von anderen, das macht der auch immer auch gerne, dass er mal gemeint hat, die haben das für ein paar Milliarden Dollar da irgendwie gekauft. Und in den zwei, drei Jahren, seitdem sie die haben, ist eigentlich gar kein Produkt rausgekommen. Also eins ist rausgekommen, aber das ist noch von Zeiten, bevor Google die gekauft hat. Also das war schon längst sowieso in der Mache, aber seitdem Google die gekauft hat, ist eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts entstanden. Und vielleicht ist ja der Markt auch gar nicht so Geldverdienermäßig so spannend.
Ja, vielleicht ist das aber auch der Effekt. Große Firma kauft kleine Firma, und die Strukturen geben das einfach nicht her, dass die Symbiose aus beiden Firmen irgendetwas ergibt.
Naja, aber drei Milliarden, oder was wir bezahlt haben, ist jetzt nicht so wenig. Ich weiß nicht, ob es drei waren oder anderthalb. Aber so wenig war es jetzt nicht.
Ist das nicht für Google Portokasse? Naja, drei Millionen.
So groß sind die jetzt auch nicht.
Okay, das ist für niemand Portokasse, oder? Naja, egal. Ja, und das letzte ist nochmal...
3,2 Milliarden waren das, das ist schon ordentlich.
3,2 Milliarden ist wahrscheinlich für niemanden Portokasse.
So, jetzt Sticker.
Sticker und Effekte und Kram hast du da hingeschrieben.
Was war denn jetzt nochmal dieses Sticker?
Na, Sticker ist, du kannst eine Sammlung an Bildern anlegen. Und der User kann...
Achso, ja, das hier, was sie da mit dem Eis vorgeführt haben.
Genau, nee, das Eis ist tatsächlich eine iMessage-App, wie sie so schön heißt. Nein, Sticker ist einfach nur eine Sammlung an Bildern. Die kannst du als User halt dann irgendwie, kannst du halt ein Bild nehmen und das auf deine Konversation droppen an einer bestimmten Stelle. Nee, die Sticker kannst du quasi in der Konversation frei positionieren. Also es ist nicht so, dass du ein Bild überträgst, sondern du nimmst dieses Ding unten aus dem Auswahlteil und klebst es irgendwo an eine Sprechblase ran, oder weiß ich nicht. Also ja, ich gehöre glaube ich auch nicht zu der Generation, die versteht, was das soll. Aber das tun sie halt. Also für mich wirkt das so ein bisschen wie eine Abwehrreaktion auf andere Messenger, wo Apple das Gefühl hat, sie müssen jetzt Features bringen, die andere bringen und damit erfolgreich sind. Aber hey, also gerade das, was sie auf der Keynote gezeigt haben, da hab ich das Gefühl, unter Steve wäre das nicht passiert. Zumindest hätten sie ordentliche Sticker verwendet in der Keynote.
Ordentliche Sticker, ich bitte dich. Dann können wir ihr nicht mehr folgen.
Das ist auch okay, dass andere Leute das machen. Die Frage ist, ich hätte jetzt keinen Bock, wenn ich mit irgendjemandem chatte, dass der mich mit so einem Zeug vollballert und würde das gerne bei mir sagen, will ich nicht, brauche ich nicht, kann ich nicht und dann kann der mir sowas auch nicht schicken. Das würde ich gut finden.
Was ganz Geiles in der Beta. In der Beta ist halt auch so ein Sticker-Pack dabei, und das sind alles Grafiken aus dem alten, ganz alten Mac OS in schwarz-weiß, unter anderem auch diese Hunde-Kuh, wie heißt das Ding? Aber der hat auch noch einen Namen, glaube ich. Clarus, genau. Der ist ja dabei, und dann ist so ein OK-Button mit extra Rand und ein Cancel-Button und irgendwie so eine alte Sanduhr und so ein Zeug dabei. Das fand ich dann ganz niedlich zum Angucken, aber im Großen und Ganzen, ja. Also diese iMessage-Apps wiederum sind relativ interessant. Also da hast du halt auch wieder eine Extension, wo du quasi so eine Mini-App in die Konversation einklinkst und die Partner in der Konversation können in dieser App dann Dinge tun und bekommen alle den gemeinsamen State dieser App gezeigt. So wie das mit dem Eis gezeigt haben. Also für sowas wie dieses gemeinsame Termine finden. Wie heißt dieses Ding da, diese Webseite? Dudel. Für sowas zum Beispiel wäre das genau das Richtige. Du schmeißt so ein Dudel-Ding in die Konversation rein und jeder, der bei der Konversation mitliest, kann dann seine Häkchen setzen und dann hast du irgendwie innerhalb von kurzer Zeit einen Termin gefunden. Sowas in der Art. Also dafür gibt es schon auch Use-Cases, die sinnvoll sind. Man muss da nicht alles zusammenbauen, interaktiv.
Ja gut, andere Plattformen haben sowas teilweise schon. Ich kenne mich jetzt bei WhatsApp und Line und so weiter nicht aus, was die Anwendungsvielfalt betrifft und wie ausgebucht das ist, aber im Prinzip...
Telegram macht das wohl?
Ja, alle Messenger machen das. Der Messenger ist das neue OS. Das muss man sich mal klar machen. Chat ist einfach so powerful, so... gut, weil es halt ein Ort ist. Das ist ja auch der Erfolg von Slack. Chat ist halt einfach ein Ort, wo Leute sind. Abhängen, ansprechbar sind, immer irgendwie bereit Nachrichten auszutauschen, weil es einfach mega niedrigschwellig und zu praktisch ist. Und weil da Leute sind, ist es halt der richtige Ort für Apps. Weil Apps wollen da sein, wo Leute sind. Leute sind an ihren Telefonen, deswegen gibt es da Apps. Aber Leute sind halt auch in ihren Messengern. Und da gibt es jetzt auch Apps. Und was heute ein erfolgreiches Betriebssystem ist, was das Betriebssystem für ein Gerät ist, kann in Zukunft sehr wohl eben sein, dass ein Betriebssystem für einen bestimmten Dienst erfolgreich ist. So wie Facebook auch interessant ist. Und auch, weil es halt die Kommunikation so vereinfacht, deshalb auch ein Betriebssystem ist.
Ja, ich sehe das total ein. Aber für mich wirkte das so, als würden sie das als Abwehrreaktion auf andere Plattformen machen. Also jetzt mal mit Ausnahme dieser Messaging-Apps, das fand ich ein ganz interessantes Konzept. Aber diese Stickers, na ja. Und du kannst halt einen Sticker-Pack, kannst du dir halt mal so eben zusammenbauen, ohne dass du da Code schreiben musst. Im Prinzip ist es nur ein Bundle, das bestimmten Regeln befolgt, was du in Xcode legst, du eins anschmeißt, Bilder drauf, die du da hast, und sagst hier erstellen, und dann hast du halt so einen Sticker-Pack gebaut.
Das macht fünf Minuten lang Spaß und dann nicht mehr.
Ja, nee, diese Stickers sind ja extrem erfolgreich, muss man dazu sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das so auf dem Zeug hast.
Ja, wir sind nicht die Generation dafür.
Sorry, Denis, in Asien Sticker ist einfach ein Millionenmarkt. Das ist einfach die Leute, das ist so ein bisschen wie hier mit Klingeltönen eine Weile, weißt du?
Machst du das auch noch mehr?
Sticker sind der neue Klingelton. Ja, Leute tun das. Es gibt einfach Jugendliche, die finden das cool.
Vielleicht ist es eine Mode und die ist in drei Jahren wieder vorbei.
Ja, aber es ist insofern eine Mode, als dass es sich darin gerade ausdrückt. Aber das, was dahinter steckt, nämlich diese Individualität in der Kommunikation, ist ein Urbedürfnis von Menschen an sich, aber natürlich speziell von Jugendlichen und Kindern. Die wollen einfach diesen Ort nicht immer gleich haben und Sticker sind einer der erfolgreichen Dinge, die an der Stelle irgendwie gegriffen haben.
Ich verstehe, um zusammenzuwassen, ist es wichtig für die Fortpflanzung. Man muss auffallen. Ist doch am Ende so, oder?
Ja, das hast du sehr schön zusammengefasst. Sticker sind wichtig für die Fortpflanzung.
Also da steht ja auch noch Effekte.
Das war das mit dem Eis, ja?
Nein, Eis war die iMessage-App. Die Effekte waren dieses komische Zeug. Diese Häusern kleiner werden, den Chat-Bubbles und so weiter. Da war dann für mich wirklich auch so der Punkt gekommen, wo ich sah, dass Steve das nicht gegeben hätte.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen.
Ja, aber ich fand das so billig gemacht alles.
Hast du mal gesehen, wie Google das gemacht hat?
Ich will es gar nicht erst wissen. Mir war das schon zu schlecht. Also, das so... Kratzt mich nicht. Ja, sehe ich alles ein.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, das größte Feature von Twitter ist die 140-Zeichen-Begrenzung.
Die über sich, um es gerade erinnert hat.
Ja, das ist auch deren Untergang, wirst du sehen.
Nö, haben sie das sehr sinnvoll gemacht. Haben sie das so gemacht, wie ich das schon länger gewünscht habe.
Ich glaube das ja noch nicht so.
Links zählen nicht mehr, ne? Und Usernames. Und Usernames zählen nicht mehr.
Okay, aber der Text bleibt weiter noch 140 beschränkt.
Ja, jetzt könnte man nämlich das auch mal mit diesen URL-Shorten nochmal wieder sein lassen. Das ist nämlich sowieso nur alte, dreckige Scheiße. Und ich will das nicht.
Vor allem, wenn du schon in deinem Browser oder beim Öffnen siehst, dass du irgendwie von Bit.ly nach da, nach da, nach da, da kannst du ja mehrere Sekunden lang zugucken, bis der Richtige gefunden wird. Das geht mal gar nicht.
Nee, das ist echt furchtbar. Aber lass uns nicht über URL-Shorten nabreden, dann gucken wir nur Scheiße drauf.
Ein Kleinkram, der da unter Messenger war, das Messenger ja noch nicht drin stand, war halt auch so dieses Autoersetzen von Wörtern in Emojis hinein.
Wer soll denn das Zeug noch lesen?
Ehrlich gesagt, da hab ich mit ein paar Kollegen drüber gesprochen.
Ist das schon Compression?
Und die meinten so, das ist eigentlich insofern ganz geil, weil die Menge an Emojis, die du hast, inzwischen so groß ist, dass du die im Zweifelsfall gar nicht findest. Und wenn jetzt aber der Chatclient, während du tippst, dir den Vorschlag macht, das könnte ich jetzt zu einem Emoji machen, dann hast du halt die Chance, ein Emoji zu benutzen, obwohl du gar nicht weißt, dass es dafür überhaupt ein Emoji gibt. Also nicht, dass ich jetzt so der große Emoji-Verfechter bin.
Emoji-Discovery. Ja, das ist so. Und auch Emoji, da fühlte ich auch lange Zeit, so wie du jetzt mit Stickern. Das ist nämlich eigentlich dieselbe Welle. Ich meine, wir sind doch alte Säcke, die sagen, man hätte Text-Smiley nie verlassen dürfen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen Morse-Code ist gut genug.
Doppelpunkt, Klammer zu, damit ist doch eigentlich alles gesagt.
So sieht's aus.
Doppelpunkt, Minus, Klammer zu bitte.
Musst du natürlich sagen...
Semikolon, Minus, Klammer zu.
Siehst du mal, es gab dann auch irgendwann diese modernen Smilies, wo ich mir dann auch dachte, was ist denn das für ein Smiley? Ja, so mit...
einem Sternchen zum Beispiel.
einem Sternchen und mit 8 und so weiter. Und ich bin halt noch so richtig Generation Smiley, so wirklich Doppelpunkt. Die Frage war eigentlich nur, macht man noch einen Minus zwischen dem Doppelpunkt und Klammer zu oder nicht?
Nee, kannst ja machen. Die Sache ist halt, aber Ascii reicht dafür, um sich da zu aufzudrücken.
Ja gut, aber im Prinzip ist ja Emoji verhält sich zu Text und Bild genauso wie unsere Smilies sich zu der damaligen Text- und Bildwelt verhalten haben. Das ist sozusagen Color, Bitmap. Damals gab es weder Farbe noch Bitmap. Jetzt gibt es das und dann sieht es halt so aus. Im Prinzip sind Emojis genau derselbe kulturelle Prozess, der auch die normalen Smilies oder Emoticons hervorgebracht hat. Und der kulturelle Ausdruck, der sich da drin reflektiert, ist halt auch wiederum so ein Differenzierungspotenzial der damaligen Jugend. In dem Fall halt der 80er-Wirrso halt, hätten wir schon Bitmap und Farbe als normal angesehen, hätten wir halt Emojis erfunden und hätten die genauso normal gefunden. Und es wird in 10, 15 Jahren, wenn der nächste große Scheiß da ist, obwohl ich glaube, so Emojis werden sich relativ lange halten, irgendwann wird dann halt Emojis auch nachgetrauert werden. Ja, damals, weißt du noch, als der Facepalm-Emoji rauskam und so, das war noch Kommunikation. Genau. Wie heißt das? Reverse Hand with Middle Finger Extended. Das sind immer alles so Wellen. In 30 Jahren ist auch dann das schon wieder durch. Man muss das jetzt einfach mal zur Kenntnis nehmen, dass es einfach stattfindet, und das ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal schlecht. Also nur weil wir jetzt irgendwie älter geworden sind, und es anders ist, als wir das irgendwie in unserer Jugend erlernt haben, heißt es ja noch lange nicht, dass es scheiße ist.
Nee, ich will das auch jetzt nicht so verstanden wissen, dass ich diese Sticker und diese Effekte und dieses ganze Zeug irgendwie ablehne. Das ist durchaus interessant, und man kann das einsetzen, ob man will oder nicht. Ich fand nur die Effekte und die Sticker, die sie in der Keynote hatten, halt einfach mal unterirdisch. Also das hätte man auch mit ein bisschen mehr Stil machen können.
Was soll das mit diesem kleineren und größeren werden? Finde ich ganz okay. Und was war das noch? Fireworks? Das ist doch alles generisch. Das ist doch einfach generic Effekt. Dollar-Effekt. Ich weiß gar nicht. Du wirst stöhnen, wenn dann erst wirklich die Apps kommen mit den richtigen Poop-Effekten.
Poop-Effekte?
Na ja, halt so Two Girls, One Cup. Ja, oder was auch immer. Und schmutziges Zeug. Das wird wirklich schlimm.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht. Gibt es da eine API für die Effekte?
Ja, das ist halt genau das selbe Ding.
Das war glaube ich keine API, die Effekte. Die haben sie einfach nur so reingebaut. Wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Ich habe das so verstanden, dass das im Prinzip genauso alles mit einem Plugin zu realisieren ist. Über die Extensions. Du kannst es halt schicken und dann geht der Code mit. Lustigerweise ist das im Prinzip genau diese Instance-Ups-Geschichte, die wir noch bei dem Review von der Google Keynote besprochen haben. Eine App kommt dynamisch auf dein Telefon in Teilen, in kleinen Dosierungen, ohne dass du das vorher angekündigt hast. Das ist genau diese Message-Extension. Nein, wenn ich dir einen Sticker schicke?
Ja, der Sticker ist aber nur eine Grafik.
Sicher?
Ja, der Sticker auf jeden Fall. Weil du kannst so einen Sticker-Bundle bauen, einfach nur mit einer Handvoll Grafiken, die du auf der Platte hast. Dann packst du die in dieses Bundle rein und dann hast du einen Sticker-Pack. Da bin ich mir relativ sicher, das hab ich mir angeguckt.
Das heißt, demnächst gibt es App, die einem Sticker-Pack kommen.
Aber diese Effekte?
Die Effekte habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht gesehen, dass es da für eine API gibt.
Habe ich vielleicht falsch verstanden.
Aber diese iMessage-Apps sind auf jeden Fall eine Extension. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob du die entsprechende App dann runterladen musst aus dem Store oder ob du tatsächlich die Extension transferiert bekommst. Da muss ich nochmal nachgucken.
Also du musst dir auf jeden Fall nicht vom Store was runterladen, sondern das kommt dann halt automatisch. Und dir wird aber angeboten, wenn du das selber verwenden willst, dann gehst du in den Store.
Das ist aber mit den Stickern genauso. Also du kannst nicht einzelne Sticker bei dir safen, sondern du kannst nur ganze Sticker-Packs irgendwie...
Genau, du brauchst dann halt die App. Es ist halt auch eine Ökonomie, die sich jetzt halt hier auftut. Und Apple will halt auch diesen Style von Ökonomie innerhalb ihres Ökosystems am Laufen halten und scheißt halt auf Cross-Plattformen. Weil mit dem App Store, mit diesem Message App App Store ist ja klar, dass sie halt auch nicht auf Android gehen werden.
Interessanterweise hält sich ja das Gerücht hartnäckig, dass sie Messages auf Android bringen wollen.
Ja, wenn sie aber nicht holen. Na das ist jetzt durch mit dem App Store. Sie werden es nicht machen. Sie haben es auch gesagt, dass sie es nie machen werden. Es ist halt, es ist immer das, es ist das, was es immer ist bei Apple. Es stärkt ihre Plattform.
Jaja, klar.
Und dass andere Plattformen Zahlen haben, die vielleicht nennenswert sind, das beschränkt sie nur begrenzt. Wenn es darum geht, ihre Plattform zu verbessern, dann bleibt es so. Wenn es ein komplett separater Dienst ist, wie zum Beispiel Musik, dann sieht es ein bisschen anders aus.
Also interessant fand ich halt auch, dass du diesen ganzen Apple Watch Kram jetzt auch in iMessage, also in Messages machen kannst. Dieses Herzchen zeichnen und den Heartbeat schicken. Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, wo der Heartbeat herkommt, wenn du keine Watch hast. Nee, ich will auch kein Heartbeat bekommen, aber du kannst es halt machen. Ja, vor allen Dingen, weil das so ein rekordeter Heartbeat ist und sie mehr oder weniger den Eindruck erweckt hatten, das würde live deinen Herzschlag übertragen werden. Aber nein, die rekorden den Heartbeat und dann wird darüber gesendet, dann kannst du ihn auf der anderen Seite irgendwie abspielen. Swift Playground steht hier. War im Prinzip auch das, was ich gesagt hatte. Also es gibt für Swift only eine quasi Entwicklungsplattform fürs iPad. Sie haben es jetzt ein bisschen anders gemacht mit du kannst so Lernziele definieren und kannst da diese komische Figur, Bite wie das Teil heißt, da durch die Gegend schicken. Nee, es ist kein vollständiges Xcode und du hast auch keine großartige Verwaltung von Dateien und so.
Ist schon hauptsächlich zum Lernen.
Ja, aber du kannst tatsächlich irgendwie die iOS-APIs wohl fast vollständig benutzen und kannst dann irgendwie im Splitscreen deine App laufen lassen, während auf der anderen Seite irgendwie das...
Gibt es dieses Ding eigentlich nur für ein iPad oder gibt es die auch auf Sierra?
Nur für... Ach so, die Swift Playgrounds, die gibt's... Nur für iPad. Nur für iPad, ja.
Es gibt ja den Swift Playground in Xcode.
Ja, es gibt die Playgrounds in Xcode. Keine Ahnung, was da noch passieren wird.
Aber wenn das auch am Rechner gehen würde, wäre schon cool, weil extra ein iPad besorgen für sowas.
Ach, und die Swift Playgrounds sind natürlich Swift 3, ne? Also nix mit Swift 2.2 oder 2.3, sondern die sind Swift 3.
Klar, wenn einer jetzt frisch anfängt, kann er auch gleich 2.3 einsteigen.
Im Prinzip klar. Im Prinzip natürlich klar, aber... Und diese Tastatur, die sie sich dafür ausgedacht haben, die ist ganz witzig. Vor allen Dingen, weil diese Selbstvervollständigungstasten, die du normalerweise hast bei der Tastatur und dir Wörter vorschlagen, dir tatsächlich Funktionen vorschlagen, die du in deinem Playground schon drin hast und so weiter. In dem Zusammenhang übrigens dieses Gerücht mit den Funktionstasten, die es nicht mehr gibt, sondern halt diese Leiste, die dir Dinge anzeigt, wo du draufdrücken kannst, würde in dem Zusammenhang tatsächlich Sinn machen, wenn du auf dieser Leiste Autovervollständigungsvorschläge bekommst, die du nicht nur beim normalen Tippen verwenden kannst, sondern halt auch in Xcode oder so.
Du meinst, dass diese OLED-Leiste dir kommen wird?
Ja, was heißt wird kommen? Also sie ist ja gerüchtet. Aber in dem Zusammenhang fiel mir plötzlich wie Schippen aus den Augen, dass das natürlich so eine Vorschlagsengine auf dieser Leiste zu haben, sodass man dort dann die Vorschläge drücken kann. Das würde zum Beispiel relativ viel Sinn machen. Aber naja, sei es drum. So, was machst du da? Overloading Procedures? Was hast du denn jetzt für ein Ding?
Na, dieser Swift Playground, der hat ja so ein Spiel im Prinzip als Basis zum Lernen von Swift.
Ja, nicht nur. Du hast halt, du kannst auch, also es gibt auch andere Playgrounds, wo du halt dann nur so Formen und Farben hast.
Ja, aber sie haben das gezeigt mit diesem Byte, was so ein Hopsewesen ist, was sich so Pixel für Pixel irgendwie in so einer kleinen Minilandschaft umher bewegt und du musst ihn halt irgendwie programmieren, damit er irgendwie das Richtige tut.
Genau, und da lernst du dann Schleifen und solche Sachen.
Genau. Da fiel mir dann Lightbot sofort ein, wo sie dieses Modell geklaut haben. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die App kennst.
Nein, kenn ich nicht.
Aber Lightbot ist im Prinzip genau das. Lightbot hat so eine Pixel-Welt und kann dann irgendwie mit Prozeduren arbeiten und so weiter. Und den halt so in einzelnen Schritten ist super für Kids. Ich lass das gerne meine Kids irgendwie spielen. Die machen das ganz gerne, um einfach so diese Idee zu bekommen von einzelnen Instruktionen und Prozeduren und Dingen, die sich wiederholen etc. Und auch Schleifen und all diese ganzen grundlegenden Programmierkonzepte kannst du halt auf dem iPad sehr schön oder auch auf dem iPhone mit Lightbot machen. Meine Empfehlung, falls jemand sowas sucht, wir hatten ja hier neulich schon mal dieses Human Resource Machine besprochen. Lightbot ist im Prinzip sowas ein bisschen ähnlich, nur dass es eben noch mal sehr viel reduzierter ist und eben sehr viel Ähnlichkeit aufweist mit dem, was Apple da macht.
Ja, der Unterschied bei Apple ist natürlich, dass du tatsächlich richtigen Swift-Code schreibst.
Nur die Visualisierung erinnert mich daran.
Ich hab so die ersten paar Leveln durchgespielt. Da hast du halt in dem ersten Ding, hast du halt die Funktion, irgendwie einen vorwärts gehen und dann hol dir so ein Diamant, der da irgendwo hängen.
Einmal springen.
Genau, einmal springen, um diesen Jewel zu holen. Und dann gibt's irgendwie Schalter, wo du drauf springen kannst und so weiter. Und dann gibt's irgendwie dann die Turn Left Instruktion. Und dann kommt irgendwann der Level, wo du halt aber rechts rumdrehen musst. Und dann ist natürlich das Ding, klar, ich schreib mir jetzt ne Funktion Turn Right. Da ist dreimal Turn Left drin. Und dann habe ich ein Turn Right, weil ich dreimal Left gemacht hab. Und das ist so der Punkt, wo es dann anfängt, wo du halt wirklich Funktionen zusammenbaust aus einfacheren Sachen und so. Und wo du dann halt auch lernst, mit einer Schleife dann deine Funktionen aufzurufen und die Instruktion, die du in die Funktionen reinzutust, so zu gruppieren, dass das sinnvoll ist und so weiter. Das fand ich schon recht cool. Wie gesagt, bei mir auf dem alten iPad Mini Retina ist es extrem langsam. Du merkst richtig, da im Hintergrund rödelt einmal der Compiler und dann muss der Linker noch machen und dann muss er irgendwie das Zeug starten. Also du drückst aufs Play und es dauert fast zwei Sekunden, bis sich das Teil bewegt. Das muss irgendwie noch schneller werden, aber es ist einfach von der Macher. Das ist total super und dieses Männchen ist so niedlich. Der freut sich so schön, wenn er seine Aufgabe gelöst hat und ist auch wirklich sehr traurig, wenn er es nicht schafft.
Ich habe eher die Befürchtung, dass wenn die Kids alle programmieren lernen und dann man die sagt, jetzt schreib mal so ein richtiges Programm und dieses ganze hübsche Männchen und das ganze Zeug, die wir haben, sondern nur noch pur Text und dann kommt halt auch irgendwie Text raus, dass sie denken, das ist ja voll langweilig. Also dass sie halt immer so schick coden wollen.
Ja, aber du kannst halt auch den Plus-Button drücken und kriegst ein leeres Projekt und kannst es mal ganz aus dem vollen Schatten.
Ich teile deine Bedenken dann nicht. Ich meine, meine erste Computer-Erfahrung war ein Schach-Computer. Das hat mir im Prinzip nur die Lust nach mehr und nach tiefer und genauer geweckt. Also nicht so, dass ich von dem Level nie wieder losgehen will. Es ist nicht so, dass du auch Kindern irgendwie du fängst ja auch nicht bei Assembler oder Zweier-Komplement-Bit-Encoding an, sondern du versuchst halt überhaupt erst mal ein Gefühl für Programmierung als solche zu bekommen. Und da sind die Angebote mittlerweile echt vielfältig. Merk das an meinen Kids, die so denken da gar nicht drüber nach, das ist halt zu programmieren, das macht man halt. Und noch ist jetzt nicht so weit, dass man jetzt wirklich über Konzepte reden kann, aber da kriegt halt irgendwie in Scratch eine Menge hin und macht das gerne und demnächst wird halt immer auf eine andere Programmiersprache gegangen. Ob ich dann jetzt irgendwie so einen Swift Playground vor die Nase halte oder irgendwie ein Python-Environment, das weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau, aber das mit dem iPad ist natürlich echt cool. Weil du das halt einfach so auf dem iPad mal eben so auf dem Sofa machen kannst.
Also man merkt deutlich, es ist halt auch eine Maßnahme mehr iPads zu verkaufen. Eindeutig.
Ja, es ist auch eine Maßnahme mehr Kindern Programmieren in Swift beizubringen.
Aber wenn es selbst mir irgendwie Spaß gemacht hat, dann ist es irgendwie...
Das hast du richtig gemacht.
Ja, ich glaube, da geht was. Da geht was. Und sie haben ja auch irgendwie angekündigt, dass du dann noch weitere Lessons da irgendwie runterladen kannst und so. Das ist schon irgendwie... Ansonsten über Swift 3 müssen wir glaube ich heute nicht mehr reden.
Nee, da reicht die Kraft nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist auch so viele Details, die jetzt nicht so richtig...
Aber um dann zum Schluss noch mal auf so ein Ding zu kommen, wer hat denn die beste Präsentation geliefert auf dieser Kino?
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Die Afro-American Mutter?
Wie hieß die?
Ach die, die war ein bisschen flippig, ne?
Die fand ich super.
Doch.
Ich fand nur irgendwann, wer war denn, der so einen Seitenhieb, da ging es irgendwie um Fotos. Und so, ja, hier Familien-Trip. Also so wie Marketing sich halt eine Familie vorstellt und das ganze Publikum so, oah! Das fand ich einen schönen Seitenhieb, weil ich meine, inzwischen weiß es halt jeder.
Ich fand die Performance super, mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass Apples ja auch schafft, sozusagen von Kino zu Kino immer mehr Diversität aufs Paket zu bringen.
Auf jeden Fall, das finde ich.
War richtig viele Frauen diesmal, ne?
Drei.
Okay, aber bei dem Platforms-Date auch sind noch mal welche.
Ja. Warte mal, ich guck mal. Ich hab's mir nämlich glaub ich notiert. Also es gab, ne, vier. Vier Frauen und sechs Männer. Ist schon mal.
Schon mal gar nicht so verkehrt.
Das ist schon mal ne Ansage, davon halt irgendwie sechs Weiße und eine Schwarze halt.
War überhaupt schon mal ein schwarzer Typ auf der Bühne? Ich kann mich nicht erinnern. Noch nie, ne?
Das war das erste. Also bei einer Apple Keynote.
Aber diese.
Die ist ja von Beats. Die ist erst wenige Monate vor der Akquisition von Apple zu Beats gekommen. Und jetzt ist sie da aber halt die Chefin für Marketing, iTunes, weiß nicht ganz genau, wie der Posten heißt. Und die lebt das irgendwie.
Das war ja wohl auch so in der Sache, oder? Die wollen ja bei ihrer Musik so ein bisschen hip sein. Da kannst du natürlich nicht so eine Schnarchnase hinstellen.
Das haben sie ja probiert mit Eddy Cue. Das war ja ein totales Desaster.
Obwohl ich bei Eddy Cue so ein bisschen bewundere, wie eiskalt der sich zum Deppen macht. Also das ist so...
Ja, aber das muss auch nicht weiter strapaziert werden. Ich meine, der hat mit diesem Craig Federighi mittlerweile den Entertainment... Also ich meine, der holt sich jetzt einfach jedes Mal ein Entertainment-Pokal. Der wird immer cooler.
Ja, der ist cool. Also seid ihr nicht mehr old... Wie war das? Shakehand? Old Shatterhand und dann Air Force One und so weiter. Der ist glaube ich durch die Tiefen schon durch.
Genau, der hat irgendwie einmal alles durch. Und ich meine, auch in seiner Rolle jetzt als Head of Software hat er natürlich auch eine ganze Menge zu überblicken. Das ist schon alles ganz nice orchestriert. Und ich fand auch, die Kino hatte jetzt irgendwie keine...
Sag mal, viel Schiller ist gar nicht aufgetaucht.
Zweite Mal hintereinander. Zweite Mal hintereinander.
Aber er ist ja noch live dabei. Er hat dann diesen Podcast mit dem John Gruber gemacht.
Genau.
Also der ist ja schon noch am Start.
Ja klar, ich meine, der ist ja auch...
Nicht mehr der Jüngste.
Er ist vor allem die treibende Kraft jetzt hinter den Änderungen des Appstores. Und ich bin gespannt, wie weit sie das noch treiben.
Also das könnten wir ja vielleicht zum Ende auch noch mal kurz bringen.
Genau. Zunächst einmal, was sie neu machen, ist dieses Subscription-Modell, was bisher ja nur für bestimmte Apps, nämlich sogenannte Periodicals, also Dinge, die irgendwie regelmäßigen Medieninhalt liefern, gemacht haben. Das öffnen sie jetzt als generelles Konzept für alle Apps im Prinzip, schauen sich aber trotzdem noch mal an, was da genau im Einzelnen dahinter steckt. Es wird da bestimmt Missbross-Potenziale geben, die sie sehen oder die sie missan. Grundsätzlich heißt das aber, dass wenn du jetzt als App-Developer dafür sorgen möchtest, dass Leute langfristig sich an deine App binden und du aber auch einen recurring Revenue hast, dann könntest du dieses Subscription-Modell machen. Das wäre sozusagen das, was Instacast vielleicht hätte retten können. Und der besondere Benefit ist, dass wenn du es schaffst, die Leute länger als ein Jahr zu halten, dann gibt es ab dem zweiten Jahr, zieht der Apple halt nicht mehr 30% von dem Betrag, der eingezogen wird, ab, sondern halt nur noch 15%.
Ubi hat gesagt, das machen wir auch, aber gleich sofort ohne ein Jahr warten.
Was ist denn jetzt mit Instacast-Core oder wie das heißen soll?
Unklar. Kommt vielleicht noch mal raus, vielleicht nicht. Also es gibt halt so eine Beta-Version, die unterwegs ist, die hat aber keine Syncherei mehr.
Ja, ja, ja, das war mir ja klar. Also das war ja der große Grund, warum er das überhaupt aufgegeben hat. Hatt ich das Gefühl.
Ja, vor allem die Cloud. Aber halt auch generell der Stress, die Updates mit den ganzen US-Releases und tausend neue Features und heute Watch und morgen dies und morgen das. Also das kann ich schon verstehen. Naja, das ist halt einfach Stress. Und es war dann halt einfach nicht möglich mit diesen Revenue-Modellen. So, jetzt gibt es das Revenue-Modell. Das heißt halt irgendwie Subscription. Ich denke, dass das für einen guten Podcast-Client auch funktionieren kann. Könnte. Muss man sehen.
Auch für allerlei andere Apps sicherlich auch.
Auch für allerlei andere Apps. In meinem Fall halt für einen Podcast-Client auf jeden Fall. Wenn er denn das bietet, was ich auch haben will, ist natürlich noch mal eine andere Frage. Muss man mal sehen. Ich persönlich finde das immer noch schade, dass man halt keine Apps ausprobieren kann. Dass es nicht so eine Woche Test Drive gibt. Ich weiß gar nicht, was dagegen spricht. Zu viele Downloads oder was?
Ja, aber zu viele Downloads kann es nicht sein. Es gibt so viele Apps da draußen, die irgendwie freemium machen. Die versuchen dich erstmal zu downloaden. Und dann schauen wir mal weiter. Und Apple hat die Infrastruktur.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, inwiefern sie jetzt den Mac App Store aufziehen. Ich habe so den Eindruck, da ist einiges im Busch, dass sie das jetzt verbessern wollen, weil das ist halt scheppig. Also, ich meine, der Mac App Store ist halt nichts.
Ja, sind ja alle rausgegangen aus dem Mac App Store.
Nicht alle, aber es gibt nur sehr wenige wirklich sichtbare.
Alle interessanten.
Ja, so Pixelmeter und sowas ist halt noch drin.
Kann sein, ja. Aber im Prinzip ist es auch nur noch irgendwie Spiele. Wenn du jetzt den App Store aufmachst, dann hast du irgendwie...
Das ist der Grund, warum die das mit dem iCloud-Kit geöffnet haben.
Da hast du irgendwie drei Photo-Retouching-Dinger drin und dann ansonsten nur Spiele. Spiele, Spiele, Spiele, Spiele, Spiele. Stimmt, Pixelmeter ist hier noch.
Ja, die waren halt von Anfang an dabei und die haben irgendwie sozusagen den vollen Winter mitgenommen. Aber es repliziert sich halt nicht unbedingt jetzt für andere Games. Ich meine, du kannst da noch nicht mal Videos previewen, du kannst da irgendwie gar nichts machen. Also das muss sich ändern. Ich vermute mal, da wird sich auch irgendwas ändern. Aber das ist dann irgendwie nicht unser Thema.
Ja, noch nicht.
Noch nicht. So, Wrap-Up?
Ich hab noch was.
Watt denn?
Hier mit den Bitcoins. Davon abgesehen, dass die eine ganz schöne Achterbahnfahrt hingelegt haben in den letzten ein, zwei Wochen. Wobei sie jetzt gerade eher auf dem Weg nach unten sind.
Oh, jetzt geht's schon wieder runter. War das nicht gestern was mit 700 Euro?
Ne, 700 nicht, 680 war irgendwie das Höchste, glaube ich. Das war vor ein paar Tagen. Jetzt ist es wieder bei 5,56. Es sinkt heute ein bisschen schneller, aber sonst eigentlich relativ langsam. Also ist jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm. Aber darum geht's eigentlich auch gar nicht so richtig. Sondern ich habe ja schon oft erzählt, dass ich so einen Bitcoin-Pool habe, wo man sein Mining betreiben kann, ohne dass man 10 Jahre wartet, bis man mal einen Blog findet. Und aus, wie soll man sagen, dem ist sein Funding ausgelaufen. Das heißt, der Pool hat so lange keine Bitcoins mehr gefunden, oder die User haben keine Bitcoins mehr gefunden, keinen Blog gefunden, so gesagt, dass ich keinen mehr auszahlen kann. Deswegen habe ich den schon vor zwei, drei Wochen ausgemacht. Ich hätte das in der letzten Sendung leider vergessen, dass da noch was war. Und der ist jetzt sozusagen aus. Ich habe jetzt auch keine Statistik in den Kopf, weil ich habe schon lange nicht mehr so richtig drauf geguckt, aber ich habe knapp 390 Blöcke gefunden. Kann man sich an Bitcoins umrechnen, wie viel das war. Das ist schon eine ordentliche Summe, die da durchging. Nein, ein Blog waren ja früher 50 Bitcoins, und jetzt seit irgendwie dreieinhalb Jahren oder fast vier sind es ja nur noch 25 Bitcoins. Wobei ich sagen muss, die meisten meiner Blöcke waren noch aus den 50-Bitcoins-Zeiten, weil danach war die Difficulty so schwierig, da hab ich gar nicht mehr viel gefunden. Also, das kann man sicher mal durchrechnen, wie viel das so war, aber das hab ich jetzt auch gerade nicht so richtig Bock. Aber weil der jetzt sozusagen aus ist, gibt's jetzt, alle Leute haben natürlich dann auf Payout gedrückt, was ja auch okay ist, aber der Pool hatte keine Bitcoins mehr. Das heißt, ich muss demnächst da vonhand nochmal, das ist gar nicht wie einen halben Bitcoin, draufschieben, weil die haben ja alle so eine Mini-Summe, die sie da abheben, weil das halt sehr schwierig war, noch Geld irgendwie mit Mining zu generieren, deswegen sind das alles 0,01 Bitcoin, was die Leute so kriegen. Das heißt, ich schieb da mal einen halben Bitcoin drauf oder so, dann noch nicht mal vielleicht, und dann kann ich die restlichen Auszahle machen. Also, die müssen sich da keine Sorgen machen, da kommt demnächst wieder Geld rein und dann wird der Rest ausgezahlt. So, dann gibt's noch Leute, ich hab's gerade mal so durchgerechnet, so circa sind so 18.500 Bitcoins. Wenn man das jetzt nochmal, den aktuellen Kurs von 555 Euro nimmt, sind das 10 Millionen, die ich da so durchgeschoben hab, theoretisch, in der Theorie.
10 Millionen was?
Euro.
Echt? Durchgeschoben an andere Leute? Und du, Arma Schlucker, für dich ist es nicht so ruhig geblieben.
Bisschen. Das größte war übrigens hier dieser Bot, der da irgendwie abkassiert hat. Ich glaube, der hat alleine 6000 Bitcoins irgendwie sich auszahlen lassen. Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher über die Zeit. Ist egal. So, dann gibt es jedenfalls noch eine Sperre, dass man sich ja nicht weniger als 0,01 Bitcoin auszahlen lassen kann bei meinem Pool, damit die Leute nicht immer diese ganzen ultraminisumme auszahlen. Da jetzt natürlich nichts mehr dazukommt, weil das Mining aus ist, werde ich diese Sperre demnächst aufheben. Und dann können die Leute natürlich einfach immer auf Payout drücken, egal wie viel sie noch haben, damit jeder sozusagen die Restfennige, die da noch rumliegen, dass sie sich das dann halt auszahlen können. Hab ich noch keine Zeit gehabt. Ich hatte ein bisschen zu tun, letzte Woche familiemäßig. Aber es kommt irgendwie noch. Aber jedenfalls, der Pool ist jetzt aus. In zwei Wochen wäre der 5. Jahrestag gewesen, weil ich hab genau 1. Juli 2011 angefangen. Ist ein bisschen schade, dass ich ihn vorher ausmachen musste, aber es war irgendwie abzusehen, dass da jetzt nichts mehr reinkommt und dass man dann, wenn man in die Richtung Miese geht, dass man dann halt mal ausmachen muss. Und ist halt jetzt so weit. Aber hat irgendwie Spaß gemacht, hab was gelernt. Find ich fast schade, dass es nicht weiterläuft, aber es geht halt nun mal nicht. Und ja, so war's.
So war's und so werden wir es immer in Erinnerungen behalten.
Ja, das ist glaube ich der zweitlängste Pool, den es gab bis jetzt vor kurzem. Der einzige, der noch älter ist, ist dieser von Slush, die auch diesen Tresor irgendwie machen, diese Hardware-Wallet, sonst alle anderen Pools, wenn es überhaupt noch welche gibt, sind alle jünger, alle anderen sind weg, sind verschwunden. Haben die ganzen Chinesen alles plattgemacht mit ihrem Self-Mining oder was auch immer, die da so betreiben.
So, ich bin durch. Vielleicht noch ein Hinweis, nächste Freak Show gibt's schon nächste Woche. Wir ziehen die nächsten Termine mal eine Woche vor, weil sonst geht sich das irgendwie mit allen möglichen anderen Terminen nicht aus. Mal gucken, in welcher lustigen Konstellation wir hier nächste Woche sitzen. Jetzt haben wir halt mal WWDC durchgekaut, ist auch gut. Und dann können wir uns wieder den nicht Apple-Themen widmen.
Ja, ich kann jetzt schon sagen, ich kann nicht so.
Das ist immer eine neue Mischung. Das wird alles ganz neu, ganz anders.
Und außerdem hat Italien gegen Irland verloren und Schweden gegen Belgien.
Ja, das läuft.
Und Ibrahimovic, der hat ja sein letztes Spiel gemacht. Der hat gesagt, nach der EM hört er auf. Das war dann heute sein letztes Spiel.
Nee.
Portugal gegen Kroatien, Deutschland gegen Slowakei.
Also wenn wir immer Profifußballer werden...
Wales gegen Nordirland. Ich glaube, dieses Spiel muss man sehen, oder?
Es sind vor allem alle Mannschaften von der Insel weitergekommen. Aber ich meine, wenn bei 24 dann irgendwie nach drei Spielen gerade mal sechs Mannschaften ausscheiden, muss man sich auch nicht wundern, wenn noch irgendwie alle dabei sind.
Das stimmt, es scheiden ja gar nicht viele aus.
Das ist vollkommen bekloppt.
Nee, was? Sechs? Acht?
Die vier besten Dritten kommen weiter.
Sechs Gruppen, aber vier Mannschaften sind 24 Mannschaften.
Ja, aber du hast sechs Vierte und noch mal zwei Dritte, die ausscheiden.
Hä, aber sechs mal vier sind 24 und es bleiben 60 übrig.
Es kommen 16 weiter, so viel brauchen wir nicht.
Aber dann fliegen noch acht raus.
Fliegen acht raus, ja sag ich ja.
Was hab ich gesagt?
Ach schon, also sie fliegen sechs Mal vierter Platz raus und zwei von den Drittplätzen sind acht. Aber wenn wir mal Profi-Fußballer werden, dann kündigt man natürlich vorher nicht an, weil man aufhört, sondern man macht ein richtig gutes Spiel und dann sagt man mal nicht auf, damit einem so ein Unfall wie dem Ibrahimovic da heute nicht passiert. Damit man mich nicht mit der Lage aufhört. Das heißt, wenn wir hier unseren Podcast mal beenden, dann auch mit einer coolen Sendung, wir kündigen das vorher nicht an, sondern wir entscheiden, das war jetzt cool und dann sagen wir, das war's. Wie heißt er denn sonst? Du weißt ja wenig, mein Slutern.
Ja, doch, ja, Ibrahimovic. Ich kann schon gar nicht mehr denken irgendwie.
Lesen anscheinend auch nicht.
Nee, doch, hast recht.
Ich dachte, du bist hier Fußballfan, nur ein Dauercard und du kannst doch noch einen drauflegen. Anscheinend nicht so wirklich.
Ich kann so selbstverliebte Superstars auf den Tod nicht ausstehen.
Bist du so? Aber der geht doch noch.
Nee, der ist so auf einem Level wie Ronaldo. Ja. Ich meine, wer sich selber als Genie und Gott und Held und was nicht alles bezeichnet, hat schon ein bisschen einer Klatsche. Ich meine, ich kann ja verstehen, wenn man in so einer Situation ist, dass man dann irgendwie total durchbrennt.
Dass man einer einer Klatsche hat.
Aber manchmal ein bisschen Bodenhaftung. Tut auch solchen Großverdienern mal ganz gut.
Hat eigentlich der Gomez auch einer einer Klatsche?
Die sind alle ganz bescheiden mit ihren geringen Einkommen. Kann ja nicht jeder so einen Sausen Braus leben wie die Podcaster. Leute, weißt du, was wir machen? Wir machen Schluss.
Das war's.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kriegt David sogar noch ein Intro hin innerhalb von einer Woche. Der sitzt jetzt wahrscheinlich schon aufrecht im Bett. Wir werden sehen. Bis dahin sagen wir erstmal Tschüss, viel Spaß mit allem, was ihr so treibt und tut.